März 2011.
Da hat sich was getan.
Da hat sich was getan, ja.
Also alle, die berichten, sagen Slappy, Snappy, Snappy.
Das ist ein fantastischer Computer und das merken glaube ich gerade auch eine ganze Menge.
Das ganze Internet ist von diesem Eindruck überzeugt, das flutscht einfach.
Also mittlerweile glaube ich ja sogar daran, dass Apple in der Lage ist, diesen PC-Markt auch noch zu übernehmen.
12 Monate später.
Ich wollte überhaupt in meinem Leben immer nur einen einzigen Computer.
Den besten.
Alle anderen interessieren mich gar nicht.
Wenn Apple der Meinung ist, sie müssen den jetzt nicht mehr bauen, dann ergibt sich da eine Opportunity für andere Menschen mit klarem Kopf.
Ich hab Angst. Nein, ich hab einfach sofort diese ganze Scheißkasse.
Ich hab noch nie in so einem schlechten Computer gearbeitet, wie alles, was unter Leiden läuft.
Das ist furchtbar.
Und ich hab einfach Angst, dass dieser Firma, der schon mal da war, mich wieder in diese 10-1-Base zurückdreht.
Ich will jetzt überhaupt noch, wenn man jetzt überhaupt einen Scheiß bewerben soll, dafür.
Ich kann gar nicht so viel Scheißen nicht werfen.
Herzlich willkommen bei Bum Zag Return.
Das muss so ein bisschen ausfäden, oder die Musik, das muss so.
Aber sag mal, ist die neu?
Die ist neu, die hab ich gerade noch zugeschickt bekommen.
Weil ich hör mich jetzt öfter zack sagen. Früher war ich da weniger drin, glaub ich.
Ja, irgendwie klingt die neu, ne? Hört man uns? Kann man uns hören?
Also ich glaub, ich bin immer noch nicht dabei. Bumm, zack.
Nee, du bist immer noch nicht dabei.
Du musst in so einer Sendung das öfter mal raushören, bis er genug Verarbeitungsmaterial hat und dann kann man dich da auch mal festiefen.
Ich hab noch kein Outro. Das kommt noch während der Sendung. Ja, das war eben gerade mit dem kurzen Loch im Screen, das war so meine Doofheit, weil ich wollte schon mal ganz elegant das Quicktime-Fenster wechseln, um dann auf die nächste Musik schön schnell umschalten zu können und hatte vergessen, dass hier der Quicktime-7-Player in dem Hintergrund die Musik ausmacht und musste dann schnell wieder zurückswitchen.
Kann man das nicht ausschalten?
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich glaub, beim neuen Quicktime-Player ist es einfach nicht mehr so. Man könnte einfach den... Egal. Ja, Tim ist im Urlaub. Ach, britzelts wieder. Tim ist im Urlaub. Das heißt, wir machen heute und darum tanzen wir jetzt auf den Tischen und machen jetzt hier zu dritt die Sendung. Die Sendung ist leider unerwartet erkrankt. Kurz vor wenigen Minuten hat er vielleicht auch nur Panik bekommen und Tim stößt.
Er hat die Erlang-Krankheit bekommen oder so?
Nee, er meinte irgendwas von, keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich Erlang.
Er fühlt sich nicht.
Er fühlt sich nicht. Der Arme. Gute Besserungswünsche von hier. Und Tim stößt vielleicht nachher noch per Skype zu, sobald er gegessen hat, in einer Stunde ungefähr. Mal gucken.
Gegessen?
Ja, bis dahin sollten wir eigentlich so Themen wie Kalender und Line und sowas hinter uns haben.
Früher war mehr Kalender.
Ja.
Jetzt müsste eigentlich Tim was sagen, oder?
Ja, normalerweise sagt dann Tim immer was, was wir als nächstes machen.
Was hatten wir vor zwei Wochen? Ich kann mich gar nicht mehr erinnern.
Ich mich ehrlich gesagt auch nicht.
Ach so, ihr habt doch hoffentlich über das iPad geredet, ohne eins zu haben, oder?
Wir sind nochmal die Liste durchgegangen, aber da wir ja auch selber gar keins hatten.
Das können wir jetzt ändern, ne? Ich meine mittlerweile gibt es ja welche. Ich hab meins auch schon sogar hier, dass ich...
Hooray, das Studio hat eins da.
Ja, wir haben eins da.
Wir haben alles in Bewegung gesetzt.
Genau, das ist keine Kosten und irgendwas gescheuert.
Genau.
Und haben eins geholt. Und ja, was soll ich sagen? Das Display ist so, wie man es sich vorstellt, sehr geil. Das macht echt Laune. Das ist so Schrift und so, das ist wesentlich besser. Es gab ja so im Netz diverse Aufregerthemen, wie zum Beispiel, dass es warm wird. Und es wird warm mitunter, aber das ist jetzt nicht schlimm.
Wow, fünf Grad mehr als vorher. Immer noch unter 50.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich es bemerkt hätte, wenn ich mich nicht immer drauf hingewiesen hätte.
Nö, wird es erst, wenn auf der Rückseite Kupferlamellen sind.
Also Lifter hinten drauf hängen.
Und Kupfer.
Goldkontakte.
Aber ich hab da eine Idee. Also da ist ja, weil ich das richtig verstanden hab, eine Batterie drin, die haben die ja ordentlich größer gemacht, weil dieses Displayer und dieses Quad-Ding.
Nee, nicht ganz doppelt so groß.
Doch, mehr als doppelt so viel Ladung.
Von 25 auf 42 oder sowas, oder?
18 oder so.
Nicht ganz verdoppelt war es, glaube ich. Aber mehr als ein 11er MacBook Air.
Und jetzt stellt euch vor, weil so Displays sind ja auch, wenn die das da anliefern, die haben ja, also bei den MacBooks ist es ja auch so, die haben ja teilweise so auch Standardanschlüsse. Jetzt könnte so ein findiger Hacker daherkommen, ihr wisst was, jetzt kommt er, und das einer, der nicht so gut gucken kann, sagen wir mal, nimmt das neue Display raus, packt wieder das alte rein, hat aber diese fette Batterie, hat voll die Grafik Power und dann hält sein Ding 20 Stunden oder 15.
Ich glaube, da musste eher das, also das Display austauschen, das haben sie ja probiert.
Ja, und ging nicht, oder?
Das haben sie hier bei iFixit gemacht, das hat aber nicht geklappt.
Naja, schade.
Die hatten ja so eins aus dieser Vorsäe, die da aufgetaucht sind. Aber was natürlich klappen könnte, dass man einfach die neuen Akkus an das alte, an die alte Elektronik anschließt intern.
Ja, aber da ist wahrscheinlich kein Platz für den neuen Akku, weil der Akku ist ja auch größer, ne? Ja, muss ja irgendwo herkommen.
Muss das neue Gehäuse nehmen.
Das neue Gehäuse ist ja gleich groß.
Nee, der ist ein bisschen dicker.
Aber der Akku ist ja nicht nur höher, sondern der ist doch bestimmt auch breiter und so, oder?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ich hab's auch nicht aufgemacht.
Ich glaub nicht, dass es nur für den Akku, diesen halben Millimeter, da könnte natürlich auch sein.
Ich glaub schon. Und ein bisschen schwerer ist es.
Also ich weiß, dass ein Kumpel mal sich irgendwie, gab's neue IBM, jetzt heißen ja Lenovo, Rechner rauskamen und da war nicht mehr das schicke große, die hatten ja 1920 mal irgendwas. Und dann hat er sich halt irgendwie gebraucht, glaube ich, oder als Ersatzteil irgendwie dieses riesen Display besorgt mit der schicken Auflösung. Hat bei seinem neuen das kleinere rausgebaut und das neuere reingehangen irgendwie so. Und war dann happy und das hat funktioniert. Und die werden automatisch erkannt irgendwie von der Auflösung her und das geht wohl.
Ich hab ja mal bei einem Powerbook G4, bei so einem Titanium, habe ich mal das Display ausgewechselt.
Das hab ich auch mal gemacht.
Es ging danach noch an.
Das war eins mit einer anderen Auflösung?
Genau, ich hab nämlich beim Ebay-Kauf demlicherweise nicht drauf geachtet, dass ich auch dieselbe Auflösung hatte. Das Display hat perfekt reingepasst, war alles überhaupt kein Problem, aber nach dem Einschalten hat es plötzlich eine geringere Auflösung.
Okay, aber es hat funktioniert.
Es hat funktioniert ungefähr eine Woche lang und danach war es kaputt.
Okay, aber es lag ja nicht daran, oder?
Nee, das lag nicht daran. Das lag an meiner Unfähigkeit, dieses Ding wieder zu sehen.
Also man könnte sowas schon machen, theoretisch.
Ich hab da den ganzen Deckel ausgetauscht. Also ein Freund von mir, der hat das Ding irgendwie gehabt und hat das Display kaputt gemacht. Und irgendwie hat dann relativ lange mit kaputtem Display weitergearbeitet, weil irgendwie nur unten so doppeltaumelnbereit halt nichts zu sehen war. Und ein anderer Freund von mir, der hatte seinen G4 völlig auf irgendwie, da war die Hauptplatine kaputt und diverse andere Dinge funktionierten nicht mehr nach hartem Einsatz. Und dann hab ich dem das Display abgeschwatzt und dann haben wir das getauscht. Und danach ging alles wieder.
Das war so schmerzhaft. Ich war damals total pleite und konnte mir darum keinen neuen Rechner leisten. Beziehungsweise musste ich dann im Endeffekt doch tun, aber wollte ich halt umgehen, diesen Kraftakt. Und das war wirklich, was war denn das? Dann hatte ich das Ding. Die Hintergrundbeleuchtung war kaputt von dem Powerbook. Also das Display an sich ging noch einwandfrei. Das hatte ich dann auch überlegt, ob man das dann eventuell noch irgendwo als so sich ein Beamer selber bauen kann oder sowas. Und dann nach dem Austausch habe ich dann gesehen, warum die Hintergrundbeleuchtung nicht mehr ging, weil das Kabel nämlich durchgeschubbert war. Also man hätte wahrscheinlich durch einen Kabelauswechsel das Display reparieren können. Wusste ich aber nicht. Aber dieses Ding zu zerlegen, da musste ich ja wirklich einmal komplett die gesamte Platine rausnehmen. Und ich bin dabei sowas echt nicht gut. Denn ich hatte am Ende auch drei Schrauben mehr als vorher. Und das war kein Spaß. Das mache ich nie wieder. So PCs, da bastle ich ja noch selber dran rum. Aber so ab Macbook oder dann iPhone, da gehe ich einfach nicht mehr ran.
Bei iPhone habe ich schon zweimal irgendwie dieses Teil ausgewechselt, wo Kopfhörer-Buchse, Sleep-Wake-Button, Mute-Button, Laut-Leiser-Button dranhängt.
Du hast MS-Pro auch mal das Display ausgetauscht, ne?
Ich habe MS-Pro auch mal das Display ausgetauscht. Ja, das war sehr lustig.
Kannst du das normal machen, jetzt ist dein iPhone 4 jetzt wieder runtergeschlossen.
Ja, ich hab's gesehen.
Wolltest du nicht bei meinem iPhone 4 auch die Ein- und Ausschalt-Taste reparieren? Geht nicht mehr. Also ich muss halt voll doll drücken, damit es irgendwie... Ey, du hast mich angerufen. Wo hin? Damit...
Welche Pizza du haben wolltest.
Verstehe. Da war ich schon unterwegs. Ne, mein, da geht nicht mehr. Ich meine wahrscheinlich, ich kaufe mir demnächst Herbst, später Sommer, eh das Fünfer. Sind zwei Jahr rum, muss man ja Neues holen.
Ja, das kann ja nicht mehr lange dauern.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, ich finde das schon immer noch ganz schön schick und...
Ja, die entsprechenden Ersatzteile sind auch wirklich ziemlich günstig auf Ebay. Also 12, 10 oder 15 oder so. Und dann musst du halt einbauen. Das ist echt ein Schmerz.
Ich hab das schon mal so ein bisschen auseinandergenommen. Ich bin noch schon relativ weit gekommen. Meine Batterie ist jetzt nicht mehr festgeklebt, sondern hab ich schon alles entfernt. Aber das mit den Schrauben, da braucht man ja auch. Ich dachte, ich hab zu Hause so ein Schrauben, so ein Uhrenmacher-Set, ja, das war klar zu groß. Also du brauchst echt so feines Zeug, dass du denkst, äh, Wahnsinn, also.
Genau, du hast unten auch noch die normalen Kreuzschlitz hier.
Genau, da hab ich auch gelesen, da gibt's jetzt diese neueren Phillips-Dinger, oder wie die heißen.
Ich hab nämlich auch diese anderen schon.
So, komische Fünfeckige, sehen aus wie Torx, haben wir aber noch.
Diese Größe musst du ja auch erstmal rankriegen. Das ist auch Werkzeug, das darfst du nicht liegen. Wenn das runterfällt und mit der Spitze aufkommt, dann ist das Ding ja wahrscheinlich gleich komplett verbogen, so dünn ist das. Als letztes hier mit einem iPhone 4, ihr habt alle schon 4S-Schweinerei.
Na wartet. Da muss man auch echt Nerven haben, weil irgendwann hast du das Gefühl, du hast nur noch Wurstfinger. Du wurstfingerst an dieser Technik rum. Weil das ist alles so klein.
Also das Gefühl, was man schon bei der Bedienung hat, hat man dann auch beim Zerlegen.
Du hast keine Vorstellung.
Viel, viel schlimmer.
Wenn die Schraube so auf dem Tisch liegt. Normalerweise ist es so, dass du mit einem Zeigefinger und einem Daumen so eine Schraube nehmen willst. Aber Zeigefinger, Daumen zusammen hast, ist dazwischen noch ein kleiner Spalt. Und dazwischen ist die Schraube. Du kannst sie gar nicht mit den Fingern hochheben. So klein sind die. Du kannst sie auch nicht zwischen die Finger nehmen und da reinsetzen. Weil wenn du die zwischen die Finger nimmst, dann ist die Schraube nicht mehr zu sehen, weil die ist dann weg. Du kannst sie nicht mit deinen Fingern da reinsetzen. Oder du machst wieder deinen Schraubenzieher ganz minimal nass, weil die Schrauben sind so klein, dass sie schon durch die Haftung an sich an diesen Wassertropfen oder an dieser feuchten Schraubenzieher-Spitze kleben bleiben. Also so leicht sind die.
Was ich empfehlen kann, ist, dass man sich auf jeden Fall erst den Guide bei FX-it runterlädt. Und dass man dann am besten noch Crap-Papier hat und sich zu jedem Arbeitsschritt aufschreibt, welche Schrauben mit welcher Farbe in diesem Arbeitsschritt genau da rauskamen. Und man nimmt dann immer das Crap-Papier und klebt das dann auf den Zettel drauf. Neben der Beschriftung, das sind jetzt die Orangenschrauben aus Schritt 6 und so weiter. Und dann kommt man relativ gut durch.
Ja, habe ich so ähnlich gemacht, aber ich habe zu Hause so eine Plastekisten, wo so zehn Fächer sind, so zweimal fünf in Reihe, weil ganze Elektronik-Kram, den ich auf Widerstände zeugt, das habe ich immer in so kleinen Kistchen. Und da mache ich dann immer einfach nach dem anderen irgendwie, damit die halt kannst du genau in der Reihenfolge, da machst du sie rein und holst sie auch rückwärts dann wieder raus. Und sonst ist es schon übel, ja. Also vor allem, wenn dir so ein Ding auch mal runterfällt, ich meine, das fängst du nun nie wieder. Also echt keine Chance.
Deswegen sage ich ja Krepppapier und gleich auf dem Festkleben.
Das hatte ich, da hatte ich kein Krepppapier, hatte ich nicht, aber ich hatte mir so das ausgedruckt und dann so zurechtgelegt auch und als ich das bei meinem MacBook Pro noch das Super Drive ausgeschmissen habe und dafür eine zweite Festplatte bzw. dann da so ein Optibay eingebaut habe. Und da hatte ich so geschwitzt vor Angst, also vor An-Konzentration, dass ich die ganze Zeit aufpassen musste, dass es nicht in den offenen Rechner reintropft. So, hier gibt's... Ach guck mal, da hat jemand hier tatsächlich im Chat jetzt hier so Screwdrivers fürs iPhone.
Ja, bis die dann hier in Europa angekommen sind aus Amerika, ist das 5 Mal schon draußen.
Naja, aber nicht mehr das Bild. Oh, da haben sie aber ganz ordentlich...
Mit Ersatzteilen sogar, oder wie?
Und wie viel Shipping?
Ey, was ist denn das hier? Wieso kann ich das Fenster nicht größer machen? Das ist ja tatsächlich Tims Rechner. Kommen sie zum Tims Rechner schon, gehen in Safari, die Fenster sind nicht mehr größer.
Der hatte noch nie Computronen.
Ah, aber es geht hier nicht an der Seite. Jetzt geht's wieder, wenn man es einmal... Ach, egal. So, ja.
Du musst noch mal sagen, weil du gerade beim Fenster vergrößern bist. Wir sind ja nur mal die wilden Jungs, wir quatschen immer rein. Deswegen, ich halt mich einfach dran. Ich hab gestern so eine alte Kiste neu aufgesetzt und dann hat er einen 10.3 gebootet. Und da musste ich erstmal überraschenderweise feststellen, Feilvolt gab's schon unter 10.3. Ich dachte, es wäre mit 10.4 gekommen. Also Nummer so in den Mai hat mich überrascht. Aber ansonsten, ich dachte mal, ich gewöhn mich nicht dran, dass man an allen Ecken und Enden hier scrollen, also das Fenster vergrößern kann. Ich dachte mal, so ein Windows-Schnickschnack braucht doch keiner. Und ich muss sagen, ich hab's gestern sofort irgendwie vermisst, weil ich hab mich doch ganz schön doll dran gewöhnt. Also es war sozusagen eine gute Entscheidung, dass Apple das gemacht hat. Ich war am Anfang nicht so überzeugt. Dass man an allen Ecken und Fenster, an jeder Richtung und die Ecken und so, dass man da resize kann.
Das braucht man auf jeden Fall. Das finde ich tatsächlich auch sehr angemeldet.
Am Anfang dachte ich, das ist doch Blödsinn und das stört auch manchmal, dass dann jetzt, da muss ich immer zwischen scrollen und resize muss man genau aufpassen, was da kommt und so. Aber ich benutze es anscheinend doch so oft, dass ich es gestern vermisst habe unter 10.3.
Eines der Tools, warte mal, jetzt kann man ja nochmal hier empfehlen quasi. Eines der Tools, was ich neulich entdeckt habe, das war, und zwar, es gibt ja unter, das ist ja unter Windows 7 eines dieser guten Features ist, dass man Fenster, wenn man es oben an den Bildschirmrand klatscht, dass es dann so quasi in Fullscreen-Modus geht. Also, dass es komplett größer hat. Und dann haben sie das gleich nochmal mit linke Bildschirmhälfte und rechte Bildschirmhälfte. Kannst du jeweils gegenhalten.
Von welchem Windows reden wir denn?
Was kann man, warte, also okay, nach oben ist klar, Fullscreen und links und rechts hab ich grad nicht verstanden.
Links und rechts ist so linke Bildschirmhälfte, rechte Bildschirmhälfte. Also, das ist so einmal, das ist so die linke Bildschirmhälfte einnimmt komplett das Fenster, wenn man es an den linken Rand klatscht, an den rechten Rand klatscht, an die rechte Bildschirmhälfte und da hatte ich hier ewig lange, wie heißt das, nicht SCART, sondern wie so ein anderes Kabel. Nee, es gibt so ein Kabel.
Ach, SCART.
Nicht HDMI, sondern wie heißt das?
S-Video.
S-ge, S-ge, S-ge, S-ge, S-ge.
Das hat das gemacht, damit war ich aber nie so richtig zufrieden. Und was ich jetzt ausprobiert habe, es hat zwar ein unglaublich hässliches Icon, aber es funktioniert ganz und gar hervorragend. Das heißt Better Snap Tool. Und damit kann man für kostet 1,59.
Lass das nicht den Andreas Hegenberg hören, dass sein Icon hässlich ist.
Ist aber ein tolles Tool. Andreas Hegenberg.
Ich finde das Icon gar nicht so hässlich.
Na ja, das steht hier als Autor, als Entwickler.
Ich muss jetzt mal, und das ist so, was ist das für ein dämlicher Link? Na toll, jetzt hab ich hier einen Link reinkopiert und dann passiert hier nichts, sondern zack.
Tja, so ist das mit diesem Scheiß.
So ist das mit diesem langsamen... Das wäre ja, wenn man an diesem Rechner sitzt, dann wird man zum Affen.
Manche Sachen sind echt antiproduktiv, oder? Auch da willst du eine Ull kopieren und dann macht er nur den Text hin.
Aber da hab ich das komplett reingeschmissen.
Das ist halt ein intelligentes Ull.
Genau, kümmer dich mal ein bisschen darum. Du sitzt hier nicht ganz so aufverzweifelt da. Und das macht auf jeden Fall sehr viel... Das macht auf jeden Fall... Es ist so ein ganz gutes Kultur, wenn man Sachen auf den gesamten Bildschirm bringen will. Funktioniert auch mit einem Zwei-Monitor-Setup.
Was hat das jetzt mit diesen Kabeln zu tun? Und meintest du Chinch?
Chinch? Ich meinte das... Chinch heißt die F, die ich meinte. Das war das Tool, was ich vorher dafür genommen habe.
Auch sehr schick.
Das Tool hieß so wie so ein Kabel. Jetzt haben wir den Bogen.
Und ich konnte es nie neu starten, wenn ich es mal neu starten wollte. Es hieß so wie Skat-Kabel, aber ein anderes Kabel.
Wenn ich mal kurz besser wissen darf, Chinch ist ein Stecker und kein Kabel.
Ach egal.
Ich kaufe auch Chinch-Kabel. Man kann es wirklich zu Tode konfigurieren, kann alles einstellen und kann auch einstellen, dass wenn man auf den Button klickt auf die Ampel, dass da irgendwas anderes passiert, als normal passiert.
Wo will ich das wirklich?
Naja, ich meine hier den grünen Zoom-Button, da irgendwas anderes drauf zu haben, ist glaube ich gar nicht so verkehrt. Funktioniert dummerweise nicht bei Carbon-Apps. Also man kann...
Sagtest du gerade Carbon-Apps? Ich muss jetzt hier den Tim geben.
Die iTunes Runtime Engine. Die iTunes Sandbox.
iTunes OS.
Ach ja, jetzt ziehe ich einfach mein Thema. Ich mach jetzt mein Thema.
Warst du fertig mit deinem iPad eigentlich? Mit dem iPad? Ja, wir sind da so ein bisschen abgekommen.
Ach stimmt, wir waren ja ganz am Anfang, dass ich total vergessen aufzuschreiben, dass wir ja auch das iPad hatten.
Wir haben es kurz erwähnt. Wahrscheinlich wissen es eher alle jetzt.
Ja, genau. Also ich hab mein altes, sieht man auch ganz deutlich, ich hab mein altes Cover behalten. Das funktioniert ganz hervorragend. Es gibt wohl irgendwie Probleme bei bestimmten älteren Covern.
Ja, ich weiß auch warum.
Weil die Magneten umgedreht haben, ne?
Ja, genau.
Ich glaube, haben die die Markt, also es geht wohl mit einigen und mit anderen geht es nicht.
Die haben irgendwann bei den Covern, haben sie die Polarität eines ganz bestimmten Magneten umgedreht, der dafür zuständig ist, irgendwie Sleep-Wake zu betätigen. Und bei den ganz alten Covern, da ist der Magnet eben noch andersrum.
Und die funktionieren aber bei den ganz alten iPads trotzdem, oder nicht?
Bei iPad 2 ist es nicht so wichtig. Weil das iPad 2 nur auf den Magnet reagiert, aber nicht auf die Polarität des Magneten. Und das 3. iPad 3 reagiert wohl auf die Polarität des Magneten. Und wenn der nicht stimmt, dann funktioniert der Magnet nicht. Wenn man das aufschneidet und den Magnet umdreht, was man jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt will, aber man könnte es tun, dann geht's wieder.
Man kann auch zum Apple Store gehen und es einfach umtauschen. Machen sogar, dass ich anscheinend los.
Das ist wahrscheinlich die bessere Methode, ja.
Ja, das ist, ansonsten ist es halt, ja, es ist ein bisschen schwerer. Ich hatte es schlimmer mir vorgestellt, weil ich dachte so, hey, das ist so zwischen iPad 1 und iPad 2, so vom Gewicht her. Und das iPad 1 war mir eigentlich schon immer ein bisschen zu schwer. Das iPad 2 fand ich sehr gut, aber das iPad 3 dachte ich, ja, nö, passt. Also es gibt es nicht zu meckern. Man muss ewig den Akku laden.
Ja, der ist ja auch ein bisschen größer, ne?
Ist das wirklich so krass, also mit dem ewig Akku laden? Also es wird überall nur gestöhnt?
Also ich hab bisher nur über Nacht geladen. Aber ich hatte es vorhin als R-Display genutzt, um ein zweites Display zu haben. Hab so lange das iPad per USB geladen. Und ich hab das Gefühl, dass es jetzt leerer ist als vorher. Also er schafft am USB nicht genügend Strom. Und hier am gepowerten USB vom MacBook, also der ein bisschen mehr Strom liefert, schafft er nicht genügend Strom, um auch nur den Akku zu halten. Also ja, das ist schon am Rand der Technik. Und wisst ihr, was meine Theorie ist? Ich bin ja jetzt, nachdem ich die Photoshop-Wette nur so knapp, also eigentlich ja doch ein bisschen gewonnen hatte hier mit iPad und Photoshop. Ich sage ja, dass in ein oder zwei Jahren kommt ein iPad mit Intel-Prozessor. Statt arm.
Glaube ich nicht.
Dazu müsste Intel überhaupt erst mal einen Prozessor liefern, der das könnte.
Die machen jetzt ja schon die ersten Attempts so für Telefone. Die sind, glaube ich, also ist jetzt mal gucken, was rauskommt, kann natürlich auch total in die Hose gehen. Aber so der Gedanke war, offensichtlich ist das Problem bei den Dingern, ist nicht schon lang nicht mehr der Prozessor, sondern ist der 4G-Chip und ist das Display und ist die Grafikkarte und dieses ganze Zeug. Und ob da jetzt noch ein bisschen anderer Prozessor drinne ist.
Also beim iPad 3 ist es definitiv die Hintergrundbeleuchtung. Sagen zumindest die Leute, wenn man das Teil dunkler macht, hält es länger.
Ja, aber es ist wohl irgendwie...
Ja, aber das 2 erhält auch länger, wenn man es dunkler macht.
Ja, aber beim 3er ist es wohl noch krasser.
Die müssen doppelt so viele LEDs wohl.
Ja, ne, vor allen Dingen die...
Die Gesamtherdigkeit muss auch funktionieren.
Die LEDs sind kleiner. Also die Fläche, durch die Licht scheint, also im Verhältnis zu der Fläche, wo Leiter sind, wo kein Licht durchkommt, ist irgendwie kleiner geworden. Deswegen muss da hinterher mehr Licht gemacht werden, dass auch genug Licht durchkommt.
Also diese TFT-Kraftwelle?
Ja, genau, diese Fensterchen, wo es Licht durchgeht. Man sieht das auf diesen Großaufnahmen auch relativ deutlich, dass die relativ klein sind.
Man kann es ja ganz simpel erklären, für die Leute, die es visuell brauchen, wir haben ein Fenster und da kommt eine gewisse Menge Licht durch. Und wenn wir das Fensterkreuz reinmachen, sodass wir vier kleine Fenster haben, dann ist an der Stelle, wo das Fensterkreuz ist, kommt halt kein Licht mehr durch.
Das ist zwar vier kleine Fenster, wenn das Fensterkreuz sehr dick ist.
Egal wie dick es ist, aber es kommt auf jeden Fall weniger durch. Genauso muss man sich das mit den Pixeln vorstellen. Die haben die Pixel einfach nochmal im Fensterkreuz reingemacht.
Ich glaube, so im Großen und Ganzen kommt das hin. Aber ansonsten, das Display ist wirklich gigantisch. Es klingt immer doof, aber man kriegt es erst mit, wenn man es auf einem eigenen Gerät hat. Ich habe von Linus Neumann, also hier, den mit Tim, diesen Netzpolitik-Podcast, ist nicht der Netzpolitik-Podcast, wie heißt dieser Podcast mit Tim und Linus? Ich weiß es auch nicht. Der Netzdings-Podcast. Bei dem habe ich das iPad 3 gesehen. Hab so gedacht, schick, definitiv besser. Aber wenn man das irgendwie mit den eigenen Tweets sieht und mit den eigenen Webseiten, dann ist es schon nochmal ein ganz großer Unterschied. Das ist Logbuch Netzpolitik. Genau. Danke Hubschrauber. Ah! Und wenn man dann sein altes iPad wieder in die Hand nimmt, dann ist man sofort, das ist so, man ist instant versaut.
Das war wie beim iPhone 4. Ich glaube, du musst erst mal eine Woche Retina Display gucken. Weil erst mal so beim direkten Vergleich, wir haben es jetzt gerade auch mit, wie sagt man, Side-by-Side irgendwie direkt verglichen. Also man kann, wenn man genau hinguckt, den Unterschied sehen. Aber man könnte natürlich auch den Eindruck haben, na ja, wenn du genau hinguckst, siehst du es, wenn du nicht genau hinguckst, dann eigentlich nicht. Aber ich denke auch, wie beim iPhone 4, wenn du das eine Woche benutzt hast und du gehst danach wieder zurück, dann denkst du ja auch, das geht überhaupt gar nicht. Also das ist einfach irgendwie unscharf, Treppeneffekte und all der ganzen Kram und das muss nicht sein eigentlich.
Und ich zoome auf Seiten nicht mehr so viel. Also ich nutze das iPad ja wirklich relativ viel und ich habe vorher so auf Seiten einen Artikel gerne mal reingezoomt, zum besser lesen und das mache ich jetzt tendenziell immer noch, aber bei Weitem nicht mehr so stark. Also vorher war immer so die erste Handbewegung bei Spiegel Online, zack zack, in den Artikel reinzoomen und das mache ich jetzt nicht mehr. Das wird die Werbeschalt, die Werbeindustrie sehr freuen, dass sie dann ihre scheiß Banner noch daneben pappt in HD. Und es gibt immer noch keine Retina-taugliche Porno-Seite, glaube ich.
Aber jetzt wurde es gerade gesagt, dass mir, ich muss gestehen, ja tut mir wirklich leid, aber ich habe halt kein iPad, ja. Mir ist es auf dem iPhone eigentlich noch nie aufgefallen, so mit der Werbung, also auf meinem Mac hier, ich habe hier irgendwie so einen Ad-Block und Zeug und Facebook und alles, also es ist fast eigentlich gar nichts mehr da, ja. Wie ist denn das auf dem iPad? Gibt es eigentlich schon einen Werbeblocker oder Ad-Blocker und so weiter? Also gerade da würde es ja auch Sinn machen, weil es kostet...
Nicht direkt, aber ich glaube es gibt alternative Browser, die sowas machen.
Der Safari selbst irgendwie nicht.
Der Safari selber nicht.
Und der Extension gibt es erstmal auch noch nicht.
Extension gibt es auch nicht. Ich hab mir überlegt, ob man nicht einen Proxy, einen Werbeblock einen Proxy-Dienst anbieten könnte.
Ja, sowas gibt es. Mach dir in 10 Minuten setze ich dir sowas auf. Da habe ich irgendwie so einen Squid und dann gibt es von Felix von Leitner damals, 1995 oder noch länger, ich habe keine Ahnung, wann der das gemacht hat oder was, jemand anders, weiß ich nicht, aber ich glaube, das war der Fefe. Und hatte so ein kleines Miniskript, konnte man beim Squid mit reinmachen und der hat halt gecheckt, wenn die Uhr irgendwie Folgendes ist, irgendwie so ein Pulse-Kript hat, da kann man ja so eine Spielreihen schön easy machen. Dann irgendwie, wenn irgendwie, Add-Click, Double-Click oder wie auch immer die hießen, dann irgendwie wegmachen und dann filtert der Proxy das einfach gleich so weg und liefert dir irgendwie was anderes oder irgendwie so. Das geht alles ganz easy.
Da gab es auch heute so einen schönen Fall, wie man diese Adblock auf dem Chrome jemand ausgetrickst hatte. Und zwar auf zwei Arten. Zum einen hat er einfach sich angeguckt, wie blockt Adblock, dieses Adblock plus, wie macht das, wie blockt das die Werbung, natürlich relativ simpel, indem es einfach das CSS abändert. Und dann hat er einfach einen Skript dafür geschrieben für die Seite, was man dann einfach in die Seite gepackt hat, das geguckt hat, hat jemand meine CSS geändert und das CSS zurückgeändert. Und dann wird es zurückgeändert, fertig aus. Das war so okay, eigentlich total naheliegend.
Finde ich auch okay, weil das müssten dann alle machen und so viel Geld haben die gar nicht, die ganzen kleinen Buden.
Naja, vor allen Dingen ist das glaube ich so dieses, da müssten die sich ja mal für absprechen. Das ist ja so das Ding, weil so die Werbebetreiber, also eigentlich den Webseitenbetreibern ist ja total wurscht, ob die Leute einen AdBlocker haben oder nicht. Stimmt nicht, das ist ihnen eigentlich nicht wurscht. Aber da hat die Kommunikation funktioniert, meiner Erfahrung nach immer relativ schlecht. Ich hab ja mal eine Zeit lang da in dem Bereich mal ein bisschen was gemacht, das war mal ganz furchtbar. Aber die andere Variante, die ich gefunden hatte, das war wesentlich schlauer. Und zwar es gibt eine, also man kann bei AdBlock Plus, im Chrome, kann man eigene Dateien hinzufügen, mit eigenen Beschreibungen, wie so Patterns aussehen für die Werbe. Und da haben die so eine interne Seite, die du mit so einer Chrome-Doppelpunkt-Slash-URL aufrufen kannst. Und die nimmt per Get-Parameter einfach die Datei an. Also du kannst einfach einen Link setzen, der auf deine eigene Whitelisting-Datei führt. Und dann installiert sich AdBlock Plus mal eben so eine neue…
Wie Chrome nimmt einfach irgendwas, was irgendjemand auf irgendeiner Seite verlinkt?
Nein, nein, nein. Du kannst… Also so Erweiterungen, diese JavaScript-Erweiterungen, die funktionieren so, dass die haben, die legen dir quasi einen virtuellen, also die haben ein eigenes Protokoll. Du kriegst eine eigene, jede Extension hat eine ID. Und dahinter bist du in so einer Directory-Struktur. Und du kannst verhindern, du kannst in den Einstellungen von AdBlock Plus ab einer gewissen Version, die glaube ich offiziell noch gar nicht draußen ist, kannst du verhindern, dass das Seiten darauf verlinken könnte. Jetzt könnte AdBlock Plus sicherlich mit einem Referrer-Check auch prüfen, war ich das denn überhaupt? Ist das denn überhaupt jemand Legitim ist? Aber im Augenblick passiert das alles offensichtlich nicht. Und dann brauchst du einfach nur diese URL aufzurufen und da-da hast du eine Whitelist installiert. Das werden sich jetzt bestimmt, wobei über den AdBlock, über den Werbesposter brauchst du das ja gar nicht auszuliefern. Mal sehen, wie lange das dauert, bis das irgendwelche Seiten machen. Das ist einfach ein Unterschied. Ja, AdBlock, du schreibst ja schön mit, sehr gut.
Ja, Themenkarte.
Soll ich mal ein bisschen über Windows 8 schimpfen?
Bitte, einfach mach, wie was kommt.
Ich finde ja dieses neue User-Interface von Windows 8, ich finde das ja gar nicht schlecht. Ich fand ja dieses Windows Phone 7 schon nicht verkehrt.
Diese Kacheln.
Diese Kacheln und ich fand dieses Windows 8 nicht schlimm und ich habe mir dann auch ein Video angeguckt, wie ich das zu bedienen, also wo sie es vorgestellt haben und den Entwickler vorgestellt haben, fand das auch ganz toll damals. Und ja, und jetzt kam die Public Preview und dann habe ich Virtual Box angeschmissen und habe das da drauf installiert. Und ich habe die Hände über den Kopf zusammengeschlagen vor Schmerzen.
Hast du dich gerade gesagt, du findest es gar nicht schlecht?
Ja, bis ich es das erste Mal selber bedient habe. Also es funktioniert vielleicht auf einem Tablet ganz geil, aber es ist, das habe ich wirklich, oder das habe ich seit 20 Jahren nicht mehr erlebt, dass ich vor einem Computer sitze und wirklich keinen blassen Schimmer habe, was ich jetzt zu tun habe. Also was ich tun kann, also ich hatte das Internet Explorer icon angeklickt und dann ging der Browser auf, dann ging da irgendeine Seite auf und dann wusste ich nicht, was ich weitermachen sollte. Ich habe dann so irgendwie irgendwelche Tastenabkürzungen probiert, also die Seite war leer, du hast einfach nur so Vorwärts-Rückwärts-Buttons unten gesehen und die Seite, keine Tab-Leiste oben, kein Closebar.
Adressleiste?
Nein.
Nichts dergleichen. Wirklich nichts. Und dann hatte ich so gesehen in den Demo-Videos von denen, dass man so vom Rand her, also auf ihren Tablets haben die immer so vom Rand her, die die Maus, den Finger weg bewegt, sodass dann irgendwelche, sodass du dann irgendwelche Gesten da quasi, also wenn du von oben reingreifst, dann hast du die und die Geste, und wenn du von links reingreifst, hast du die. Um dann bestimmte Elemente einzublenden auf der Seite, dann bin ich dann mit der Maus wie ein Bekloppt da oben überall gegengestoßen gegen die einzelnen Bildschirme.
Dann kamen die mal rein und rausgefallen.
Nee, da passierte gar nichts.
Da passierte absolut gar nichts.
Und dann hab ich angefangen so auf der Tastatur rumzudrücken, so alle Tasten der Reihe nach durchzudrücken, bis irgendwas passiert.
Das ist auch so der Klassiker.
Ich kam mir vor wie ein totaler Anfänger. Und irgendwann bin ich dann auf die Windows-Taste gekommen und dann passierte was. Weil wenn man auf die Windows-Taste kommt, dann ist er wieder im Start-Menü. Dann hat man kein Programm beendet, dann hat man ja gleich nicht gemacht. Und dann hab ich gegoogelt, wie man denn eigentlich so einen Browser beendet. Und dann kam das auch raus. Man muss nämlich in die Bildschirmecken die Maus bewegen. Also nicht irgendwie an den Bildschirmrand, sondern wirklich in die Ecken. Aber das passiert einem nicht versehentlich aus. Jedenfalls ist mir das nicht passiert. Und dann hab ich so gedacht, naja, vielleicht ist virtuell Box ja die falsche Methode, um das Ganze zu testen. Ich hab zu Hause noch so einen PC, wo so ein Linux draufläuft und mit XBMC drauf. Und da ist noch auf einer anderen Partition so ein Windows 7 drauf, was ich nie benutzt habe. Dann hab ich so, okay, jetzt knall ich da einfach, bügel ich da Windows 8 drüber. Ich wollte es mal ausprobieren haben. Und man scheitert, also ich weiß, es ist so wie so Windows 3.1. Da ist eine Oberfläche und die ist auch ganz hübsch, aber wenn man sobald man irgendwas machen will, was auch nur ein bisschen ernsthaft ist, muss man in den anderen Modus wechseln, in diesen Desktop-Modus. In den DOS-Modus. Und das war so richtig für so Sachen wie Bildschirmauflösung ändern. Das gibt's einfach nicht. Wenn du dann die Maus in die untere rechte Bildschirmecke bewegst, dann hast du so Einstellungen, aber da kannst du nur so Seam-Farbe einstellen, dein Profilbild und nach Softwareupdates suchen oder so was. Aber so was Profanes wie Bildschirmauflösung ändern gibt es da einfach nicht. Oder die Maus-Cursor-Geschwindigkeit, die war mir viel zu langsam, die wollte ich viel viel schneller haben. Alles gibt es einfach nicht.
Weil man soll das Ding ja später auch mit dem Finger benutzen und du kannst den Finger ja nicht schneller machen.
Ja, aber das ist deren Betriebssystem für ein Desktop. Das wollen die auf ein Desktop bringen. Und dann bin ich da auf diesen Desktop-Modus gegangen und will da unten aufs Startmenü und dann gibt es natürlich kein Startmenü mehr. Haben sie abgeschafft. Wie kommt man jetzt an die Systemeinstellungen ran? Ohne Startmenü. Also ok, du hast wirklich, du guckst als ob du wirklich nicht mal wüsst, was das Startmenü wäre.
Doch, doch, ich weiß, was das Startmenü ist. Ich hab irgendwann bei Windows XP bin ich stehen geblieben.
Dann hab ich mit der rechten Maustaste auf den Desktop geklickt. Dann kommt man ja irgendwie an die Anzeigeneinstellungen ran. Und dann hatte ich die Anzeigeneinstellungen offen. Dann bin ich da per Breadcrumb, also gibt es oben so eine Leiste, mit der man so durchklicken kann, sich so die Ordner-Hierarchie wieder hoch. Und da hab ich dann mich auf die Systemeinstellungen hochgearbeitet. Und da bin ich dann an die Mauseinstellungen rangekommen. Aber ich hab bis heute keinen offiziellen Weg gefunden, wie man in die Systemeinstellungen kommt. Also in die normalen, in denen man auch was einstellen kann. Und das ist wirklich... Vom Gedankengang ist das her so, es gibt neben der Windows-Taste drücken, kommt man auch noch mit einer Geste in dieses Windows-Start-Kachel-Ding rein. Und zwar wenn man unten links in die Bildschirm-Ecke klickt.
Klickt oder reinfährt?
Klickt. Also reinfahren und dann klicken.
Also da, wo ja früher der Startbutton war.
Genau. Also wenn man dahin klickt, wo früher mal der Startbutton war, dann passiert das, was so etwas Vergleichbares... Also man muss wissen...
Das ist doch offensichtlich.
Man muss wissen, wie es früher war. Jetzt ist da wirklich kein Hinweis. Es ist nicht mehr angedeutet, dass irgendwas passieren könnte, wenn du dahin klickst. Also wenn du mit der Maus da bist, in der ganz untenen Ecke, dann erscheint da auch so ein hässliches Bild, was dir irgendwie klar machen soll, dass da jetzt das Startmenü kommt. Aber ich bin von alleine nicht auf die Idee gekommen. Und ich glaube, da verzweifeln wirklich sehr. Also das ist echt schmerzerregend.
Ja, was ich mich frage ist, ist es jetzt nur halb fertig? Oder wissen die nicht mehr, was sie tun? Sind die so hektisch am Rumhühnern, dass sie nicht mehr merken, dass sie jetzt alles kaputt machen? Also wahrscheinlich eine Mischung aus beidem. Aber irgendwie, das kann doch nicht sein. Also ich meine, ich halte ja nicht viel von Microsoft, aber so wenig dann auch wieder nicht.
Na ich glaube, also mein Eindruck ist, dass das ein Interface ist, was einfach für einen Computer ist, der noch nicht da ist. Also ich glaube, auf einem Tablet würde das alles relativ geschmeidig funktionieren.
Ja, aber so ein Computer ist doch in den nächsten 5 Jahren noch nicht da. Zumindest bei den PCs nicht.
Ja, genau das ist, ich glaube, das ist das, was sie nicht... Also man merkt das wirklich an so Details auch in diesem Startmenü, was man vorne ganz am Anfang drin hat. Da kann man ja so durchswipen. Also das ist so, das kann man so ein bisschen wie Springboard. Man kann so mit dem Finger durchswipen, wenn man, wenn es eine Fingerbedienung hat.
Und dann, dann, dann fließen so die Kacheln hin und her.
Und dann fließen so die Kacheln hin und her. Jetzt ist das aber so, dass meine Maus, die hat einfach keinen Rechts-Links-Swipe. Und das, das Rollrad, das kann nur oben und unten. Das heißt, da ist unten so ein kleiner Rollbalken unten dran am Bildschirm. Mit dem man nach links und nach unten muss, um auf die zweite Seite zu kommen. Also bestimmt gibt es noch irgendwie eine tolle Geste, die ich bloß wieder nicht entdeckt hab. Aber um auf die zweite Seite zu kommen, musst du ganz klassisch unten auf den Rollbalken klicken und dann so den Rollbalken hin und her ziehen, um die zweite Seite zu sehen. Weil sie einfach nicht, offensichtlich nicht bedacht haben, dass ja bei einem klassischen Desktop die Maus so ist, dass man nur hoch und runter scrollen kann. Und das ist, das ist glaube ich so das, was was so gerade diese Schmerzen an diesem Betriebssystem macht. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie das noch mehr kriegen. Also ich bin da echt mal gespannt drauf.
Und das soll so gegen Ende des Jahres kommen, oder wie es Windows sagt?
Ich glaube so im September, Oktober.
Ja und kann man dieses Kachel ganz ausschalten und wieder aufs Kachel Windows zurück?
Also man kann irgendwie die Registry editieren und dann kommt man wieder in den Windows-Modus und dann hat man auch wieder ein Startmenü und sowas.
Also in der Registry kann man immer alles machen.
Offiziell geht da nix.
Echt?
Also du bist an dieses Interface gebunden. Und das ist wirklich, ja, also man bräuchte sowas wie so ein Magic Trackpad oder sowas, aber das gibt's ja nicht.
Also sozusagen den...
Die haben sich von der falschen Hardware inspirieren lassen.
Den Untergang, den Apple jetzt mit Lion und demnächst Mountain Lion macht, wo ja auch schon ganz schön viel immer mehr iOS kommt, was mir teilweise nicht so gefällt. Also dieses Reverse Scrolling ist ja noch cool, ganz viele andere Sachen sind, naja. Und Microsoft meinte, sie müssten das gleich mal noch überholen.
Sie machen das mit Anlauf?
Ja, vielleicht verkaufen sie auch gleich ihr Magic Trackpad mit dazu. Du kriegst es im Bundle oder so mit dabei.
Wenn sie Trackpads bauen könnten.
Das neue Windows-Eingabe-Super-Duper-Gerät.
Aber es gibt ja für PCs keine vernünftigen Trackpads. Das ist ja, wenn man sich mal die üblichen Tests durchliegt.
Deswegen meine ich ja, vielleicht haben sie das irgendwo in der Hinterhand und bringen das zum Start.
Und was hält Microsoft davon? Die verkaufen ja keine Hardware, also ich meine das ja.
Na ja, Mäuse haben sie damals auch verkauft, als sie ihr Windows irgendwie an den Start kriegen wollten. Also das wäre ja noch logisch, wenn sie sagen so, Leute mit dem neuen Windows kriegt ihr jetzt auch das neue Trackpad von Microsoft dazu und dann funktioniert das vielleicht oder so.
Aber es ist halt, also was bei mir das schlimme Gefühl war, ich sah es davor wie gesagt und es ist ein Gefühl, was ich nicht von der Benutzung von Computern kenne, dass ich verzweifelt war.
Ja, lang kein neues System mehr angefasst.
Nein, ich hab Windows, ich hab irgendwie mit, ich komm mit Laien klar. Also ich meine, klar, man hat irgendwie, es gibt kleinere Probleme, aber so wirklich, ich weiß nicht, wie ich diesen Browser verlasse. Das war, das hatte ich noch nie. Das gab's, das ist so lange, wie ich einen Computer bedient habe, gab's das noch nicht. Und ich stell mir das vor, wenn jetzt so alteingesessene Windows-User, die ja eigentlich nur bei ihrem Windows-PC bleiben, weil sie den kennen, wenn diese mit dieser Oberfläche konfrontiert werden. Die schreien, die schreien wirklich und rennen weg zum nächsten Hersteller. Das ist meine feste Überzeugung.
Ich kenn genug Leute, die sagen, sie wollen nicht von XP auf Windows 7 updaten, weil da ist ja alles anders. Da ist ja alles anders, da kennen sie sich da nicht aus. Und solche Leute kriegst du natürlich auf Windows 8 nie und never.
Also wirklich keine Chance. Ich find, Windows 7 kann man ja mitarbeiten. Ich glaub, das ist auch tausendmal besser als XP. Mit XP wollte ich nicht arbeiten müssen, aber Windows 7, das ging so halbwegs. Aber Windows 8, das wird, also mit Microsoft geht's. Also wenn hier Tim immer auf Apple schimpft, dass das Piek Apple da war, dann ist das jetzt hier aber Freefall Microsoft, wenn das kommt.
Schuss in den Fuß mit Anlauf und der großen Bummel.
Man könnte vielleicht sagen, dass Windows 7 Piek Microsoft war. Weil ich find das 7, ich hab das ja... Als Zuhause auch, ich find's eigentlich ganz okay.
Wenn man jetzt denkt, dass Microsoft sowieso so in Zyklen arbeitet. Also so nach der Art, Windows NT4 war gut, 2000, naja, okay, Windows XP war wieder ganz gut, Windows Vista, naja, eher nicht, Windows 7 war wieder ganz gut, Windows 8, naja, eher nicht. Man könnte auf Windows 9 hoffen.
Also wenn sie das Windows 9 noch überleben, dann...
Oder Nova, oder wie sie es dann nennen.
Du weißt ja, ein Betriebssystem war immer gut, wenn der Nachfolger gleich heißt. Das heißt, Windows 8 ist angelehnt an Windows 7, das heißt, Windows 7 war gut. Windows 7 heißt nicht so wie Windows Vista, also Windows Vista war scheiße. Vista heißt auch nicht wie der Vorgänger, und dann hießen sie alle nicht wie der Vorgänger. Der einzige, der noch irgendwie gleich hieß, war glaube ich 98, weil 95 war halt gut, weil er war ja komplett neu und schick und alles. Deswegen, jedes Mal, wenn die verkacken... Na, jedes Mal, wenn die verkacken, ändern die ihren Namen.
Dafür ändern sie den Namen aber relativ selten. Ja, und dass dieses Ding immer noch Windows heißt, das ist ja auch...
wozu?
Also ich meine, es ist wirklich kein Windows mehr. Das hat nix mehr damit zu tun.
Ja, das seh ich aber ein. Ich meine, Mac OS heißt ja auch immer noch Mac OS. Das ist halt der zentrale Markenkern dieses Betriebssystems.
Egal.
Sollen sie es jetzt tiles nennen, statt Windows?
Na, ich nehme an, dass sie auf ihre Metro oder irgendwie hinaus wollen.
Metro? Was ist das für ein Name?
Was heißt das? Was kann ich da nix dafür?
Klingt wie eine französische U-Bahn.
Und ich bin ja mal sehr gespannt. Office kriegen sie ja darauf nicht zum Laufen. Das haben sie ja schon offiziell angekündigt. Microsoft Office geht ja nicht mit dieser Metro-Oberfläche. Die haben sich ja quergestellt. Deswegen ja auch ARM, den klassischen Windows-Desktop hat, den Office-Runtime-Modus quasi.
Das Carbon für Windows.
Und jetzt habe ich bei OS News, das ist eine lustige Seite, die schrumpfen immer so gerne über Apple, und die haben darüber berichtet, dass jetzt Microsoft gerade die Regeln gelockert hat, wie man ein, Microsoft-Fliese, wie man ein Browser für Windows 8 entwickelt, für diese Metro-Oberfläche. Und zwar haben nämlich die...
Da gab es Regeln?
Da gibt es Regeln, wie man ein Browser entwickelt? Wie viele Browser wollen die denn auf ihrem System haben? Oder glauben sie, werden sie je auf ihrem System bekommen?
Na ja, also ich meine, dass es dafür ein Firefox geben wird, ist klar. Dass es dafür ein Chrome geben wird, ist auch relativ klar. Die wollen natürlich alle da sein. Ich finde es ja auch, also ich meine, es wäre ja nun schlimm, wenn plötzlich unter Windows 8 keine Dritthersteller-Browser mehr laufen würden. Das wäre ja wie unter iOS. Also ich meine, das auf dem Desktop wäre wirklich ein Erträgliches. Und denen ist aufgefallen, dass man dafür diese Metro-Sachen, die darf man ja auch alle nur mit C-Sharp entwickeln. Und ein schneller Browser ist damit wohl nicht machbar. Und so vernünftiges HTML-Parsing. Und man muss da an die Win32-AP ran. Also hat sich Microsoft jetzt breitschlagen lassen. Und jetzt gibt es so einen speziellen Browser-Modus, der so ein bisschen Windows 8 ist, oder so Metro, aber so ein bisschen auch noch in dem alten drin ist. Darum kannst du auch nicht in den Windows-Market rein, die Browser, sondern die müssen irgendwie dann alle aus eigener Quelle installiert werden, weil in den Market dürfen nur offizielle Metro-Sachen.
Ach, und Metro kannst du nur, und dass sie scharp machen.
Genau.
Na ja, gut, ist ja eigentlich auch sinnvoll, diese ganzen Uraltöpfe abzuschneiden.
Ja, aber wenn es nicht schnell genug ist, um einen Browser drin zu schreiben? Also, und genau, und die müssen immer beide Modi unterstützen, nämlich den Windows, also den klassischen Modus und den Metro-Modus. Und im Metro-Modus können sie nur laufen, wenn sie der Default-Browser sind. Also du musst einen Browser als Default-Browser einstellen, um ihm die Möglichkeit zu geben, in den Metro-Unterfest zu laufen. Ansonsten laufen sie immer exakt.
Exakt, das war der Gesichtsausdruck, den ich auch hatte.
Na gut, ich muss es nicht verstehen. Oder?
Ja, also das ist, das ist, ach, na ja. Das war Windows 8 für mich. Das hat, also, wer auch immer beim letzten Mal hier noch erzählt hat, dass ja Windows vielleicht eine ganz vernünftige Alternative wäre. Ich glaube, das geht nach hinten los.
Ja, okay, ein Griff ins Betriebssystemklo.
Als große.
Powerbook 6-Raparatur hab ich da drauf geschrieben?
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht. Vielleicht ein Schrägstrich oder so soll das vielleicht sein?
Und soll das sein, ich hab vergessen, die Schriftdase zu drücken.
Ja, erzähl du mal was.
Welches Thema? Was haben wir da? Gib mir eine Karte.
Na, deine Airport Extreme hier, ne?
Ja, muss ich mal ein bisschen berichten, wieder ein bisschen Positives, ne? Muss ja auch wieder runterkommen von dem ganzen Microsoft Bashing. Ich hab mir, nachdem ich schon seit einiger Zeit, ich hab zu Hause eine Apple Airport Express, ich fand die eigentlich ganz cool, die ist ganz klein. Ich kann da meine Anlage anschließen und kann mit iTunes meine Musik hinschieben und gleichzeitig ist es halt irgendwie meine WLAN-Station. Und irgendwie, die ist nicht kaputt, die funktioniert immer noch, aber so seit ein paar Monaten, ich hab das Gefühl, das liegt daran, dass ich wohne in Berlin-Mitte, da ist halt...
Da kochen die WLAN-Frequenzen.
Da kochen die WLAN-Frequenzen, also jede Familie und wahrscheinlich die Kinder haben ihre eigene WLAN-Station. Ich hab keine Ahnung. Also wenn ich bei mir die WLAN-Stationsliste im Menü aufmache, dann geht die bis zum unteren Bildschirmrand. Also das ist wirklich alles voll. Und deswegen, ich bin irgendwie nicht so weit weg von meiner eigenen Station, aber ab und zu, ich hab so vollen Empfang eigentlich, aber dann macht so plopp, die Station ist irgendwie weg und der braucht irgendwie so ein paar Sekunden, bis er sie wieder kriegt. Und in der Zeit, weil ich auch irgendwie, ich glaube, weil ich IPv6 Privacy Extension hab oder so, jedes Mal wenn das kurz weg ist, dann ändert der auch die IP-Adresse. Das ist halt so ein Nebeneffekt, keine Ahnung, jedenfalls ist alles, meine ganzen Connections und so weiter, es rattert und klingelt und nervt voll. Und dann denkst du dir, warum geht denn das schon wieder nicht? Und dann nach einer Weile geht's wieder. Und die Leute fragen schon, ob mein Adium kaputt ist, weil da geh ich natürlich immer auch raus, rein, raus, rein und all sowas. Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, schnauze voll.
Liegst du vielleicht an BitTorrent?
Nee, hab ich gar nicht. Also, nee.
Ich hab mal festgestellt, dass man ältere Fritz-Boxen mit BitTorrent ganz gut killen kann.
Nö, das, also, BitTorrent bin ich ja auch, Hardcore BitTorrent-User, aber das funktioniert eigentlich. BitTorrent stört das ja auch nicht, der hat halt kurz einen Ausfall, macht danach weiter, holt sich die Connections wieder, also den interessiert das ja nicht, aber mich stört das. Und, ähm, jedenfalls habe ich dann, hatte ich ja glaube ich auch schon mal erzählt, bei anderen Tags so einen coolen Bericht über die Airport Extreme gelesen, die letztes Jahr rauskam, die fünfte Generation der Airport Extreme.
Die so wahnsinnig viel schneller ist?
Die so wahnsinnig viel schneller ist und besonders dann, wenn sie mit dem MacBook Pro zusammenläuft, weil beide einen Broadcom-Ship drin haben und dann beide auf so einen Broadcom-Spezial, wir sind jetzt mal nicht mehr Standard irgendwie machen. Also die setzen nur noch einen drauf, so wie es ganz früher bei den Modems mal da war, mit V34 Plus und was sie denn alles so führen. V32 Turbo, genau. Ja, so was. Und das machen die bei Apple mit Broadcom wohl auch angeblich, weil sonst könnten sie gar nicht so hochkommen. Jedenfalls hab ich mir jetzt da mal so ein Ding geholt, hab das irgendwie angeschlossen, hab alles gemacht und getan und auch mal den Durchsatz gemessen. Also es jetzt war vor zwei Wochen knapp. Bisher hatte ich keine Ausfälle, sie sind wirklich weg durch das Ding. Und ich hab mal den Durchsatz gemessen und ich komm so auf 31 Megabyte die Sekunde, was gerade so in dem Bereich ist. Also ich hab doch keine... Also ich hab eine USB-Adapter, der irgendwie 34 MB die Sekunde macht, aber sonst alle bisherigen USB-Adapter, die ich hab, weil die sind ja auch alle so low quality, schaffen keine 30 MB. Das heißt, ich kann über meinen WLAN locker auch auf alle möglichen Platten zugreifen, also USB-Platten, weil es ist schnell genug. Und die könnte man ja...
Das ist ja nicht krass.
Das ist ja auch noch an die Airport Extreme anschließen sogar.
Aber 31 Megabyte, das ist ja 300 Megabit schafft er offiziell, ne?
In der Handzeige steht 425 als Wert.
Das ist ja knapp unter theoretisch Maximum. Beneidenswert.
Also bei Anatec haben sie so 36 oder 38 gemessen. Wahrscheinlich stand es so direkt nebeneinander. So habe ich es nicht gemessen.
Ich freue mich, wenn ich 5 habe. Ich habe VDSL50, ich kann nicht mal davon träumen, das auch komplett tatsächlich zu nutzen.
Also ich bin voll happy, das Ding steht jetzt auf meinem Regal, leuchtet ein bisschen dezenter vor sich hin, weil die Express hatte so eine LED, die hat ganz schön geknallt. Wenn du abends so einen Film guckst, und da ist eine ruhige Stelle im Film, weil dann Film und Licht ausweist schon, und dann auf einmal blinkt es immer so. Und dann denkst du dir, what the fuck, was ist denn hier los? Und dann guck ich so, alles klar, meine Express blinkt gerade so ein bisschen rum und dann blitzt das immer so im Raum, weil die LED so ein bisschen knallig ist. Aber bei der Extreme, die ist so ein bisschen so, wie soll man sagen, so ein bisschen abgeschwächt, so ganz dezent, also ist alles einfach schick. Na ja, da ist ein USB-Anschluss dran. Kann man auch zur Not hier immer so als Trick, man kann auch seine iPhone da drüber laden, glaube ich. Und ähm...
Du kannst doch auch einen Drucker anschließen.
Und vor allem, du kannst wirklich, weil im Konfigurationsmenü hier von dem Airport, Airport Admin Utility hier, man kann da auch nicht nur, ich hab jetzt gerade einen USB-Stick drin, stecken nur so zum Testen, aber im Utility habe ich gesehen, dass der auch mehrere Platten verwalten kann. Das heißt, du kannst da auch locker einen USB-Hub anschließen und dann mehrere Platten anschließen. Das ist alles gar kein Problem. Also, du könntest da eine ganze Serverfarm sozusagen über dieses Ding machen. Und wenn du dann ja trotzdem am Ethernet hängst, dann musst du dir die Platten ja noch nicht mal über WLAN benutzen. Dann würdest du sie ja sogar per Ethernet bekommen. Weil deine Station hängt ja auch am Ethernet.
Ja, aber das Ethernet nutzt... Ich bin so genervt, weil ich hab zuhause ja mittlerweile drei WLAN-Hotspots, um die Wohnung halbwegs zu versorgen mit WLAN.
Achso, weil du hast so einen schlechten Empfang.
Ich hab total schlechten Empfang.
Ich kaufe dir eine Extreme, stell die in die Mitte und das Ding hat drei Antennen und der strahlt in alle Richtungen, kann automatisch zwischen 5 und 2,5 GHz hin und her switchen und so, also der sucht halt wirklich die Antenne, die am besten passt und so. Und Beiner, ich hab jetzt den eingestellt, dass er halt 2,5 und 5 GHz macht. Und vorher, da war so ein Häkchen, da kannst du sagen, dass als Netzwerkname, dass du eine, also meine Station heißt Funkfeuer Extreme jetzt, dass da steht in einer Liste auf einmal Funkfeuer Extreme und einmal Funkfeuer Extreme 5 GHz, dass ich es mir sozusagen aussuchen kann. Und dann dachte ich mir, ne, will ich aber eigentlich gar nicht, weil ich will ja nicht zwei Stationen und wieder zwei da in der Liste haben. Ich will eigentlich nur einen Namen haben und er soll mal machen, habe ich probiert und tatsächlich hat er automatisch auf 5 GHz geschaltet und mein iPhone kann ja keine 5 GHz, der macht dann locker 2,5. Also dann macht das einfach automatisch. Deswegen stell das Ding in die Mitte deiner Bude, wo es am besten in alle Richtungen geht. Schalt einfach ein, er soll einfach alles anbieten und Chukka fertig.
Vielleicht hör ich mir doch mal so ein Ding. Ich hab nämlich festgestellt, dass ich auch immer, ich hab mir extra mal so, als ich in meiner alten Wohnung Empfangsprobleme bekam mit 2,5 GHz, hab ich dann halt mir so ein 5 GHz Ding gekauft, hatte plötzlich keine Probleme mehr, alles klar, 5 GHz ist the way to go und das will man haben. Und jetzt in der neuen Wohnung hab ich dann auch alles schön auf 5 GHz. 5 GHz gemacht und hatte wirklich gar keinen Empfang, bis ich irgendwann mal festgestellt hab, mit 2,5 geht's wesentlich besser, also es ist nicht gut.
5 GHz ist halt so hoch, das kommt halt nicht so gut durch Wände durch, besonders nicht wenn die nass sind. Hast du feuchte Wände? Nee, aber 5 GHz ist halt schnell irgendwie, also es kommt nicht gut durch irgendwas durch, wird aber dafür sehr lokal, sehr powermäßig und stört halt, also lässt sich nicht so schnell von den Nachbarn stören, glaube ich. Aber es kommt halt nicht so weit, also durch dicke Wände kommt es nicht so gut durch wie 2,5 Vueh.
Naja, und ich glaube nicht nur durch dicke Wände, sondern wenn die Abschirmung ein bisschen da ist. Ich habe eine Wand.
Haben die da Alufolie tapeziert oder was?
Es muss sowas in der Richtung sein. Dahinter ist alles tot.
Ich hatte in einer meiner alten Wohnungen in der Kochecke in der Küche, da war tatsächlich unter der Tapete Alufolie tapeziert.
So als Bärmedämmung oder was?
Ne, wahrscheinlich so als Feuerschutz, damit das nicht so schnell die Wärme, irgendwie die Wand, das war halt nur so Gipskarton.
Na ja, verstehe.
Und keine Ahnung, vielleicht hast du sowas auch in der Küche an einer bestimmten Stelle.
Dürfte da eigentlich nicht sein. Also es muss, die Wand, die war früher mal eine Wand, wo quasi, also es war früher keine Wohnung, sondern da war vorher so ein Fahrradkeller drinne und sowas, also es war schon ziemlich abenteuerliches Zeug, was wir da von der Wand gekratzt haben, aber Alufolie war jetzt erstaunlicherweise noch nicht dabei. Genau, oder, nee, damit man hier sowieso, damit man nicht die ganze Zeit mit so einem Tint-Folger-Held rumrennen muss.
Also das Schöne an den 5 Gigahertz-Bereichen ist, dass die meisten Nachbarn das halt eben nicht haben und das heißt, da sind die Frequenzen irgendwie frei.
Ein bisschen freier, ja.
Ja, aber 2,5 Gigahertz ist wirklich voll, da sind ja auch noch die Deck-Telefone alle drin und so, oder? War das nicht so? Also ich glaube, da ist die Frequenz einfach nicht.
Können wir mal gucken, was hier so los ist.
Und dann gibt es noch was, weil in Europa, also die mussten ja diese Frequenznummer und ihre Geräte da beantragen, und hier dieses 802.11a heißt es ja irgendwie, oder n kann auch im 5 Gigahertz-Bereich. Jedenfalls hat irgendwie das Europa-Dingens, was das irgendwie spezifizieren oder absegnen muss, die haben gesagt, ihr dürft das schon machen im 5 Gigahertz-Bereich, aber nur, wenn ihr was unterstützt, was DFS heißt, Dynamic Frequency Switching oder wie auch immer. Jedenfalls, wenn das die Airport Extreme merkt, dass im 5 Gigahertz-Bereich, wenn der Channel, den du gerade benutzen willst, wenn der voll ist, dann springt sie automatisch zu einem anderen. Das heißt, sie sucht sich auch immer schön irgendwie einen freien aus. Das heißt, selbst wenn da ein paar Nachbarn sind, dann sucht sie es halt da aus, wo gerade irgendwie so ein bisschen leer ist. Und in Europa sind wohl irgendwelche Wetterstationen oder irgendwie sowas auch bei 5 Gigahertz. Und deswegen haben die gesagt, ihr könnt das schon machen, aber ihr müsst dann automatisch wegspringen, wenn da schon was anderes ist. Und gleichzeitig auch für die Leute, die nicht gerne so bestrahlt werden, was noch unterstützt werden musste, für Europa ist irgendwie, ich glaube es heißt TPC, heißt Total Power Control, glaube ich, oder sowas. Transport Power Control, irgendwas mit Power Control. Jedenfalls, dass es automatisch die Sendeleistung sozusagen irgendwie einstellt, je nachdem, ob überhaupt gerade was los ist oder wie weit der Kleinen weg ist, also der Empfänger weg ist und so. Dass nicht da die ganze Zeit irgendwie volle Pulle rum gebrutzelt wird, sondern dass es sich ein bisschen zurückhält. Und ja, ich hab jetzt ein gutes Gefühl. Ich schlaf auch seitdem viel besser.
Viel schneller. Zum Thema Fritzbox, weil du das angesprochen hast. Heute gab es bei uns in der Firma wieder ein neues Update für die Fritzbox, aber wir haben es nicht eingespielt. Wir hatten beim letzten Update das Problem, dass wenn der USB-Stick in der Fritzbox steckt, dann lässt er sich nicht updaten. Und dann kackt die irgendwie mitten beim Updaten ab. Und dann war's das. Das hat uns irgendwie einen halben Tag Arbeit gekostet, das Ding wieder hinzukriegen. Ja, irgendwie musste dann der eine Kollege sein Windows in der Virtual Box auspacken, um da irgendwie wieder Anschluss an die Fritzbox zu bekommen und so weiter. Das war alles ein bisschen. Und weißt du, warum sie das Update gemacht haben? Warum? Wegen der Sommerzeit, weil sie...
Stimmt, die haben die Sommerzeit verkackt, ne?
Die haben irgendwie die Sommerzeit verkackt. Und das Allerbeste ist...
Wie, dann updaten sie danach?
Weißte, ja.
Ich, keine Ahnung. Wahrscheinlich müssen sie immer, wenn irgendwie sich die Sommerzeitdaten ändert, irgendwie ein neues Update bereitstellen. Also ich hab keine Ahnung, was die da machen. Aber das Beste ist, das Beste ist, dass dieses Update ist nur ein sogenanntes Labor-Update oder wie sie das nennen. Also das ist kein...
So eine Beta-Version quasi.
Jaja, das ist kein vollständig QA-geprüftes Update, weil, und das war die beste Begründung, weil sie es innerhalb einer Woche nicht schaffen, das so zu testen, dass sie es als normales Update rausbringen können.
Also das kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen. Die haben da bestimmt einen relativ komplexen Testablauf, so im Allgemeinen. Denn wenn du ihm da zugeschrieben hättest, dann würden die das in Zukunft auch mal mit USB-Stick stellen. Ich kenn das ja noch von einer Firma, wo ich früher bei MyHammer gearbeitet hab. Und da hat so ein kompletter Testdurchlauf, und ich meine, es war nur eine Web-Plattform und nicht irgendwie so ein Betriebssystem, das du auf hunderten Geräten installieren musst, die du irgendwie rumstehen hast. Da hat das auch so drei, vier Tage gedauert ein kompletter Durchtesten. So mit allen Teilen der Plattform und sowas, bevor das rollen durfte. Das hat auch ewig gedauert. Also da war eine eigene Abteilung, die war rund um die Uhr damit beschäftigt, Dinge zu testen. Das finde ich eher besser als schlechter, wenn sie das nicht auf die Reihe kriegen. Sobald kommt das mit der Winterzeit auch nicht mehr. Können sie jetzt ruhig noch ein Vierteljahr warten, bis sie das Update rausschmeißen?
Ja, aber naja, es ist halt so, dass die Fritzbox wohl immer noch Winterzeit hat und sich erst am 1. April umstellt. Weil sie hat ja das falsche Datum. Ich weiß nicht, ob es wirklich ein Problem ist, aber wenn man könnte jetzt das Update einspielen, dann hätte man bereits die Sommerzeit oder man kann einfach bis zum 1. April warten und dann ist es eh egal.
Ich weiß ja, dass alle, die nicht updaten, haben jetzt immer noch nicht die Sommerzeit und sind um eine Stunde falsch.
Dann hab ich definitiv noch die falsche Zeit.
Wenn du die Fritzbox als Timeserver benutzt, dann ist das ein Problem. Ansonsten eigentlich nicht so. Es ist nur im Log falsch und so, oder?
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Also ist jetzt auch nicht so mega schlimm. Ich weiß nicht, was die Fritzbox noch so macht und wo die Zeit wichtig ist.
Na ja, du kannst so Sachen machen. Also erst mal hat es den Wecker. Das ist das, was vielen Leuten aufgefallen ist. Dann hast du so automatisch, dass es so in einer bestimmten Uhrzeit die Antennen ausschaltet oder einen Energiesparmodus gibt. So eine Schwäche kannst du machen.
Es gibt noch was. Du hast ja so deckte Mobilteile.
Genau, Telefone hast du da drin.
Und die kriegen ihre Uhrzeit natürlich von der Fetzbox.
Dann ist dann auch immer eine Anzeige falsch. Und dann, wann dich jemand angerufen hat, ist dann auch alles falsch. Also es ist schon jetzt nicht so doll mega schlimm, aber so häuft ganz vieles Kleines, was nicht okay ist.
Genau, das ist das, was wir wahrscheinlich ganz dringend haben.
Dann, ich will noch kurz was erzählen, was gerade passend mit Uhrzeit zu tun hat. Und zwar, ich weiß nicht, ich hab ja mal berichtet hier, ich hab mir doch so eine Uhr gebaut. Kannst du dich dran erinnern, Max? So, und da ist alles irgendwie perfekt. Läuft seit ein paar Jahren irgendwie und so weiter. Ist alles schick. Aber, das Einzige, was ich nicht programmiert hab, weil das Ding kann auch die Sommerzeit, das wird per, das ist so eine Funk-Une.
DCF 77.
Genau. Und da wird zum Beispiel auch übermittelt so in jeder, also in der Stunde, bevor die Zeitumstellung ist, gibt's pro Minute ein so ein Signal, dass demnächst eine Zeitumstellung kommt. Und wenn ich das Signal mehr öfter kriege als das Signal, dass ich, dass keine Zeitumstellung kommt, dann mach ich sozusagen automatisch eine Zeitumstellung. Das heißt, ich würde die sogar dann machen, wenn in der Minute, wo die Zeitumstellung stattfindet, ich gar keinen Empfang hätte. Weil dann würde er sich ja automatisch einfach um eine Stunde korrigieren. Aber meine Uhr weiß das sozusagen durch die Signale, die vorgekommen ist, dass sie es von alleine machen muss, ohne zu warten, bis sie korrigiert wird. So, alles ganz schick, habe ich getestet, habe Videos von, habe ich da gestanden, aufgenommen, alles ganz toll, funktioniert alles. Das einzige, was ich halt nicht programmiert habe, ist die Schallsekunde. Und siehe da, ich dachte, sie wird abgeschafft, aber nein, dieses Jahr im Juni oder Ende Juni wird eine Schallsekunde eingeführt. Das heißt, dass, ich glaube, am letzten Tag im Juni, also es müsste ja der 30. Juni sein, ich glaube, um 23.59 Minuten haben wir nicht nur eine 59. Sekunde, sondern auch noch eine 60. Es kann sein, dass es wegen GMT ist, es ist dann bei uns 1 Uhr Nacht, also theoretisch der 1. Juli dann schon, weil das ist bei GMT diese Schallsekunde Geschichte.
Achso, es gibt dann einfach...
Dann gibt es ganz kurz eine 60. Sekunde, also eine Sekunde lang gibt es eine 60. Sekunde und dann wird erst gesprungen, weil die Erde mal wieder ein bisschen langsamer dreht, weil die wird ja mal langsamer mit der Zeit. Und dann müssen sie immer mal wieder so eine Schallsekunde einführen alle paar Jahre und jetzt ist diesen Sommer ist es wieder so weit und das kann mein Uhr noch nicht. Die hat halt so ein Modulo drin, wenn es über 59 kommt, dann wird automatisch wieder null angezeigt und dann muss ich das ganz kurz mal korrigieren. Ja, da gibt es ganz viele, die das mit der Sommerzeit gerne so hätten. Mir ist eigentlich egal, ob es Winter- oder Sommerzeit dauerhaft ist, aber ich hätte gerne eine Zeit, die die ganze Zeit durchläuft. Den Rest gewöhnt man sich ja dann.
Da muss man sich mal den Wikipedia-Artikel durchlesen, wann, zu welchen Zeiten, wo auf der Erde Sommerzeiten eingeführt und wieder abgeschafft wurden.
Das ist total flummig. Für jeden US-Hersteller, also auch hier bei FreeBest, wo ich ja mal beobachte, was die da so für Commits machen und so. Und dann hat wieder ein Land eine Woche verschoben, ein Land hat es jetzt abgeschafft, die anderen machen das und das. Dann da gibt es neue Länder, die machen es wieder so und die haben da riesenlange Listen, die müssen andauernd gepflegt werden und so. Wann, wer, was irgendwie macht.
Es gibt diese Olsen-Database, aus der bedienen sich eigentlich alle Hersteller.
Ja klar, aber es muss ja ins US mit rein, weil nicht alle sind dauer online, weil muss man sich ja drum kümmern und so und das ist der totale Krampf.
Ist das diese Datenbank, die die unter Copyright, die Zeitzonen-Datenbank, ist das die? Die wo sich plötzlich rausstellt, dass die unter Copyright steht?
Ja, aber nur für historische Zeitzonen-Daten.
Nur für die Zeit von 1980 oder so war das.
Genau, die war das. Die benutzen eigentlich alle. Das ist irgendwie...
Ja, da stehen Zeitzonen unterm Urheberrecht. Muss ja auch mal sein. Ähm, Themenwechsel?
Wir waren jetzt fertig mit Zeit und Airport Extreme und so weiter und so fort.
Wir haben ja hier mal vor ein paar Sendungen über Hausautomatisierung gesprochen. Wie ist das erste System, das weiß ich nicht mehr. Und ich habe mir danach gedacht, das selber auszuprobieren, habe ich keinen Bock drauf. Aber mein Vater, der bastelt ja so gerne auf seinem Rollstuhl rum.
So mache ich das auch immer, wenn ich selber keinen Bock oder kein Geld habe, dann quatsche ich mal andere voll, dass es ja eigentlich voll cool wäre und so.
Genau.
Und warte, bis die das machen.
Und jetzt hat mein Vater sein gesamtes Haus ver-ILVt. Also mit dieser ELV Max-Anlage. Und da gibt es auch eine iPhone-App für.
Also die haben aber richtig ein Haus.
Die haben ein Haus. Und was hat er da gemacht? Also die Temperatursteuerung läuft darüber, dass er die einstellen kann. Und er hat mehrere Fenstersensoren, dass die nachgucken, ob die Fenster gerade offen sind. Und er hat einen so einen Button, wo er quasi sagen kann, ich verlasse jetzt das Haus, mach alle Heizungen aus oder so was. Und ich kann jetzt von hier aus, ich hab die iPhone-App hier auf meinem Telefon laufen.
Kannst du mal sehen, ob deine Eltern da sind oder nicht?
Ich kann gucken, ob meine Eltern da sind. Und ich kann die Temperatur runter setzen, wenn ich mag. Also ich hab jetzt einen kleinen Schieber, mit dem kann ich im Haus meiner Eltern die Temperatur regeln.
Das wird so übel werden, wenn du dazu kommst. Und die kehlen nicht einfach nicht, sondern die machen einfach im Winter so kalt, dass du einfrierst und dann bist du tot.
So, wir schließen einfach die Tür ab, dann kommst du nicht mehr raus.
Ja genau, wir machen auf Kühlschrank und schließen die Tür ab. Weil die Türen sind natürlich dann auch so gesteuert. Die gehen ja auch so Star Trek-mäßig nur noch irgendwie auf Detection auf und zu. Und das wird dann auch einfach abgeschaltet. Das wird schon spaßig in der Zukunft.
Der ist ziemlich zufrieden mit dem Ding. Also wir hatten ja auch in den Kommentaren danach so eher auch verhalten-kritisches Zeug. Also das ist so ja ist noch alles eher Beta und so, dieses ganze Zeug.
Das ist sau billig.
Also er hat jetzt für komplette Hausausstattung 200 Euro gezahlt. Also für alles.
Das finde ich. Und das war ja schon also auch nicht nur aus...
200 Euro?
Also es gibt so einen zentralen Cube, den muss man einmal haben, der sozusagen sich um den ganzen Funkverkehr kümmert. Der kostet irgendwie 60 Euro. Und dann kosten so diese ganzen Heizungsregler, die da so, also nimmst du schraubst die alten...
Thermostat-Dringer.
Thermostat-Dringer runter und knallst das da drauf. Das kostet irgendwie pro Gerät 20 Euro. Und so ein Türöffner, so gucken, ob das Fenster offen ist, kostet auch so um die 20 Euro. Also ist tatsächlich jetzt nicht so...
Und alle per Funk und mit kleiner Batterie oder was?
Und alles per Funk und mit kleiner Batterie und beliebig von überall aus steuerbar. Und er hat jetzt nicht, im Keller hat er das jetzt nicht und ich glaube im Gästezimmer kann das auch nicht automatisch sein, aber so den ganzen Lebensbereich, der wird darüber, so über diese Anlage steuert.
Und der Sinn und Zweck davon ist ja schon auch um Strom sparen oder? Und um Energie sparen.
Bisschen Energie sparen, ein bisschen Komfort. Also ich finde das schon ganz geil so.
Na wo ist der Komfort? Also die Fenster gehen dann nicht von alleine auf und zu zum Beispiel, sondern...
Also aber die Möglichkeit zu haben, wenn man...
Achso, er muss jetzt nicht mehr zu allen Heizungen rennen, sondern er kann das jetzt so steuern.
Du liegst im Bett und denkst, oh das ist ja kalt, ich mach noch mal kurz die Heizung so ein bisschen an. Du brauchst nicht mal das Bett zu verlassen. Sonst kannst du das direkt mit dem iPhone machen. Der Bildschirm ist schon angegangen.
Der wollte auch Energie sparen.
Und das finde ich, kann man schon machen. Also das ist so... Ja, das klang jetzt erstmal, fand ich, gar nicht so verkehrt. Und was jetzt allerdings...
Das müsste er aber schon ordentlich Energie sparen, wenn er aus dem Haus geht und sagt, ich gehe jetzt arbeiten. Sind deine Eltern noch arbeiten? Ja, die arbeiten noch. Wenn er sagt, er ist jetzt zack 8 Stunden weg, wenn sie beide morgens das Haus verlassen, dann kann das Haus erstmal alles klar. Die können jetzt hier erstmal voll auf 5 Grad runter für die nächsten 6 Stunden und dann erst langsam wieder hoch, bis die da sind.
Ich fänd's halt geil, wenn die eine API hätten. Das kriegen die natürlich nicht auf die Reihe, eine vernünftige API zu bauen. Ach so, gesteuert wird das ganze Ding. Er hat's eingerichtet, er wusste nicht mehr genau, wie er's eingerichtet hat. Auf jeden Fall hat er kein PC gebraucht. Es gibt eine Mac-Software für, und damit kann man das wohl auch alles einrichten. Danach läuft die Steuerung komplett über eine Webseite. Also du gehst auf eine Webseite, loggst dich da ein und die greift auf dein Gerät zu Hause zu, auf deine Box. Also egal, ob du von zu Hause aus deine Heizung umstellst oder ob du das von Amerika ausmachst, macht wirklich überhaupt keinen Unterschied für das Gerät. Und die machen auch mal regelmäßig Software-Updates der Seite, was dazu führt, dass die auch Features nachrüsten.
Und die Seite läuft bei ELV?
Genau, die läuft bei denen. Das kostet dann auch irgendwie eine Gebühr pro Jahr. Ich glaube, ein Jahr ist dabei oder zwei Jahre. Danach kostet es drei Euro pro Jahr, glaube ich.
Das heißt, deine Heizungssteuerung ist eigentlich in Dritthand?
Ja.
Muss man ja nicht so machen.
Ja, muss man nicht so machen, aber es ist jetzt nur mal, ja.
Aber wenn DSL ausfällt, also die Box hat offensichtlich, die wird von außen programmiert, ist jetzt nicht so, dass wenn DSL ausfällt und morgens, wenn die Heizung anspringt, solltest du keinen DSL haben, dass dann die Heizung nicht anspringt. Sondern das geht noch, das merkt sich dann irgendwie die Box wohl.
Ich hoffe, dass da schon die Hacker auch irgendwie kommen und dann irgendwie alles schick irgendwie alles öffnen oder open sourcen und das dann auch Apis gibt.
Ich meine, so mit einer Api, so Geofencing. Ich meine, wie man in EYK5 hat diese Geofencing-Api.
Ja, wenn man nicht mehr in der Nähe von seinem Haus ist, Schwupp, Kältermachen.
Genau. So, hey, ich bin auf dem Weg nach Hause, mach die Heizung an.
Aber ich meine, man könnte ja Besuch haben oder deine Mutter ist noch da oder du bist halt noch da.
Sollte sich ein iPhone kaufen.
Eigentlich wäre schicker, wenn das Haus irgendwie durch Sensoren selber merkt, ob da noch wer rumrennt oder nicht. Und wenn es halt irgendwie klein genug ist, dass es nicht die Katze ist, die dafür sorgt, dass die ganze Zeit die Heizung ballert. Weil die Katze, die kriegt das irgendwann mit und läuft so lange vor dem Sensor hin und her, bis die Heizung so aufgedreht wird, dass sie sich drauflegen kann. Das Katzen sind voll schlimm.
Die haben so einen großen Knopf, wenn der Letzte das Haus verlässt, drückt die diesen Knopf und dann gehen alle Heizungen im Haus aus. Den haben sie auch. Und irgendwas wollte ich noch erzählen. Ach so, ja, aber was halt auch bei deren Software total nervt, was ich an meiner Heizung so unerträglich finde, ich hab auch so was wie Tim hier hat, so ein Ding an der Wand hängen mit irgendeinem hässlichen LCD-Display dran und man kann es nicht bedienen.
Ja, die sind voll schlimm und vor allem die regeln ja gleich immer alle Heizungen auf einmal irgendwie so ganz komisch. Man kann gar nicht mehr die Zimmer einzeln regeln mit diesen Dingern.
Na doch, du kannst ja eine Heizung immer noch selber runterdrehen. Ja, das kannst du schon noch machen. Die regeln halt den zentralen Durchlauferhitzer, den du irgendwo um 12.00 Uhr im Haus hängen hast. Der hat halt nur eine Regelung. Aber was ich bei den Dingern so furchtbar finde, die haben keinen Feiertagsmodus. Also du kannst, normalerweise kann man die ja so einstellen, dass in einer Woche...
Ach so, weil die den halt auch nicht kennen und so.
Na nicht nur, dass sie ihn nicht kennen.
Haben die überhaupt ein Datum?
Die haben Wochentag drinne. Und die haben eine Uhrzeit drinne. Und die können sich halt merken, so Montag bis Freitag. Oder man kann das auch tageweise genau regeln, wenn man mag. Aber wir haben Montag bis Freitag, da sind wir halt nur morgens und abends da. Und am Wochenende sind wir die ganze Zeit über da. Bist du mal am Wochenende in der Woche zu Hause, weil du jetzt z.B. krank bist, bumm, geht um 11 die Heizung aus. Also 11 Uhr morgens. Und dann rennst du hin und stellst das auf den Tag Modus und sagst, hey, mach an. Und dann vergisst du es natürlich abends wieder auszuschalten. Und dann wachst du morgens um 5 auf, weil die Wohnung total warm ist. Oder eben merkst du, dass du die ganze Zeit durchgeheizt hast, wie ein Bekloppter. Und dass sie nicht einfach eine Taste haben, du, Feiertag. Ich bin heute zu Hause, mach einfach so, als ob Wochenende wäre. Das sind so Sachen, die fehlen. Und das hat das Ding auch nicht. Und auch diese iPhone-Steuerung hat nicht zum Beispiel den Fall, was ich so... Also bei uns ist das Schlafzimmer immer relativ kühl. Aber jetzt im Winter war es manchmal auch zu kalt. Und dann hätte man einfach gerne so, mach jetzt nochmal eine halbe Stunde ein bisschen warm. Oder eine dreiviertel Stunde. Also bis wir eingeschlafen sind. Danach ist es ja ganz angenehm, wenn es kühl ist. Das kann auch keiner von diesen Heizungen. Man kann also auch diesem Ding hier, diesem ELV Ding, kann man nicht sagen, du mach jetzt mal eine halbe Stunde. Nee, Quatsch! Stimmt, das geht sogar. Man kann sogar mit getimt, aber man kann nicht sagen, mach mal warm, sondern muss dann immer explizit sagen, mach mal auf 22,35 Grad Celsius. Aber das kann man dann auch sagen, zeitlich begrenzt auf bis Uhrzeit oder sowas. Also das kann man schon sehr detailliert programmieren.
Da geht noch was.
Da geht noch was, aber es ist auf jeden Fall schon mal so, dass man sagen kann, kann man schon mal ausprobieren. Also wie gesagt, mein Vater, ich dachte, der Herr Schmeister, ich hätte auch sagen können, dass er das wieder zurückschickt oder sowas, aber der ist echt glücklich damit.
Und sag mal dieses, wir haben ja da mal angefangen, drüber zu reden, weil dieses, diese eine angebliche oder...
Dieses Ami-Ding.
Ja genau, dieses Nest heißt es, dieser angebliche... Tony Verderr hieß der genau, iPhone oder iOS-Developer, keine Ahnung was, aber GUI-Designer, weiß nicht. Gibt es das inzwischen auch schon irgendwie so ein bisschen für Europa oder noch gar nicht? Oder wie geht es der Firma an sich? Es ist schief gelaufen, ich klicke hier bei denen gerade so ein bisschen, aber es ist jetzt nichts zu sehen. Also ich kann hier von Europa noch nichts entdecken, weil früher meinten sie erst mal noch nicht so, aber es gibt es ja nun auch schon eine Weile.
Also da kann ich ein Update zugeben, und zwar habe ich da, ich lese ja hier von Marco Amendt das Blog, und der hat sich das damals gekauft für sein Haus und war am Anfang total, also war entsetzt. Und zwar ist das nämlich so, das Ding hat, da kommen bestimmte Drähte ran, und es gibt eine reine Stromversorgungsdraht, der nichts weiter macht, als das Ding mit Strom zu versorgen. Und damit das halt die ganze Zeit über betrieben wird. Und der hat jetzt, sein Haus hatte das einfach nicht. Das hatte diesen Stromversorgungsdraht.
Aber wie wurde dann sein Teil dann?
Genau, das ist jetzt die Spannung. Also vorher, die er abgenommen hat, die entsprechenden Einstellgeräte, die waren so, dass da Batterien drin waren. Man musste alle paar Wochen oder Monate mal die Batterien auswechseln, damit das Ding anbleibt. Und dann hat er das halt dran geschaut. Und darum haben die so einen Trick drin, diese Dinger, und zwar die machen so Burst-Modi. Das heißt, sobald die Heizung an ist, kommt auch Strom. Und zwar nur, wenn die Heizung an ist. Das heißt, die Dinger heizen mal zwischendurch für zwei Sekunden. Die schmeißen die Heizung an, haben für zwei Sekunden Strom, nutzen das, um den Akku so ein bisschen zu laden.
Diese Nest-Dinger.
Ja, und gehen danach wieder aus.
Machen danach die Heizung wieder aus.
Und das ist normalerweise so. Diese Boiler haben offensichtlich eine relativ hohe Trägheiz, sodass du davon nichts mitkriegst. Also die geht halt kurz an und dann geht sie halt wieder aus. Du merkst es nicht und irgendwann ist das Ding voll geladen. Jetzt hatte der aber eine Heizung, die schnell genug war. Und er hat irgendwo eine Sound-Datei hochgespielt, die so wirklich so... Wieder aus.
Fünf Sekunden später wieder...
Und wieder aus. Wie so ein Flammenwerfer, diese Flamme, die immer an ist.
Genau.
Und du brennt die voll durch, zwei Sekunden lang, wie so ein Afterburner, und geht wieder aus. Du sitzt dann in deinem Raum und denkst dir, what the fuck.
Nein, nicht nur das, sondern das klang auch wirklich so, als ob da irgendwas Mechanisches passiert. Mit anderen Worten, da arbeitet irgendwas auf Verschleiß.
Oh Mann.
Und dann haben die das von Nest mitbekommen und haben ihnen einen Techniker vorbeigeschickt, der das dann alles repariert hat und der ihnen noch die Leitung gelegt hat und weiß ja teufel was. Und... Dann hat er das... Irgendwie jetzt geht's alles und jetzt ist es alles gut und dann hat er jetzt noch irgendwie ein Zimmer ausgebaut, irgendwie sein Arbeitszimmer ausgebaut, hat dann eine Heizung verlegen, hat gesagt, okay, mach ich keinen Nest wegen dem Stress, den ich schon mal hatte.
Hätte gleich nur die Kabel mit Strom halt da langlegen müssen. Irgendwie so.
Wie war denn das jetzt? Weiß ich nicht mehr. Kann sein, dass die auch noch irgendwie lagen, aber ich weiß es nicht. Auf jeden Fall dann... Nee, die liegen da sogar. Aber er wollte halt, er hatte halt irgendwie so ein bisschen so kein Bock da drauf. Weil nach den schlechten Erfahrungen und hat sich dann vom Techniker, vom Heizungsinstallateur so einen ganz klassischen beige Kasten installieren lassen, setzt sich am Abend vor dem Fernseher und hört... Geht das Ganze wieder los.
Genau das gleiche mit dem beige Kasten.
Genau das gleiche. Der beige Kasten hatte das nämlich auch.
Das heißt, das machen alle so.
Das machen die alle so.
Und zwar er hatte sogar den Draht, also der kam da aus der Wand raus und der Elektroinstallateur hat offensichtlich einfach ein entsprechendes Gerät, was das einfach nicht kann, angeschlossen. Und was das so lädt. Und daraufhin hat er dann kurzerhand bei Ebay, sich noch zwei so Nestteile gekauft und hat die dann auch mitinstalliert, so nach dem Motto, naja, die haben wenigstens den richtigen Draht dran und scheint ja auch nicht besser zu gehen. Und er musste sich, das war auch die Quintessenz der Geschichte für mich, er musste sich die bei Ebay kaufen, weil regulär kriegt man die immer noch nicht innerhalb von einer vernünftigen Zeit. Also die scheinen noch echt gut im Geschäft zu sein und ziemliche Lieferengpässe zu haben. Oder sie produzieren nicht genug. Hier haben wir noch irgendwie den Link mit der Sounddatei drin. Achso, hier ist nochmal alles erklärt mit jedem einzelnen Draht. Ich würde sagen, auf dem kann man auch nochmal da verlinken.
Ja, kann man immer so eine längeren Story, ist ja immer ganz schick.
Ja, das ist eigentlich schon echt ganz cool. Und warte mal, was passiert jetzt, wenn ich das hier einfach auf...
Das ist dieses Geräusch.
Aber es ist doch... Da war gar nichts zu hören, dass so was an- und ausgeht.
Das klingt ein bisschen wie so ein Science-Fiction-Spiel.
Klingt irgendwie auf so einem Alien-Raumschiff oder so. Tim ist noch nicht da, mal gucken. Der wollte jetzt irgendwann mal per Dingsen dazusteußen. Aber bisher hat er das noch nicht getan. Ach ja, das ist so die... Noch was hab ich mir... Soll ich noch erzählen, was ich mir gekauft hab? Ja, ja, hau aus. Ich hab ja dieses Zeppelin-Air-Ding gehabt. Achso, da kann ich ja noch mal ein Update geben.
Macht mal.
Das haben sie jetzt wieder zurück haben wollen, nachdem ich das lange genug getestet hab.
So eine Teststation von so einer...
Bauer's, Billkins, genau. Das ist so ein Zeppelin, nicht frauenkompatibel. Also meine Freundin konnte das auf den Tod nicht ausstehen. Die war auch sehr glücklich, als es wieder weg war.
Sieht aus wie eine Riesenpille.
Sieht aus wie eine Riesenpille, genau.
Sieht nicht aus wie ein Zäppchen?
Ja, so ein Zäppchen.
Ein Zäppchen, was man von beiden Richtungen reinstellen kann.
Nur halt größer.
So eine Football-Pille.
Und der hat... Und das ging ja nicht... Das ging nicht mit einem iPhone 4S zusammen. Also man konnte das iPhone 4S vorne reinstecken in die Station zum Aufladen. Und dann konnte man auch abspielen. Aber das, wofür ich es haben wollte, nämlich für Airplay, das ging nicht. Auf dem iPad 2 war das überhaupt gar kein Problem. Das war auf dem iPhone 4 kein Problem. Auf dem iPhone 4S ging es an zu spielen. Nach 5 Sekunden war einfach Ende Gelände, ging nicht mehr. Ähm, keine Ahnung, woran das liegt. Ich hab's noch mal bei denen nachgefragt, in der Presseabteilung meinte dann so zurück, ja, Apple ist schuld. Und, ähm, keine Ahnung, das war so eher so, ja, blub blub blub blub blub. Genau, und dann haben sie gesagt, ja, aber wir haben gehört, mit der iPhone 5.1 Beta wird's besser. Und das war so irgendwie im November, ich dachte, naja, okay, iPhone 4, 5.1 Beta, die wird ja bestimmt bald kommen, dann behalte ich das Ding einfach noch so lang und dann probiere ich es aus, dass es klappt. Hat ja dann noch eine ganze Weile gedauert bis iOS 5.1. Aber ich kann berichten, es funktioniert!
Hat Apple wirklich irgendwas geändert?
Nein, also ja, Apple hat offensichtlich was geändert. Ich weiß aber nicht, ob, also ich meine, ob jetzt, ob es jetzt Apple schuld war oder ob das die Schuld von deren Chips war und die einfach nur so lange gebraucht hätten, um ein Update rauszuräumen, dass Apple gesagt hat, ok, wir fixen das mal auf unserer Seite. Weiß ich nicht. Also ich weiß jetzt nicht, wessen Schuld es war. Aber mit iOS 5.1 funktioniert dieses Zappeli-Ding ganz gut. Aber alles in allem, ich kann, also der Sound war echt super. Das muss man wirklich sagen. Das Ding konnte so einen Raum auch schön ganz gut füllen und sowas. Aber darüber hinaus, also die WLAN-Verbindung war unglaublich wackelig. Also ich hab ja nun, WLAN ist, wie ich schon erwähnt habe, nicht allzu doll in meiner Wohnung, aber ich hab ein Apple-TV, mit dem hab ich keine Probleme. Dagegen mit diesem AirPod, mit diesem Zeppelinding. Es hat die ganze Zeit über, gab's regelmäßig mal so alle halbe Stunde mindestens einen Ruckler und dass es ausgefallen war, dass man's wieder starten musste. Es ist eigentlich zu teuer für sein Geld. Und jetzt hab ich mir stattdessen gekauft, hab ich gedacht, okay, ich brauch eigentlich, und was natürlich auch das Ding ist, was will man wirklich machen? Also klar hin und wieder will man Musik hören, aber die meiste Zeit, man will eigentlich ein Radio. Und also wofür wir das Ding nutzen, ist, wir setzen uns morgens in die Küche und wir wollen ein bisschen Radio hören. Dann holst du das iPhone raus oder das iPad, machst dann so, startest irgendwie deine Lieblings-Stream-App, drückst da rum, sagst dann, fang an zu spielen, dann fängt da irgendwann an zu spielen. Und dann verlässt das Haus eine halbe Stunde später und plötzlich sitzt die Freundin ohne Radio da, weil du aus der WLAN empfangst, ein Reichweite bist oder eben umgekehrt. Also eigentlich, so hab ich mir gedacht, eigentlich ist es nicht das, was ich haben wollte.
Du brauchst halt noch einen iPod, der drin stecken bleibt.
Ich hab's jetzt so gemacht, ich bin dann zu Amazon gegangen, hab wirklich so blind ins Regal quasi reingegriffen, bei den WLAN-Radios, hab dann gedacht, na okay.
Du hast bei Amazon ins Regal gegriffen.
Und hab mir dann so eine Logitech-Squeeze-Box daraus geholt, weil ich dachte, ach, das klingt doch gar nicht mal so schlecht. Und in rot, falls es...
Ja, aber das ist schon das Safari 5.2, hä?
Ich benutze Chrome. Ist das Internet gerade kaputt, oder ist das... Irgendwas passiert. Das sieht so ein bisschen aus wie so ein... Hat mir noch das Zubehör dazu gekauft. Was man nämlich separat kaufen muss, ist ein Kit aus Fernbedienung und Akku-Pack.
Also muss ich das jetzt so vorstellen, wie so eine Art Radio mit Display und Boxen drin.
Das sieht so ein bisschen aus wie so ein Braunradio mit zu vielen Tasten. Hat auch ein bisschen zu viele Tasten. Und ist aber soweit ganz okay. Also man hat so sechs frei programmierbare Tasten, wo man dann so Sender oder irgendwas drauflegen kann oder irgendwelche Playlists, wenn man die hat. Der Volume-Button ist der kleine da aus irgendeinem Grund.
Der große ist wieder in Empfang, ja?
Na der große ist so wie bei so einem iPod. Also man kann entweder dran drehen oder eben so drauf drücken.
Ach so, das hat ja gar kein UKW mehr. Ich bin früher bei Radio bei sonst wo. Genau, das heißt Streaming.
Und dann hab ich so geguckt, was kann dieses Ding denn eigentlich so? Und das ist eigentlich verdammt geil. Weil, also man hat so eine Software, so ein Squeezebox Media Center heißt das, glaube ich. Die kann man sich unter, die läuft Logitech Media Center, so heißt das. Die kann man sich, die läuft auf dem Mac, die läuft unter Windows. Die läuft unter Debian, die läuft, die ist in Perl geschrieben, die läuft überall. Also du kannst das, die ist in Perl geschrieben. Du installierst so ein Perl-Script und danach hast du diesen Server da drauf. Ich hab das jetzt in die Cloud gepackt, hab da irgendwo meine ganze Musik und meinen Logitech Media Server rumfliegen und hab das Ding zu Hause damit verbunden. So, das ist so das erste, was eigentlich sogar ganz cool war. Und dann kann man auch über diese Webseite, also ich könnte jetzt auch von hier aus zu Hause die Musik steuern, auf was da gerade abgespielt wird und das Radio ein- und ausschalten und so eine Späße. Dann das nächste Ding ist, dass man über Lua, was so eine Sprache ist, ich weiß nicht, so eine Skriptsprache für Embedded-Systeme.
Für alles Mögliche. Die ist halt ziemlich klein. Also World of Warcraft zum Beispiel ist eigentlich Lua-geskriptet. Also alle Events, die bei World of Warcraft stattfinden, sind Lua-geskriptet. Und die User können sich mit Lua-Skripten auch eigene Programmchen irgendwie machen und zum Beispiel das Auktionshaus parsen und so weiter. Es gibt ganz viele Extensions und so. Also World of Warcraft-Kits, die ein bisschen besser sind, können Lua-coden.
Okay, dann könnt ihr jetzt auch eure Squeezebox da Erweiterungen für bauen. Weil da gibt's, also da kann man per Lua, da kann man eigene Bildschirmschoner draufpacken. Du kannst eigene Apps, es gibt eine Spotify-App sogar dafür. Es gibt die Möglichkeit, man kann sich per Facebook einloggen und kann seine Bilder angucken. Man kann sich seine Termine anzeigen lassen.
Aber es ist ein bisschen klein, oder? Wie groß ist denn das Teil?
Für Anzeigen ist es total ungeeignet, aber um Musik abzuspielen, ist es echt geil. Und wenn man so einen Spotify, ich hab keinen, ich hatte so einen Account, so hier hatten sie jetzt, als es in Deutschland gestartet hat, 48 Stunden, da hab ich das mal ausprobiert, das war schon ganz cool. Da kann man dann einfach so sein Radio mitlaufen lassen. Ja, es gibt da viele Erweiterungen für. Und wenn einem das nicht reicht, dann hab ich dann in den Menüsstrukturen irgendwie so externen Zugang einschalten gefunden. Und dann kann man nämlich den SSH-Demonstrat starten und dann hat man da eine schöne Shell drauf. Dann kann man darauf machen, was man will. Da ist ein Linux drauf. Und wir haben es jetzt noch nicht gemacht. Ich hab mir ja mal mit meinem Kollegen Toto vorgenommen, dass wir mal da hier SharePort, ne wie heißt es? SharePlay, SharePlay drauf portieren. Ah, ich krieg's nie richtig auf die Reihe. SharePort drauf portieren. Der C-Code dürfte relativ unproblematisch sein, was halt das Problem ist. Nee, da ist so ein kleiner C-Kern drinne. Und dann draußenrum ist noch ein Perl-Script. Und den Teil, also entweder man bringt auf dem Ding da irgendwie Perl zum Laufen, wobei der hat insgesamt nur 8 MB Flash-Speicher drinne. Da jetzt dann eine komplette Perl-Distribution drauf zu pappen, dürfte wahrscheinlich das System doch ganz schön auslasten. Oder alternativ, man fängt jetzt nochmal an, den Teil dann vielleicht auch nochmal in C nachzucoden. Das ist wohl irgendwie so ein wesentlichen, so ein HTTP-artiger Server, den man da irgendwie aufsetzen muss.
Oder in Lua.
Oder in Lua, naja.
Na ja, doch, das könnte gehen, weil das Perl macht jetzt auch nicht so doll viel, weil das Abspielen macht ja nicht das Lua, sondern was anderes. Das heißt, der muss nur ein bisschen Daten managen, mehr nicht?
Also eigentlich, ja, das würde alles, ich vermute mal, das würde alles gehen. Und das macht auf jeden Fall eine Menge her. Was total scheiße ist an dem Teil, die Fernbedienung, ist, also eigentlich, was braucht man an so einem Teil von der großen Entfernung? Man braucht nämlich diese sechs programmierbaren Tasten. Man muss einen ausschalten können und man muss lauter leiser machen. Mehrhin, das brauch ich darüber nicht. Was ist auf der Fernbedienung nicht vorhanden? Diese sechs frei programmierbaren Tasten. Das heißt, man kann sich da zwar durch die Menüsstruktur hangeln, in der Fernbedienung, aber da man dann eh meistens zu weit weg sitzt, um das Display noch zu erkennen, also das ist echt ein bisschen bescheuert. Aber ansonsten finde ich...
Jetzt müsstest du aber nochmal den Preis kurz sagen für dieses ganze Feature.
Stimmt, jetzt muss ich das Ding nochmal sagen, was das kostet. Das kostet... Ach so, falscher Rechner.
Bei Amazon im Regal.
Und wie groß ist das, wie man sich das jetzt vorstellen kann? Also wir machen ja eh einen Link mit unserer Liste, nehme ich mal an. Tippt, aber...
Ah, Squeezebox. Also die Squeezebox kostet 120 Euro. Ich glaube, ich hab noch 5 Euro mehr bezahlt für Rot. Und was ich dann noch dazu gekauft habe, ist das Radiozubehör-Kit. Also Akku und Fernbedienung für 37,54 Euro. Dass das nicht dabei ist, ist ein bisschen...
Was ist denn das Radiozubehör-Kit?
Nein, ein Akku-Impf. Das ist eigentlich ganz cool. Also dabei ist ein Netzteil und du steckst das ganz normal hin. Aber wir haben ja so eine kleine Terrasse, wenn man es da mal mit rausschleppen will, wie so ein altes Kofferradio oder ins Bad.
Und da sind natürlich keine D-Zellen, die da reinkommen oder so, sondern irgendein extra Akku.
Das kriegt man. Also ich glaube, du würdest das problemlos hinkriegen. Das ist irgendein Standard. Also es sind keine AA-Batterien. So schlau waren sie dann doch. Aber ich habe auch eine Anleitung gefunden, wie sich das jemand so recht gelötet hat dafür. Das ist relativ unproblematisch. Und es ist halt irgendeine Fernbedienung dabei. Wobei ich mir auch sehr sicher bin, dass da bestimmt auch Lürg für gibt und weiß der Teufel was, dass man auch eigene Fernbedienung für anschließen kann. Achso, und sie haben eine sehr hässliche, aber durchaus funktionierende iPhone-App. Es gibt diesen Squeeze-Client, der Lua-Interpreter, den gibt es für alles. Den gibt es auch für den Mac, für den Desktop. Und man kann in einer sehr hässlichen Mac-Desktop-App, die eigentlich, glaube ich, dafür gedacht ist, um so eine Lua-Skripte zu entwickeln, kann man auch komplett seine Squeezebox steuern. Und ich glaube, das, was auf dem iPhone läuft, was sie da auch gebaut haben, ist auch nur noch so ein Lua-Interpreter, der dann deine Squeezebox da oben steuert. Also das ist, das Ding hat so macht seinen Eindruck, als ob da irgendwie ein paar Ingenieure eingesperrt wurden. So baut ihr mal ein WLAN-Radio und dann haben sie diese Weltbeherrschungsmaschine am Ende gebaut. Also das ist echt krass. Aber funktioniert.
Und welchen hast du jetzt? Ich sehe hier, da gibt es verschiedene unterschiedliche.
Warte mal, ich pack den hier gerade nochmal. Also ich hab den... Richtig stabil. Ich hab das Radio. Also es ist so ein kleines Monoradio-Teil. Touch ist glaube ich im Zeitalter des iPods ein bisschen überflüssig. Das kostet irgendwie eher des iPads. Das ist hier irgendwie so eine... Ja, keine Ahnung. Das ist halt ein etwas größeres Bildschirm und offensichtlich ein Touch-Display. Kostet dann irgendwie 200 Euro. Und für ein bisschen mehr Wumms ist hier noch dieses... wie heißt das andere? Du hattest es doch gerade vorgelesen.
Ja, ich hab... Hast du auch schon wieder vergessen. Nee, ich hab schon weggeblättert.
Ach, weggeblättert. Ach die haben ja auch noch ein... Nee, das ist... Ah, jetzt finde ich ihn nicht mehr. Gut, also es gibt dann auch irgendwie so ein etwas teures Gerät mit Stereo und Superboom. Genau, der hat dann etwas größere Boxen drin. Und man kann die auch... Das hab ich nicht ausprobiert, aus Mangel an Geräten, aber man kann auch mehrere Geräte miteinander synchronisieren. Also man kann auch sagen, Spiel auf dem ab, das gleiche wie auf dem anderen. Und ich nehme mal an, dass die da irgendwie so ein Latenzreduktionsprogramm haben. Aber wie gesagt, keine Ahnung, hab ich nicht ausprobiert, aber das Ding kann wesentlich mehr, als es aussieht. Erstmal. Da war ich doch sehr beeindruckt von. Jetzt musst du was von NanoSIM erzählen.
NanoSIM, naja, viel gibt's nicht zu erzählen. Also Apple hat irgendwie, ähm, ja, nee, fang ich mal anders an. Der Nachfolgestandard von der MicroSIM ist irgendwie das entsprechende Standardisierungsgremium, hat den Herstellern gesagt, ja, wir standardisieren was und lasst euch mal was einfallen. Soweit ich weiß, bin mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher. Also Nokia, wir wollten ja eigentlich nicht über Nokia reden, aber egal. Nokia hat irgendwie einen Vorschlag eingereicht, RIM hat wohl einen Vorschlag eingereicht und jetzt halt Apple auch einen Vorschlag eingereicht. Und, ähm, da wurden sie dann alle ganz nervös. Und dann hat Apple noch dazu geschrieben, so mehr oder weniger, wir überlassen sämtliche Patente kostenfrei allen Lizenznehmern, wenn die anderen, die da Patente drauf haben, das auch machen, sollte dieser Standard verabschiedet werden. Was ich eigentlich ganz fair finde.
Was für Patente dafür, dass man so einen Sim-Schneider hat, wo man einmal so ausstanzt? Patente auf die Stanze?
Das ist nämlich der Gag an dem Nano-Sim-Vorschlag von Apple, dass die die Pin-Belegung nicht geändert haben und auch das Pin-Layout nicht geändert haben, sondern das Teil einfach nur noch kleiner gemacht haben. Während die anderen Vorschläge sehen so ein bisschen aus, das eine wie so eine MicroSD-Karte und das andere auch so ähnlich, irgendwie so mit mit Kontakten an der Seite. Also an der Seite? Ja, wie so eine SD-Karte, nur ganz klein. So, dass man es irgendwo reinschieben kann. Also, dass man nicht ein Tray hat, wo man es reintut und dann sind die Kontakte an der Seite, sondern sind irgendwie an einer im Ende, sodass du die Karte dann quasi durch eine Öffnung im Gehäuse reinschieben kannst und dann ist die Karte halt da drin, fertig. Irgendwie so. Ja, keine Ahnung. Also Apple, Quatsch, Nokia hat sich fürchterlich aufgeregt. Das wäre ja ganz schlimm, dass Apple jetzt diesen Markt auch noch beherrschen wollte.
Und nicht mehr Nokia.
Ja, findet euch mit der Realität ab. Mir ist ja aufgefallen mit dem neuen iPad jetzt. Ich hab damals, als ich mir das erste iPad geholt hatte, hatte ich ja mit 3G, da gab es ja in Deutschland noch gar keine Micro-SIM, da hab ich mir so zurecht geschnitzt die SIM-Karte und wollte die dann so lange behalten, bis es in Deutschland auch vernünftige Micro-SIM-Karten gibt. Jetzt hab ich die ins dritte iPad gepackt, dieselbe SIM-Karte, also Provisorien halten am längsten.
Ja, ich hab die damals, hab ich mir die geholt, weil ich hab ja noch eine weitere gebraucht. Und die Leute von O2 haben gesagt, ja klar, machen wir, müssen wir nur die andere SIM-Karte auch austauschen, dass man die zusammen irgendwie auf dem gleichen Vertrag benutzen kann. Und was haben sie dann gemacht? Haben mir die Micro-SIM auf Telefon gestellt und die nicht Micro-SIM nur auf Daten. Und ich hätte es aber andersrum gebraucht.
Das kann man aber auf deinem Website ändern.
Jaja, hab ich dann auch gemacht.
Da ging relativ viel.
Und jetzt, seit ich das 4S hab, da hab ich dann die große SIM-Karte auch klein geschnitzt.
Ja, das geht eigentlich simpel, ne?
Wenn man eine als Vorlage hat schon, dann kann man einfach gucken. Und so ganz perfekt muss es nicht sein, die Kontaktflächen sind ja relativ groß. Und da ist schon auch ein bisschen Spiel, was man irgendwie hat. Am Ende muss es halt in dieses Metallding reinpassen. Und wenn es da drin ist, dann geht's eigentlich.
Ja, es sollte halt nicht zu viel Spiel haben.
Nee, klar.
Wenn man vorsichtig immer wieder ein bisschen was abschnitzt.
Aber ob man jetzt um einen halben Millimeter zu viel links, zu viel rechts ist, Hauptsache es passt rein. Dann geht das schon. Bei dem Nano wird es dann wahrscheinlich ein bisschen schwerer, weil es wird ja immer enger.
Die Herausforderung wird jedes Mal wachsen. Irgendwann muss man dann auch schon mal ein bisschen was gravieren.
Ja, aber ich denke diesmal die Hersteller, also hier O2, die nicht herstellt, die Provider, die kennen ja das Spielchen schon jetzt und die werden es sich nicht entgehen lassen, dass wenn das nächste iPhone rauskommt, dann stehen die nicht komplett ohne da, sondern die werden sich wohl immer ein bisschen vorbereiten, weil diesmal hängen die ja schon im Business auch fett mit drin. Am Anfang war es ja so, dass dann nur Telekom und so weiter, und dann war es O2 ja auch egal. Inzwischen gibt es ja freie iPhones und dann wollen natürlich alle das Feature haben, dass man auch gleich die passende Karte dazu kriegt.
Aber war nicht? Das iPad war doch das erste mit Micro-SIM. Da waren sie alle gleich hinterher. Da war nicht nur die Telekom und so.
Doch, die waren relativ schnell dabei.
Da konnte man auch bei Apple sofort auf der Seite alles bestellen. Der gab es ja immer ohne Vertrag nur zu kaufen. Man konnte es ja mit allen Herstellern sofort von und so.
Ich glaube, ein Vorteil an der Nano-SIM ist natürlich auch dadurch, dass sich das Layout nicht geändert haben, dass man halt so eine Karte produzieren kann, wo man rausbrechen kann und zwar in der Größe, die man braucht.
Das gab es ja früher schon bei den Original-SIM-Karten, die noch so richtig...
Man muss ja dazusagen, dass die Original-SIM-Karten so groß waren wie Kreditkarten, oder? Und da war dann dieses kleine normale SIM zum rausbrechen oder Mini-SIM oder wie auch immer das dann hieß. Und dann das jetzige, das ist auch schon als rausbrechen, ich habe das noch nicht gesehen. Das gibt es auch als rausbrechen.
Also die Nano-SIM, die mir O2 gegeben hat, die war so auch in dieser originalgroßen Karte. Man hätte sie als normale SIM rausbrechen können, aber man konnte sie zusätzlich noch als Nano-SIM rausbrechen.
Also drei Karten in einer quasi.
Und den nächsten vier in einer.
Mein Cousin hat als einer der ersten so ein GSM-Telefon. Und das war ein geiles Teil, das war irgendwie so so groß wie so ein Telefonbuch von Berlin ungefähr. Mit so einem Schultergurt, dass man das über die Schulter hängen konnte.
Und da hast du dann diese Handykarte reingeschoben.
Und der Hörer war per Spiralkabel an diesem Kofferchen dabei.
Das war aber noch vor D-Netz oder? Das war noch so C-Netz oder sowas?
Nee, nee, das war.
Das war GSM schon?
Das war GSM schon, ja.
Krass. Also mein Vater war einer der ersten E-Plus-Kunden. Oder ein relativ früher, weil wir waren damals, wir sind, meine Eltern haben ein Haus gebaut und es gab ewig lange da kein Telefon, wo wir hingezogen sind. Und darum musste das per Handy gehen, dann konnte man nur so am Fenster ein bisschen per Handy telefonieren. Und das war noch so ein Motorola-Knochen und da musste auch die komplette SIM-Karte da unten reingeschoben. Das war so, die waren auch so groß, dass es jetzt in so ein iPhone, da würde die eigentlich zumindest vom äußeren Format eigentlich wieder so eine komplette SIM-Karte reinpassen. Zwischen euch die Handy-Generation ging das ja überhaupt nicht.
Ja, dann ist aber die SIM-Karte größer als das Motherboard auf dem iPhone.
Ist das die aktuelle SIM-Karte nicht auch?
Größer als der Akku, der da drin ist.
Damals. Wie Opa's. Sie sollten uns vielleicht mal so einen 17-jährigen Apple-Fan einladen.
Es gab ein iPad 2?
Ich muss mal ganz kurz Urtu loben, fällt mir ein, wo wir gerade bei SIM-Karten sind.
Weil wir jetzt Empfang haben hier, oder?
Weil wir jetzt Empfang haben hier. Und weil der Empfang von Urtu, wir haben ja, ich hab mich ja Ende letzten Jahres ganz furchtbar hier in diesem Podcast über Urtu aufgeregt, dann muss man sich auch mal wieder ein bisschen öffentlichkeitswirksam abregen. Die haben ja damals irgendwie dieses Wir-sind-Einzelfall von Möfio, diese Aktion, haben die ja offensichtlich ernst genommen. Und das ist, also ich hab wirklich seit Monaten keine Probleme mehr gehabt. Das heißt jetzt nicht, dass ich überall ein megaschnelles Netz habe oder sowas. Und das ist, wenn man glücklicher Telekom-Kunde ist, dann wird man bestimmt immer noch schnelleres Netz haben, als ich armer kleiner Urtu-Kunde. Aber so für den üblichen Surf, Twitter, Reader-House-Gebrauch und für unterwegs hab ich in letzter Zeit immer gut funktionierendes Netz. Und das wirklich schon auf Holzklopfen seit Monaten. Also das ist...
Stimmt, seit diese Welle der Empörung abgeappt ist, hatte ich eigentlich, obwohl ich hatte auch währenddessen nie so große Probleme wie andere Leute.
Also ich hatte wirklich, dass ich tagelang, also dass ich, mir ist aufgefallen, dass ich nach Hause gekommen hab, eine iMessage gekriegt, die eigentlich hätte, die ich hätte vor drei Stunden kriegen müssen. Und ich bin einfach den ganzen Tag unterwegs geworden, hab nicht einmal Empfang gehabt.
Nee, ist mir so krass nicht...
Und das hatte ich jetzt schon sehr, sehr, sehr lange nicht mehr. Also das funktioniert. Auch am iPad ist alles super und so. Die scheinen da wirklich ganz relativ schnell, zumindest hier in Berlin, nachgelegt zu haben. Könnte ich ja mal berichten, wie es bei euch ist.
Also ich müsste mal gucken, da in Friedrichshain, wo ich arbeite, da ist es so, da gehe ich aus der Firma raus und wenn ich dann meine, jetzt bist du auf der Straße, fragst du Siri irgendwas, bin ich genau im Funkloch drin. Das heißt dann ist so, geht nicht, kein Netz.
Nutzt du Siri?
Äh, nicht wirklich.
Gab es ja schon so ein Studio, dass alle mit Siri total glücklich sind, alle iPhone-Kunden. Also ich nutze es im Augenblick eigentlich gar nicht mehr.
Naja, auf Deutsch geht halt auch nicht viel. Ich meine, du kannst nach der Uhrzeit fragen und du kannst nach dem Wetter fragen.
Da wollte ich nicht fragen.
Naja, sagen wir mal so, wenn du es in der Tasche hast, eh gerade Podcast hörst, dann kannst du natürlich irgendwie Siri anmachen und nach der Uhrzeit fragen.
Also ich hab auch schon iMessage per Siri verschickt, das funktioniert noch ganz hervorragend, aber ich hab's nie gemacht. Und am iPad haben sie jetzt, das iPad hat jetzt kein Siri. Hat zwar jetzt den schönen Record-Button auf der Tastatur drauf, mit dem man jetzt auch Spracherkennung nutzen kann.
Ja, das ist mir völlig unklar, warum sie kein Siri auf dem iPad haben. Also ich meine, letzten Endes kann es ja kein Hardware-Problem sein. Also das ist wahrscheinlich genauso, wie du keinen Taschenrechner auf dem iPad hast und keine Uhr. Also das ist auch was, was ich nicht verstehe. Warum hab ich keinen Taschenrechner und keine Uhr auf dem iPad?
Na vielleicht dachte sie sich, dass dann genug Drittanbieter irgendwie auf den Plan springen und die dann noch mal extra 30 Prozent verdienen.
Könnte aber durchaus ein Hardwaregrund sein, dass das iPad kein Siri hat, nämlich ich glaube, die Spracherkennung ist, also das Mikro ist einfach nicht so dolle.
Du meinst, die haben diesen Chip da nicht mit drauf?
Naja, ich weiß überhaupt nicht, wo hier das Mikro ist, aber ach, hier oben, da in dem Slot, würde ich sagen, hier oben ist der Klamm.
Wenn dein Mikro von deinem Klopfhörerkabel reicht...
Naja, aber das ist halbwegs nah am Mund dran.
Wenn ich das hier so...
Ich nehme an, wenn ich es über den Kopfhörer habe, dass es dann relativ gut geht, aber ich habe hier mal diese Spracherkennung ausprobiert, einfach so reingequatscht, als es so vor mir lag, und das funktionierte erschreckend schlecht. Also die Siri-Spracherkennung, wenn man einfach so einen Text tippt, die ist ja schon gut. Ich weiß nicht, wie deine Erfahrungen so sind. Und hier war wirklich so, über die Hälfte der Wörter stimmten nicht. Jetzt hab ich vielleicht extrem genuschelt, aber ich hab auch halt so, wie man mit so einem iPad da sitzt, nämlich tendenziell eher weiter weggesessen. Vielleicht ist aber auch ein kleiner Vermarktungsgrund, kann natürlich auch sein.
Aber ich meine, du hast auch Facetime auf dem Ding, das muss doch auch irgendwie gehen. Das ist ja auch mit Ton.
Das geht auch. Ja, aber nicht gut genug für Spracherkennung. Sie haben ja auch vom iPhone 4 aufs iPhone 4S haben sie ja auch den Sprachchip verbessert, dass der im iPhone 4S Siri-tauglich wird. Und das aber auch eine bessere Sprachqualität bietet. Okay, hier im Chat meint Egghead, dass die Spracherkennung auf dem iPad genauso gut geht wie auf dem iPhone, aber...
Der Chip macht ja nicht Spracherkennung, der macht ja eher die Unterdrückung von anderen. Also, dass er besser Deins rausfiltert, indem er über das andere Mikro die Umgehomuskleräusche aufnimmt, damit er die dann wegfiltern kann.
Aber ich weiß nicht mal, wie viele Mikros das Ding überhaupt hat. Ich würde mich nicht wundern, wenn es nur dieses eine hier oben hat, dann hat sich der Salat...
Also ich finde, es ist völlig absurd, dass kein Siri mit dabei ist.
Aber schlimm ist es auch nicht.
Aber schlimm ist es auch nicht. Na gut, ich hab eh kein iPad 3, aber insofern ist es nicht mein Problem.
Instacast.
Apple Store, genau, jetzt geht's los.
Instacast, Apple Store, ja das ist...
Wenn Tim nicht da ist, können wir ja noch ein bisschen Apple bashen. Obwohl macht der ja auch inzwischen.
Ja, der, ähm, jetzt fällt mir der Name nicht ein. Dieser Mensch, der Instacast macht, der hat ja neulich...
Martin.
Martin, genau Martin. Hering, Hering, irgendwie so. Martin, genau, der hat neulich ein Update gemacht für Instacast. Und, ähm, wurde dann abgelehnt, weil ein, der, der Reviewer von Apple, sich den, ähm, den offiziellen Feed von Apple zum Thema diesen, diesen... Keynote Feed gezogen hatte. Und in dem Vorschaubild zu dem Keynote Feed war natürlich ein Apple-Logo.
Und deswegen hat er den Instacast abgelehnt?
Und deswegen haben sie Instacast abgelehnt, weil er ja ein Apple-Logo verwendet hätte.
Dabei war das von einer externen Quelle, nämlich von Apple selber.
Genau.
Was stellen die da für Reviewer ein bitte?
Das ist total absurd. Und was hat Martin gemacht, das fand ich total geil. Er hat einfach den entsprechenden Keynote Feed aus seinem Verzeichnis geschmissen und hat es nochmal neu eingereicht und dann kam es durch.
Peinlich, peinlich. Machen die das schon in Indien oder sonst wo irgendwie auf dem Mond? Das ist schon ein bisschen komisch, oder? Er muss doch wissen, was er abonniert hat und dass es nicht von der App ist.
Vor allen Dingen, es ist ja nicht von vornherein. Das ist ja, wenn du die App das erste Mal installierst, du hast ja einfach nichts abonniert. Es hätte ja sein können, dass es irgendwie so ein paar Feats schon vorabonniert sind oder sowas.
Nee, er hat ja so ein Podcast-Verzeichnis, das er irgendwie auch selber pflegt.
Genau, aber der Typ muss gesagt haben, füge einen Podcast hinzu, mal nach Apple gesucht. Vielleicht hat er nicht nach Apple gesucht, vielleicht war der da auch in einem vorgeschlagenen schon drin oder sowas, aber auf jeden Fall.
Also dieses Podcast-Verzeichnis ist ja relativ gut gemacht in diesem Instacast. Eigentlich schon fast so gut gemacht, dass du gar nicht so richtig merkst, dass du jetzt in einem Verzeichnis nachguckst, um dir Feeds anzukucken. Sondern es wären dir halt einfach Sachen vorgeschlagen und da greift man dann einfach zu. Und das kann ich mir schon dann auch vorstellen, dass es nicht super offensichtlich ist, dass es jetzt halt vielleicht auch dann doch externer Content ist. Aber trotzdem, also irgendwie.
Aber ich glaube, die stellen auch ziemliche Honks ein. Aber ich hab auch mal, ich hab da neulich mit jemand drüber gesprochen und ich hab jetzt leider die Zahlen wieder vergessen. Aber man kann ja mal überschlagen, wie viele App-Reviews Apple pro Tag so macht. Also wenn man mal so ausrechnet, wie viele Apps so pro Tag oder pro Jahr in den App-Store hinzukommen. Ich meine, wie viele sind das jetzt? 200.000 oder sowas? Wie viele Apps sind im App-Store?
Keine Ahnung.
200.000 war schon lange durch. Ist auch schon ähnlich durch, glaube ich.
Wo steht denn sowas? Wo steht denn hier? Wie viele? Sagen wir mal, ah ja, hier gibt's ne Presseerklärung mit über 500.000 Apps ist die offizielle Werbung. Seit wann gibt's den App-Store?
Seit 2008.
Seit 2008, also sind 500.000 durch 4 Jahre. Falls die alle gleich, das wären 125.000 pro Jahr. 125.000.
Das ist jetzt noch ohne Updates, ne?
Das ist ohne Updates. Das sind 342 pro Tag. Und zwar wirklich, jetzt kann man natürlich eigentlich davon ausgehen, dass es heute mindestens doppelt so viele sind, weil es steigt ja immer weiter an die Zahl.
Ich glaube, Apple hat doch mal gepostet, wie viele Leute sie da haben, nachdem es mal irgendwie da so ein bisschen Ärger gab. Und ich glaube, sie hatten noch was erzählt, dass es so einzelne Teams sind und insgesamt waren es irgendwie 40, 50 Leute. Das ist aber schon auch echt wieder lange her. Ich weiß nicht, ob vielleicht ein Hörer weiß da mehr was. Ich weiß, da gab es irgendwie mal was, wo Apple mal gesagt hat, so ein bisschen wie, wie viele Leute sie da irgendwie am Start haben. Oder der Grube hat was gepostet, ich weiß nicht so genau. Also es müssen schon ganz schön viele sein.
Das müssen echt viele sein. Und ich meine, so, lasst das so 500 neue Apps pro Tag sein, dann nochmal irgendwie 1000 Updates dazu, dann haben wir da 1500 so eine Updates. Das ist schon echt Arbeit. Und mittlerweile stellen die ja auch, es gibt, hab ich selber noch nicht ausprobiert, aber man kann sich wohl auch mittlerweile sagen, in welchem Land das Review-Team sitzen soll, was man gerne hätte. Also man kann als Deutscher sagen, hier ich möchte, dass das auch von einem Deutschen gereviewed wird. Weil, so, wenn da jetzt irgendwie ein Amerikaner deine...
Also wenn du natürlich sagst, mein Programm ist eh nur in Deutsch, was soll der Amerikaner da machen? Obwohl, nee, darf man gar nicht. Englisch ist immer Pflicht, richtig?
Englisch ist Pflicht?
Ich glaube, Englisch musste man immer unterstützen. Bin mir aber jetzt nicht so sicher. Man konnte zwar schon sagen, dass es nur in Deutschland... Wahrscheinlich war das der Grund, damit die Videoer halt auch was machen können. Ich glaube, du kannst schon sagen, es soll nur in Deutschland kommen, aber mir war so, als wenn man Englisch immer unterstützen müsste. Bin mir aber jetzt auch nicht so sicher, aber...
Der Tim meint, ich soll mal...
Der fliegende Reporter ruft jetzt an.
Der fliegende Reporter ruft an. So, was ist jetzt hier? Skype ist an.
Aber es gibt doch so Apps wie von Plus oder von Netto oder von, weiß ich nicht...
Ja, vielleicht liege ich jetzt auch falsch. Vielleicht ist es inzwischen auch überholt.
Ah, man kann den Tim... Kann man den Tim... Man kann ihn hören. Kann ich ihn hören?
Das ist sehr beruhigend, wenn man mich hören könnte.
Ist relativ leise, ne?
Das klingt wie ein bisschen aus dem Klo, aber es ist der Codec, nehme ich mal an.
Ja, vermutlich.
Nee, das ist nicht der Codec, ich sitze im Klo.
Wieso ist da endlich Ruhe?
Kannst du mal die Spülung betätigen? Wir glauben dir das nicht.
Hab ich grad. Ja, Video, ich weiß nicht, ob das geht. Ich bin hier leider in einem sehr halligen Raum, das leider gerade der einzige Ort, der leise ist und Netz hat.
Wo bist du denn überhaupt?
Ich bin grad weg.
Hab ich auch schon mal gesehen.
Du weißt schon, das ist schön. So, ihr seid gerade bei Podcast-Verzeichnissen? Oder was wollt ihr?
Wir waren gerade bei der peinlichen Instacast App Rejection von Apple.
Ja, redet ihr doch erstmal. Ich steig dann mal an.
Also du lauschst erstmal zu. Dann dachte ich, wir machen jetzt weiter, weil wir gerade bei den App Store Rejections sind. In letzter Zeit ging es wohl damit los, wie Apple auch schon im letzten Jahr ankündigte. Da haben sie gesagt, sie werden dieses ja, wie soll man sagen, das Verwenden der UDID in iOS-Apps ist nicht mehr gewollt und wird in Zukunft auch nicht mehr, wie sagt man, durch den Store gelassen. Und jetzt geht es gerade los, wo in den letzten Tagen oder letzte Woche dass halt gewisse Apps, also noch nicht von allen Reviewer-Teams, aber von einigen wohl, dass Apps, die halt die UDID benutzen, dass die rejected werden. Jetzt muss man kurz erzählen, was die UDID ist. Und zwar kann man sich, wenn man eine iOS-App baut und ich will ja auch sehen, irgendwie wie oft meine User kommen, also man will ja schon so ein bisschen User-Tracking machen, kann man sich vom iPhone sagen lassen, hier gib mir doch mal deine Unique ID, weil so heißt das Ding nämlich. Und dann weiß ich alles klar, der, der heute hier war, der kam letzte Woche auch schon und irgendwie so ist es.
Unique Device ID ist es.
Genau, Unique Device. Damit kann man jedenfalls einzelne iPhones tracken, da weiß ich, der war letzte Woche schon da und der ist heute schon wieder da und so weiter. So, das ist eigentlich auch alles ganz schön, das Problem ist nur angenommen, der Roddy schreibt halt auch eine App und dann kann er sich auch diese Device ID geben lassen und er kriegt halt sogar die gleiche, das heißt er kann sehen oder wir könnten uns dann irgendwie abstimmen und da steigen dann die Ad-Netzwerke ein, weil die lassen die sich natürlich geben. Kann man halt vergleichen, welcher User, welche Programme benutzt und so weiter. Das fanden die bei Apple nicht toll. Und ich weiß jetzt noch nicht so richtig, was...
Fanden auch Leute außerhalb von Apple nicht so toll.
Ja, ich eigentlich auch nicht.
Kann ich auch gut verstehen, muss ich sagen.
Die sollen auch mal ein Adressbuch holen, wie jeder andere Mensch auch.
Also ich hab ja auch schon mal die U, die ID, in meinem iOS-App, was ich mal geholtet hab für eine Firma, auch benutzt, weil ich brauchte die auch. Aber mich hätte es jetzt auch nicht gestört, wenn ich von dem iOS eine ID kriege, die sozusagen durch mein Programm nochmal geändert wurde. Also am besten, die durch jedes App hat ja auch eine eigene ID, wenn es mit der nochmal durchgemixed werden würde, sodass Roddy eine kriegt und ich eine kriege, wir die selber auch für uns benutzen können, aber die untereinander halt nicht gleich sind. Und so müssten sich ja eigentlich lösen, aber bisher weiß ich noch nicht, wie Apple das...
Doch, so eine Lösung gibt es auch schon. Jaja, es gibt die schon so lange, wie sie die UDID auch abschaffen wollen.
Ja, und wie heißt die? Also UDID ist halt ein Call, kann man sich von wahrscheinlich NS-Application oder was, ich hab keine Ahnung, kann man sich die halt geben lassen?
Wie die andere heißt?
UI-Application.
UI-Application, ja, Entschuldigung.
UI-Device.
Ja, irgendeine Klasse halt. Und da müsste es eigentlich was anderes geben. Also so gesehen, ich finde den Schritt von Apple eigentlich ganz okay. Angekündigt haben sie ihn auch, also darf sie jetzt eigentlich auch nicht wirklich jemanden aufregen.
Also gucken die tatsächlich, ob der API-Call stattfindet?
Ich denke mal schon. Also es ist ja manchmal so, du schiebst deine App bei Apple hoch und dann dauert es irgendwie ein paar Stunden und dann kommt schon die Rejection. Und dann denkst du auch, der hat doch noch, hat sich noch gar keiner angeguckt. Also die haben da schon es gerippt irgendwie am Start, wo sie mal so die grundsätzliche Policy eintragen und da haben sie jetzt halt mit reingeklatscht. Wenn einer sich die Juli-ID geben lässt, dann ist irgendwie gleich Feierabend. Dann kriegst du gleich deine Rejection, was ja okay ist. Also ich meine, die Leute haben... Genau, was ich vielleicht cooler finden würde, ist, wenn sie, als sie letztes Jahr gesagt haben, dass sie die Juli-ID nicht mehr möchten, dass sie das auch schon in ihr Script eingebaut hätten. Aber wie beim Compilen, dass man halt nicht den Error kriegt, sondern die Warning, dass man weiß, okay, demnächst ist es nicht mehr okay. Aber dass man schon immer so, hier, kümmer dich, weil bald nicht mehr.
Ja, vor allen Dingen, wenn sie gesagt hätten, zum So und Sovielten schalten wir das ab. Und bis dahin dürft ihr das noch. Und wenn sie das vorher gesagt hätten und nicht plötzlich ab Tag So und Soviel werden, alle Leute rejected, die das immer noch machen.
Wobei, da gab es ja auch letztens einen Artikel, wo einer meinte, dass wenn Apple das genau so macht, dann nutzen das alle, User genau, bis zum letzten Tag. Und updaten dann alle auf einmal. Und das wäre halt irgendwie auch nicht so toll. Deswegen hat sich Apple gedacht, da die hören eh nicht auf uns.
Ich sag das so gut aus.
Ja, genau, da hatten wir doch das Thema. Und deswegen macht Apple jetzt einfach harte Schnitte. Und naja, also wie gesagt, sie wurden vorgewarnt.
Zu dem Test nochmal, also sie testen eigentlich alle API-Calls. Und vor allen Dingen testen sie auch, ob du Private APIs benutzt, was du nämlich auch nicht darfst. Das haben sie irgendwann eingeführt, dass sie also automatisch das Binary durchchecken, ob du bestimmte Sachen aufrufst, beziehungsweise ob du das, was du aufrufst, auch aufrufen darfst. Ich weiß nicht, ob du nicht mit diesem ganzen Objective, Sifu, Magic, da irgendwie drum rum kommst und zur Laufzeit dir deinen Call zusammen machst.
Na klar, ist ja nur ein String, du musst den halt... Achso, wenn sie den Call selbst sehen. Ja, ich kann dann nur von meinem Kumpel erzählen, der hatte in seiner App, weil Apple das halt nicht angeboten hat, hat sich jetzt wohl geändert, der hatte Promo-Codes erlaubt. Das heißt, du konntest im App irgendwie, wenn du bestimmte Buttons oder Touches, also Flächen halt, in einer bestimmten Reihenfolge gedrückt hast, bist du halt in so ein Special-Menü gekommen, da konntest du ein Promo-Code eingeben und dann war die App freigeschaltet ohne In-App Purchase. Und das ging seit einem Jahr oder weiß nicht, wie lange gut oder noch länger sogar. Und jetzt hat er wieder nur so ein Mini-Update gemacht, gar nichts Großes und dann kriegt er auf einmal eine Rejection von Apple, steht drin, da so hier Promo-Code geht gar nicht. Also sie haben halt anscheinend wirklich im Binary gesehen, dass da irgendwas von Promo-Code irgendwie stand. Haben das gesehen und haben gesagt, hier ist nicht. Weil die Button haben die niemals gefunden. Also das kann es ja nicht sein. Und dann hat er zugeschrieben, naja, hier eure Schuld, weil ihr bietet halt keine Promo-Codes an. Und die haben natürlich nicht geantwortet, aber tatsächlich ein, zwei Wochen später meint er, jetzt könnte man bei Apple irgendwie Promo-Codes irgendwie offiziell einbauen und das wäre als gar kein Problem mehr.
Sagt dir der Name Will Shipley was?
Ja, das ist doch der iLibrary oder Library-Typ, oder?
Delicious Library.
Delicious Library, der ehemalige Omni-Group.
Ja, genau. Der hat gestern einen riesigen Blogpost, Rant, geschrieben da drüber, dass es doch irgendwie mörderisch sei für Mac-Entwickler, dass es keinen Updates, keinen bezahlten Updates im App-Store gibt. Mal sehen, ob sich was tut, wenn der das Maul aufreißt.
Ja, müsste wahrscheinlich schon irgendwann kommen, oder?
Tim, kannst du sie jetzt besser hören?
Ja, das ist immer noch mit zerhacktem Audio-Scheiß.
Was ich noch erzählen kann, die haben ja sogar wiegend zu teurer Apps im App-Store, es gibt jetzt, hat ein bisschen Wellen geschlagen, Draw-Code heißt das, glaube ich, Draw-Code oder Paint-Code, jetzt muss ich den Namen Paint-Code, ist so was, ein Zeichenprogramm, also ein Malprogramm, so ein Vektor-Grafikprogramm, was Objective-C-Code rausschmeißt. Das ist ganz lustig, also man kann, man legt quasi einen Button an, kann auch einen String reinpacken, kann auch beliebige Teile, also ich hab jetzt hier mal so einen Button offen, kann auch sagen, also ich hab jetzt hier einen Text drinne stehen, kann auch sagen, du bist jetzt ab sofort eine Variable, dann wird hier unten dem Code, den er live erzeugt, auch die entsprechende Variable angelegt. Ist natürlich alles schön retina-tauglich, wie sich das so gehört, und passt für alle Auflösungen. Und ist noch nicht so richtig perfekt, aber es funktioniert erstaunlich gut, muss ich sagen. Und kann man so gerade für Button, also ich meine, ich hab eine lange Diskussion mit Leuten gehabt, ob das denn überhaupt gut ist oder nicht. Weil so ein PNG zum Mal, also erstens, erstens Grafik und Code ist natürlich sowieso immer nicht so eine schöne Sache. Wobei, da ist man ja gerade bei iOS sehr viel gewöhnt, dass man seinen Layout halt gehend in Code macht.
Wie heißt das Programm?
Paint Code.
Also ein bisschen wie Pain Code, aber...
So, aber beim iOS jetzt hier mit dem, wie heißt das hier, nicht das Springboard, nee Quatsch, wie heißt das Ding?
Storyboard.
Storyboard, genau, das ist doch super.
Na, es geht langsam in eine okaye Richtung, das stimmt.
Also, das war schon ziemlich cool. Also ich hab damit schon auch was gemacht.
Ich hab damit neulich was gemacht und wir hatten doch ganz schöne Schmerzen dabei auch. Also so eine statische Table zu bauen. Und wie will man dann, also hast du deine, also Tabellen bauen jetzt für die, die es nicht wissen. Und da IOS ist ein relativ simples Feature, aber man nutzt halt Tabellen nicht nur, um tabellare Daten nachzustellen.
Man missbraucht die, weil man die schicke Optik von Sections haben will, richtig?
Genau, man macht daraus irgendwelche Menüs und das ist da ziemlich schmerzhaft, weil da muss man über die Texte reinschreiben. Und dafür haben sie jetzt unter anderem...
Du meinst hier dann so in dem Form, ne? Ich zeig dem Max hier gerade meine Bitcoin-App und das ist genau...
Das ist auch ein Table-View?
Das ist auch ein Table-View, ja.
Das hätte ich jetzt nicht erkannt. Ja, nee, ganz so. Ja, und dafür haben sie jetzt was gebaut, dass man das jetzt relativ komfortabel, so statische Tables zurecht machen kann. Und Tim ist jetzt noch dabei. Und das geht mit dem Storyboard ganz gut. Aber wie man jetzt im Code dann den Tab zum Beispiel, so didSelectRowAtIndexPass, abfängt, das haben wir dann so gemacht, dass wir uns da den Reusable, wie heißt das?
Aber da gibt es auch, haben die doch einen Callback für und da kriegt man es doch. Kann ich dir nach der Sendung zeigen, ich hab den Code da, da kann man das dann abfangen, irgendwie auch so ein Storyboard-Callback, wie auch immer der jetzt heißt, und dann da kommen alle rein und dann muss man die wieder auseinanderfrimeln, so wie halt vorher auch, da kriegt man auch Index und Row und kriegt das dann, ja.
Gut, dann haben wir den Teil nicht gemacht. Ah, da ist wieder Anruf. Ich hab den anruf...
Tim hat er einfach aufgelegt, ja?
Hat der Tim wieder aufgelegt. Ich höre die Anrufe nicht, weil ich den Ton abgeschaltet habe, damit ich nicht die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Skype-Anrufe mittendrin haben.
Aber du siehst die Anrufe.
Ich sehe die Anrufe, ja. Aber ich gucke halt nicht die ganze Zeit...
Ich will jetzt noch mal anrufen, weil das hört sich furchtbar an.
Ach so, du willst jetzt noch mal per Telefon anrufen, oder wie?
Nein, ich will den Skype-Call initiieren und ich möchte, dass du ihn annimmst.
Ja, hast du doch gerade, oder?
Stimmt richtig, das bringt auch nix, scheiße. Dann halt so.
Genau, das war...
Das ist eine Dreck-Software.
Oder lass uns mal iChat probieren. Hast du das auch?
Oh Gott, warte mal, jetzt muss ich ja noch iChat aufmachen. Redet ihr mal über was dann? Wir können ja Facetime starten.
Was haben wir dann noch auf der Themen? Roddy kann ja ein bisschen ein Mac-Update-Bundle erzählen. Dann hab ich nämlich meine Ruhe.
Okay, dazu gibt es jetzt auch ein Mittel viel zu erzählen. Heute ist irgendwie der letzte Tag, wo man dieses komische Mac-Update-Bundle noch kaufen kann. Da ist ein... Also ich krieg da jetzt kein Geld für, dass ich das erzähle. Das muss jetzt mal dazu sein.
Das hört sich aber vorhin noch ganz anders an.
Super. Also da ist ein VMware Fusion dabei. Das ist ganz interessant. Das kostet aber normal genauso viel wie das ganze Bundle.
Ja gut, aber wenn man zwei Sachen aus dem Bundle braucht und da sind ja wie viel? Zehn Sachen die da drin oder so?
Da sind irgendwie... Ja, ungefähr zehn.
Ist wieder One Password dabei oder sowas?
Nee, One Password ist nicht dabei. Es ist irgendwie so ein komischer PDF-Pen dabei, wo man PDFs bearbeiten kann. Und was möglicherweise... Na ja, es sind zwei Spiele dabei. Irgendwann Star Wars The Force unleashed und irgendein Warmscrumb, keine Ahnung. Und Forklift, ein FDP-Klient. Von dem ich nicht weiß, ob er gut ist.
Also ehrlich gesagt, FDP, wann hab ich zum letzten Mal FDP benutzt? Ich hab das früher echt viel benutzt, kenne mich auch aus damit, so ist alles gar kein Problem, aber...
Na ja, SFTP mache ich schon, aber FDP halt nicht.
Ich mach eigentlich immer alles direkt mit SCP, immer hinpumpen und fertig. Meine Shell hab ich eh offen dahin.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob es spannend ist, keine Ahnung. Kann man ja mal reingucken. Ich fand das jetzt nicht so spannend. Ich wollte es nur erwähnt haben, weil es läuft jetzt noch sieben Stunden und dann ist die gut.
Ja, für Leute, die irgendwie die Schnäppchen abgreifen wollen.
Ja, vor allen Dingen, wenn man Fusion braucht, haben will, dann ist es vielleicht ganz gut, wenn man noch ein anderes von dem Programm brauchen kann. Ansonsten, naja. Ich bin mit Virtual Box eigentlich so weit zufrieden, dass ich jetzt nicht unbedingt VMR Fusion haben muss.
Tim, sag mal, was ja am besten noch als Eingabequelle geeignet ist, als Mikro. Er zeigt dieses U24EXL, nehme ich nicht an, bei Sound, bei Mikrofon. Direkt vom Dante oder was?
Ja, was gibt es noch? Dann machen wir noch kleine Updates. Also irgendwie habe ich gesehen in letzter Zeit, die zwei größeren Updates, die ich hier bekomme, waren, Adium ist jetzt zum Chatten, ist jetzt endlich 64-Bit. Im Großen und Ganzen gibt es eigentlich nicht viel Neues, außer dass sie es jetzt mal auf 64-Bit umgestellt haben. Es war noch so eins der letzten Programme, die auf meinem Rechner nicht 64-Bit waren. Und es fällt einem sonst noch was Neues bei Adium ein. Sonst war da echt nichts, oder? Also es ist jetzt nichts, was dann noch zusätzlich groß war. Ist egal, jedenfalls ist die Version 1.5. Ach so, sie hatten irgendwelche, ja, die Lips, diese Update und so, ist alles nicht so spannend. Und dann gab es noch ein Update bei Colorquay, was ja jetzt viele, gerade die Leute, die bei uns hier im Irrgchat mit dabei sind, ich weiß nicht, was die nutzen, aber ich denke mal, eine Menge davon nutzen Colorquay. Die haben jetzt auch mal, der Typ bringt ganz, ganz selten Updates raus. Und der ist jetzt auf 10.7 only gegangen. Es geht vielleicht da jetzt auch mal ein bisschen vorwärts. Ich finde Koloquai toll. Das sind wohl einige andere Meinungen, aber ich mag das.
Hier haben wir jetzt auch gerade mal wieder Koloquai. Ich bin ja normalerweise Linkinus-Freund. Weiß ja teilweise warum.
Ja, jeder hat ja so anderen Kram.
Keine Ahnung, ich benutze das gut genug, als dass ich mich nach irgendwas anderem umgucken müsste.
Passwörter? Was für Passwörter? Ich hab da keine Passwörter. So, das wär das zu den kleinen Mini-Updates.
Hab ich noch was? Ach, eine Kleinigkeit zu Hardware. Meine Frau hat eine SD-Karte mitgewaschen in der Jeans.
Geht noch.
Hätte ich jetzt auch nichts anderes erwartet, ehrlich gesagt.
Echt? Ich hätte nicht erwartet, dass sie noch geht, aber offensichtlich war noch alle Daten drauf. Das hat mich irgendwie nicht...
Ja, ist doch so integriert und zugeschweißt. Also was soll da passieren? Ich denke, da kommt gar nichts mehr rein. Ich würde die Daten aber zumindest trotzdem retten, ja. Wenn es dann demnächst in einem Monat oder so innen drin dann weggerostet ist, dass du dann noch...
Ne, das mit dem Waschen, das ist ja schon ein halbes Jahr her. Oder ein Dreivierteljahr.
Verstehe. Und jetzt hast du sie gefunden oder wie? Oder wurde jedes Mal mitgewaschen?
Ne, ich hab die Hose seit der Zeit nicht mehr angehabt. Seit letztem Sommer und...
Muss ich mal kurz einen Screenshot machen? Das ist ihm nötig, dass man den Sound nicht abschalten kann.
So, dann musst du aber jetzt langsam mal machen da, weil uns gehen die Themen auf. Weil wir haben ja auch gar nicht mehr so viel, oder?
Wir haben auch gar nicht mehr so wahnsinnig viel.
Angry Birds in Space.
Ja, Schwein im Weltall. Das ist echt super. Also Angry Birds... Ich bin sowieso Angry Birds Fan, das hab ich ja vielleicht schon mal gesagt. Und es gibt halt jetzt dieses Angry Birds in Space als neues Update. Und das Geile daran ist, dass ist alles in Schwerelosigkeit, außer dass so ein paar Planeten da immer irgendwo sind, wo die Schweine drauf bauen. Und die haben natürlich ein entsprechendes Schwerefeld, sodass die Vögel in elliptischen Bahnen um dieses Schwerefeld rumfliegen.
Tim kann uns jetzt auch hören.
Tim kann uns jetzt auch hören. Das ist super. Und das macht unheimlich viel Laune, weil man plötzlich witzige Figuren schießen kann, weil die halt immer da der Schwerkraft entlangfliegen. Teilweise sind die Level auch sehr schwer, weil irgendwie das Schwerefeld dann nicht so ist, wie man sich's auf Anhieb vorstellt. Und dann fliegen die sonst wohin.
Ich war ja, ich konnte Angry Birds wirklich nie leiden. Ich hab's immer mal wieder ausprobiert, weil die halbe Welt schwärmt einem ja was davon vor. Und ich fand's immer furchtbar langweilig. Ich fand's auch immer, dass man... Da, wo der Katapult ist, wenn man den Katapult abschießt, sieht man meistens nicht im selben Moment, zumindest wenn man's auf dem iPhone spielt, sieht man nicht die Struktur, die man einwerfen muss, was eigentlich total albern ist. Also man muss da mal erst rauszoomen und sowas. Aber ich hab jetzt mir doch nochmal...
Auf dem iPad ist besser.
Genau, ich hab's mir jetzt mal auf dem iPad auch noch gekauft hier für... Funktioniert ganz hervorragend mit diesem tollen Retina-Display. Ist nicht volle Auflösung, aber ist schon ganz gut. Und das macht doch durchaus Spaß. Es ist immer noch nicht mein absolutes Lieblingsspiel. Definitiv nicht. Also ich bin ja eher so ein Puzzle-Mensch. Also da muss man ja wirklich... Man muss ja auch auf einen Millimeter... Also entweder ich bin zu blöd oder man muss wirklich auf einen Millimeter genau schießen. Und wenn man einen halben Grad nach oben oder nach unten schießt, dann trifft man schon... Dann gehen die blöden Dinger da schon nicht mehr kaputt. Also so richtig toll find ich das nicht.
Teilweise muss man da sehr exakt spielen.
Das stimmt. Ja, aber das macht echt Spaß. Also das fand ich, das hat es auch gemacht. So, jetzt müsste Tim eigentlich noch was...
Ja, ganz leise.
Ganz leise, warte mal, kann ich ein bisschen lauter machen irgendwie?
Tim, du müsstest vielleicht ein bisschen lauter machen.
Im iChat hat das noch irgendwie einen Pegel, den man nochmal nachredet.
Könnt ihr mich jetzt lauter hören? Ich hatte hier auch noch ein kleines Pegelproblem. Guck an, was es nicht alles so zu bedenken gibt bei Audio.
Plötzlich hört man dich.
Vor allem höre ich euch auch ohne Geknackel. Also dieses Skype ist ein echtes Problem. Das kann man echt nicht anders sagen. Manchmal ist es grandios beim Durchbrechen von Firewalls, aber es ist eine totale Niede im Umgang mit Audiointerfaces.
Dafür knackst du jetzt ein bisschen.
Jetzt knack ich? Ja, das liegt aber dann wahrscheinlich an meinem mangelnden Abloh. Wie schlimm ist es?
Ziemlich.
Jetzt wird es gerade schlimmer.
Es soll nicht sein, glaube ich, hier mit meiner Beteiligung.
Ist es okay, wenn wir ohne dich über die Konferenz reden oder möchtest du dabei sein?
Welche Konferenz?
Na, welche. Das Treffen.
Na, das interessiert mich auf jeden Fall, was ihr dazu sagen habt.
Na gut, dann machen wir es einfach aber nächstes Mal.
Darf ich noch eine Frage stellen? Wieso nicht? Ihr könnt ja auch hier drüber reden. Ich höre euch ja wunderbar an.
Dann erzählen wir mal so ein bisschen. Tim hat vor wann war das? Wochenende, nicht letztes Wochenende, vorletztes Wochenende. Podcaster, Leute, die mit Technik Podcasts zu tun haben. Kato hier zum Beispiel von xenem.de und so. Also alles, was er sich in Deutschland irgendwie entfernt mit Podcasts beschäftigt. Zusammen getrommelt hier in Berlin. Und hat eine kleine...
Also alles weißt du wirklich nicht.
Wow.
Kannst du das nochmal sagen?
Ich wollte nur sagen, dass das nicht alles war. Aber es waren so viele, wie ich irgendwie kriegen konnte.
Genau. Und... Waren... haben wir uns hier getroffen und es ging so um Podcast-Format. Und ich glaube, das Thema Podcasting ganz im Allgemeinen voranzubringen. War insofern sehr cool, dass wir mal alle kennengelernt haben. Also hier zum Beispiel Martin Hering von Instacast. War sehr nett. Kato mal zu treffen war auch sehr cool. Der sofort so, hey, und was wünschst du denn noch für so einen Streaming-Server, den wir hier so eine Infrastruktur haben? Okay, muss ich mal die Xenum-Struktur lieben, weil das funktioniert ja wirklich immer perfekt. Also ich hab Xenum wirklich selten. Okay, ich bin jetzt eigentlich nie auf der Hörerseite oder selten. Aber das funktioniert ja immer ganz hervorragend. Und ja, dann waren hier so ein paar Leute in Berlin und wir haben so über Formate geredet. Wie man mal so, zum Beispiel Kapitelmarken und so was, wie man das endlich mal vernünftig hinkriegen kann. Was ich jetzt ganz toll fand, hier die Jungs, das waren Österreicher, weiß nicht wie sie heißen, von Auphonic, die einen Dienst vorgestellt haben. Und das ist wirklich pures Gold für mich, weil ich versage ja gerade auch so ein bisschen, was heißt versagen, aber es fällt mir schwer mit meiner eigenen Podcasting-Infrastruktur. Ich hab mir zuhause angefangen, so ein kleines Studio aufzubauen und die Hörer haben sich immer beschwert, dass es zu leise ist. Spül mal wieder. Ja, und das ist halt nicht, dass es halt nicht zu sehr knallt, aber dass es trotzdem noch eine vernünftige Lautstärke ist, ist halt nicht so leicht hinzukriegen. Und die haben so einen Service auf die Beine gestellt. Du schmeißt da irgendwie eine Datei rein, in irgendeinem, also in einem möglichst guten Format, und du kriegst alles raus. Also die packen dir Bilder rein, die machen dann ein AAC draus, die machen dann ein MP3 draus, die machen dir dann ein OKT draus, die packen dir Kapitelmarken rein, du kannst Templates anlegen, was ja bei iTunes auch so ein totaler Schmerz ist, dass du jedes Mal, musst jedes Mal das Coverbild aufs Neue reinschmeißen. Du musst jedes Mal die Überschrift neu eingeben und eigentlich weiß er doch schon, wer in dem Podcast dabei ist, aber du musst es trotzdem jedes Mal neu eintippen. Und die können, was echt geil ist, die können sich die Daten von überall abholen und nach überall spielen. Also mein Workflow ist jetzt, ich pack die Sachen, das hochauflösende MP3, auf meine Dropbox, dann laden die sich das von der Dropbox runter und haben einen Public Key zu meinem Server, wo sie genau auf Einverzeichner zugreifen können, und können die Dateien direkt reinspielen. Das heißt, ich kann unterwegs mal zu Hause alles rendern. Das dauert ja bei so einem 3-4 Stunden Podcast. Da dauert das ja schon mal eine Stunde, bis so eine Datei rausgerendert ist. Kann ich in Dropbox sehen, die Datei ist fertig, sag dem Dienstbescheid, du schmeißt das mal an, und dann spielt er die auf den Server hoch, und ich kann das vom iPhone aus komplett steuern.
Du renderst die dann direkt in die Dropbox?
Ich mach bei mir in der Datei... Zu Hause. Mach ich zu Hause einen MP3 draus, genau. Das geht auf die Dropbox. Und dann holt sich das auf Phonic, holt sich das ab von meiner Dropbox, und mach dieses Sound-Enhancement, was wirklich eine Menge bringt, also dass die vernünftig leveln und so, dieses ganze Zeug, was man vorher nur mit viel Arbeit machen konnte. Und ja, mein Master ist genau, ist ein hochauflösendes MP3, das sind dann irgendwie 320kbit, das ist eine sehr große Datei dann. Und dann rechnen die das in die einzelnen Formate runter. Und dann kommt was Schönes, Kleines bei raus. Und ja, ich habe dann die Gelegenheit nochmal genutzt, mich mal, also ich habe auch eine Menge gelernt an dem Wochenende. Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch ging. Gut, ihr seid jetzt eher so ein bisschen maulfoul. Was ich gelernt habe, wie toll eigentlich AARC ist. Und zwar ist das, ich finde es ja immer nervig, dass man hat diese Webplayer, so und jetzt hat man schön HTML5-Player. Und wenn du da eine MP3-Datei drinne hast, und nehmen wir mal an, du würdest jetzt gerne, also was ich immer machen wollte, ich will Sharing haben. Ich möchte, dass Leute, die diese Sendung hier hören, sagen können, ha, diese Stelle finde ich besonders toll, teile ich, leite ich an meine Freunde weiter. Pack ich auf Twitter, also jetzt genau diese eine Stelle zum zitieren. Und das ist halt bei MP3, wenn du irgendwie drei Stunden, nach drei Stunden irgendwie 20 Sekunden hast, die geil sind, dann muss ein MP3 erstmal, müssen die ganzen drei Stunden geladen werden, bevor dann die paar Sekunden gespielt werden. Und da gibt's auch, haben wir ja auch lange drüber geredet, gibt's auch eigentlich, dann gibt's so Ranges und es gibt Apache-Erweiterungen, die das dann irgendwie halbwegs hinkriegen und alles ganz furchtbar schmerzhaft. Und ich wollte mir schon so ein HTTP-Live-Streaming-Server, so mit diesem Apple-HTTP-Live-Streaming, auf die Beine stellen, um das Problem zu lösen, weil ich dachte so, das bräuchte man dafür, was ja auch vom Aufwand her tatsächlich machbar wäre. Okay, Tim will was sagen, ich lass mich mal kurz aussprechen, dann lass ich dich gleich rein. Und das geht mit ARC ganz fantastisch. Das hat das nämlich direkt im Header drinne stehen, welche Minute und welche Sekunde an welcher Stelle drin sind. Und lädt dann nur die ersten paar Bytes oder Kilobyte. Und dann kann er direkt an die entsprechende Stelle springen, indem man den Server nur nach dem entsprechenden Sprachs fragt.
Das ist bei QuickTime diese Einstellung, dass man es optimiert für Streaming abspeichern möchte. Dann wird die so um 5% größer oder so und dann packt er das mit rein.
Krass, wusste ich nicht. Und seitdem funktioniert das ganz fantastisch. Also ich hab dann so einen kleinen Audioplayer geschrieben, der nicht den ganzen Scheiß nachleihen muss. So, jetzt darf Tim. Tim?
Ja, ich wollte da noch ein bisschen ergänzen. Das ist halt wirklich ein großartiges Projekt und jeder, der irgendwie mal mit Audio irgendwas macht, das muss jetzt gar nicht mal Podcasting sein. Jeder, der so das Problem hat, dass so Gespräche, die aufgenommen sind, danach nicht ordentlich klingen, da sollte man da schon irgendwie hellhörig werden, weil das Coole daran ist, dass sie eben ziemlich abgefahrene Leveling-Algorithmen da anstatt gebracht haben. Ich glaube, das hast du jetzt noch nicht erwähnt, oder?
Also ich wusste, dass sie die Soundqualität besser machen, ich wusste aber nicht inwiefern genau.
Ja, also das eigentliche Wunder ist, zumindest in der aktuellen Form, dass sie ein adaptives Leveling machen. Das heißt, sie gehen über das Audio rüber, machen erstmal eine Audioanalyse und wissen dann auf jeden Fall schon mal, da ist Musik, da ist Sprache und sorgen jetzt dafür, dass das eben lauter wird. Normalerweise ist so dieses Lautmachen immer das echte Problem. Dieses Klagen, Leute sagen, nachdem wir einen Podcast rausgehauen haben, ja, ich konnte aber nichts verstehen, war ja viel zu leise, lalala. Lautmachen ist echt schwierig. Und da haben sie halt mehrere interessante Ansätze. Das erste ist eben, dass sie zwischen Musik und Sprache unterscheiden, weil Sprache anders aufbearbeitet werden muss als Musik. Weil Sprache muss unter Umständen, wenn ich jetzt mal gerade ein bisschen leise rede und dann bin ich wieder ein bisschen laut, dann musst du halt diese beiden schnell aufeinander folgenden Teile ungefähr auf dieselbe Lautstärke bringen. Das willst du aber nicht mit Musik machen, weil dann zerreißt es dir halt die ganze eingebaute Dynamik. Wenn sich irgendwie so ein Musikstück aufbaut und dann eine laute Stelle hat oder so, dann willst du ja diesen Unterschied auch haben. Das heißt, auf Phonik guckst du erstmal in die Frequenzen rein und siehst, ah, alles klar, da ist nur Sprache, weil einfach nur an den Sprachbändern geredet wird und behandelt Musik und Sprache vollständig unabhängig. Das ist zum Beispiel anders als das dieser Levelator macht, den es ja auch seit langer Zeit gibt, der so auf eine ähnliche Art und Weise auf die Sprache losgeht. Deswegen klingt es schon mal besser. Der andere Grund ist, dass sie eben auch diese Lautnisstandards, diese neuen EU-Lautnistandards implementieren. Das heißt, sie gehen da nicht auf Beep oder so, dass die Linien im Audioprogramm alle auf der gleichen Höhe sind, sondern sie interpretieren eben frequenzabhängig, wie laut das jetzt tatsächlich normalerweise von einem Ohr gehört wird. Und bringen das wiederum auch auf eine einheitliche Lautnis, also eine Lautheit, nicht Lautstärke. Und der Effekt ist dann, oder soll sein, das ist nicht so, dass ich das jetzt selber überprüft habe, nehme ich jetzt einfach mal auf Phonik beim Wort, dass im Prinzip alle Podcasts, die durch auf Phonik durchlaufen, am Ende gleich laut sind. Und zwar nicht irgendwie gleich laut, so wie auf Phonik das gerne hätte, sondern so gleich laut, wie der kommende EBU-Broadcasting-Standard, das auch für Radio und Fernsehen laut meint. Also das ist schon mal eine bemerkenswerte Sache. Das zweite ist, dass derzeit noch gar nicht alles eingeschaltet ist. Das ist ja alles noch Beta. Was noch zukommen wird und was es auch schon gibt, was derzeit nur noch nicht in Produktivsystem eingeschaltet ist, ist eben auch noch eine Audio-Reparatur. Wenn der Analyzator, der über das Audio rübergeht, feststellt, da ist ja Brummen, Netzbrummen. Du hast da wieder einen Stecker nicht richtig reingesteckt, oder irgendwas nicht richtig geerdet, und du hast so ein leichtes Hrm. Dann erstellt er das und kann es rausnehmen. Außerdem sollen auch noch so Sachen wie Spikes gefunden werden. Wo das jetzt auch gerade schon im Chat gefragt wurde, da meinte einer, ich weiß nicht, ob er das ernst gemeint hat, aber das ist tatsächlich etwas, was in der Überlegung ist. Eine Erweiterung ist halt, dass man dann später auch Multitrack reinwerfen kann, und jede einzelne Spur einzeln reinwirft. Und das könnte natürlich dann auch die ganze Audio-Reparatur noch mal so richtig nach vorne bringen, weil du damit natürlich den Hauptfeind des Talk-Kunden-Podcasts eliminieren kannst, nämlich das Übersprechen, sprich das Aufnehmen einer Stimme über ein Podcast. Wir sitzen ja jetzt alle in einer Runde. Wenn Dennis was sagt, dann geht immer auch was bei Roddy ins Mikrofon etc. Das heißt, jede Stimme wird eigentlich über alle Mikrofone aufgenommen und durch so Sachen wie den Expander und so weiter, den wir da im Studio haben, versuchen wir das halt zu reduzieren, aber du kriegst es halt nie ganz weg. Und in dem Moment, wo du eben eine kluge Audio-Analyse hast, das ist ja der Witz da eben bei Aufonik, dass sie da mit Machine Learning-Algorithmen etc. da so richtig versuchen, Schlüsse zu ziehen aus dem Audio und gar nicht mal nur so jetzt pauschal irgendwas drauf anwenden, sondern sie schauen sich das halt an und in Abhängigkeit des tatsächlichen Inhalts wird halt die oder jene Maßnahme eingeleitet. Und so kannst du halt auch ein Übersprechen entdecken, weil wenn du siehst, oh hier ist das starke Signal und ich sehe zum selben Zeitpunkt in den anderen Spuren quasi eine Miniatur-Variante davon, dann kannst du sicher sagen, ah alles klar, übersprechen, das blende ich mal komplett aus. Und dadurch hast du dann auch noch besser isolierte Kanäle. Also das ist wirklich der Knaller. Und wo es auch wirklich interessant ist, das ist jetzt eigentlich das erste System, was in der Lage ist, Kapitelmarken für alle Formate zu setzen.
Auch schon für MP3 und so?
Auch für MP3 und auch für OK. Und dazu muss man sagen, vor vier Wochen gab es noch keinen Kapitelstandard für OK. Den haben die überhaupt erst losgetreten. Also da hat sich irgendwie nie einer für interessiert. Das ist ja hier unsere alte Debatte, kriegt ihr Formate etc. Und so wird ja immer viel auch mal gewünscht. Und mein Argument war halt immer, was ist der Vorteil davon? Und jetzt sind die Sachen überhaupt das erste Mal so halbwegs on par. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass man eben jetzt mit Aufwunsch auch noch eine ganze Menge andere Meta-Formate weiter durchsetzen kann. Kapitelmarken halte ich jetzt erstmal für das Wichtigste. Andere Sachen können dann folgen. Aber das Coole ist, man hat halt keine Arbeit mehr damit. Man sagt einfach, hier sind die Kapitel, hier sind meine Ausgabeformate und bang und dann ist das drin. Und das ist auch das erste System, das Kapitelmarken für ID3, also für MP3 implementiert. Dieser Standard ist jetzt seit sechs Jahren oder so, liegt ja auf dem Tisch und keiner hat das jemals angefasst. Und ich weiß auch, dass Instacast jetzt Kapitelsupport für MP3 einbauen will.
Oh, jetzt bist du gerade noch wieder ganz, ganz schlecht.
Potluff soll halt so das Projekt sein, das eben all diese Sachen in so ein Netzwerk gießt und dann sollen wir da gemeinsam vorankommen.
Genau.
Das ist eigentlich der Sinn der ganzen Geschichte.
Ja, das sollten wir nachher auch noch mal durch Auf Honig durchscheuchen. Brauche ich noch die Zugangsdaten für. Ja, das ist, also das macht, also dieses Auf Honig, das hat mich wirklich vom Hocker gehauen, weil es ist...
Ich verstehe immer noch Auf Honig.
Ach, Auf Honig. Auf Honig. Ja, also es ist wirklich Schmeiß rein, werd glücklich, das ist echt großartig. Und was war noch so? Gab noch einige andere Sachen, die da diskutiert wird, hier über dieses Podcasting-Fallformat. Wollen wir darüber jetzt noch was erzählen? Oder, da müsst du wirklich Tim, was glaube ich, darüber erzählen, oder?
Ja, ich meine, es wurde halt eine ganze Menge besprochen, wie man die Projekte zusammenbringen kann. Das mit dem großen Episoden-Fallformat, das ist, denke ich mal, jetzt Work in Progress. Da lässt sich noch nichts... Ist das wirklich so schlimm hier mit meinem Audio?
Also da sind sowieso Hacker immer die ganze Zeit, aber manchmal gehen halt so zwei, drei Wörter verloren.
Ja, ist ein Drama. Vielleicht einfach hier mal als letzter Beitrag. Also das erste, was es konkret derzeit gibt, ist dieses Simple Chapter Format. Das ist auf potlaf.org auch schon dokumentiert. Und das ist so ein allererster Versuch, mal zusätzliche Metadaten in Feeds unterzubringen.
Also so Sachen, Kapitelmarken, Bilder, Links, so ein ganzes Zeug.
Genau, also alles, was Podcasting besser macht, findet da seinen Raum.
So, woran ich jetzt noch dann, also für mich war das in erster Linie so ein sehr inspirierendes Wochenende, und was mich mal dazu gebracht hat, mich mit dem ganzen Thema zu beschäftigen. Ich kann ja mal kurz mein Podcasting Setup beschreiben, falls das interessiert. Also das ist so ein, was ich mir jetzt hingekriegt habe, also ich hab die alten Headset von Tim abgekauft, die ein Schweinegeld gekostet haben, und dann die Kabel, die so dämlichen Kabel, die hier dranhängen, da kostet ein Stück, wenn man das kauft bei BioDynamics, ist das? Genau, bei BioDynamics kostet so ein scheiß Kabel 50 Euro, das ist pro Stück, und davon braucht man dann drei. Dann hab ich noch so ein M-Audio NKV10, also so ein Firewire-Teil, mit dem man irgendwie so sechs oder sieben, also insgesamt hat es zehn Kanäle, und man kann, ich glaube, vier Mikros gleichzeitig anschließen. Also das ist schon ganz ordentlich. Das hat allerdings nur Firewire und kein Thunderbolt oder USB oder sowas, weswegen ich dann drauf gehofft hatte, dass es irgendwann noch mal ein Thunderbolt- auf Firewire-Adapter gibt. Die Hoffnung hab ich jetzt mittlerweile aufgegeben und hab mir ein MacBook Pro, ein altes, mit Firewire aufgetrieben, das jetzt so als Aufnahmegerät taugt. Und dann habe ich lange nach einer Audio-Software, also die Multi-Track-Recording, und die vernünftig aufnehmen kann, die auch lange Sendungen aufnehmen kann. Wenn ein Garageband, jeder, der Podcasts macht, oder unsere Podcasts, wir kennen ja das Problem hier alle, irgendwann sind die halt einfach voll. Dann stürzt halt, dann nimmt das nichts mehr auf. Weil dann sind dreieinhalb Stunden rum oder sowas und mehr passt in so eine dämliche AIFF-Datei nicht rein und dann ist halt Ende Gelände. Und jetzt hab ich, was ich dafür gefunden habe, ist Reaper. Heißt die Software. Also R-E-A-P-E-R. Ist so eine Software von dem Typen, der halt Winamp gemacht hat. Gibt's für alle Plattformen, gibt's für Windows und für Linux und für Mac. Sieht auch dementsprechend aus. Aber es kann Multitrack-Recording, es kann Markierungen, es kostet in einer Non-Commercial-License, also sie haben eine Lizenz für bis zu 20.000 Dollar Jahresumsatz. Also auch so, dass man ruhig Werbung auf seiner Präsenz haben kann, ohne gleich die Volllizenz kaufen. Die kostet 60 Dollar. Also ich meine, normalerweise kostet so Software 600 Dollar. Das finde ich echt angenehm. Kann MIDI, kann Skriptbar, kann alle möglichen Dateiformate rausschmeißen, kann unglaublich viel. So, das habe ich mir jetzt dann so auf die, die habe ich mir gekauft und nutze das jetzt für die Aufnahme. Und jetzt hätte ich ja genauso wie, für hier, wir müssen reden, und für die Märchenstunde hätte ich ja auch gerne Kapitelmarken. Endlich mal. Und habe aber keinen Bock, die selber zu schreiben während so einer Sendung, weil wenn man die zu zweit macht, dann hat man ja wirklich keine Zeit, was mitzuschreiben. Also habe ich mir überlegt, das könnt ihr euch gerne angucken, das ist unter github.com/343max/reaper minus Marker. Ist noch nicht ganz fertig. Könnt ihr euch gerne beteiligen. Ist so ein Irrg-Bot, mit dem man in Reaper Markierungen setzen kann, und zwar benannte Markierungen. Und die kann ich mir nachhinein wieder exportieren lassen. Das ist der Teil, den ich noch fertig machen muss, was aber auch wirklich nicht schwer ist. Und dann so eine Chapter-Mark, Kapiteldatei für Aphonic daraus zu generieren, was auch im Wesentlichen, Zeitangaben, Leerzeichen, Namen des Kapitels sind. Und das Ganze dann direkt mit auf die Dropbox zu packen, damit sie sich das dann rausholen können. Das wird hoffentlich toll werden. Und wenn nicht, dann muss es weggeschmissen werden, dann kommt was Neues her. Aber das ist eigentlich so ganz schick. Und das ist echt, dann kann man per Chat, kann man im Chat irgendwie eingeben, Marker. Und dann wird direkt in meine Audio-Software ein Marker gesetzt. Das sieht immer wieder so ein bisschen aus wie Magie. Wenn man sich das mal anguckt. Magie? Magie, genau. Achso, da kann ich ja auch noch den Chat zum...
Ich kann ja auch einfach...
Mir fällt jetzt gerade auf, dass ich ja auch endlich auf meinem MacBook, was ich ja auch noch hier rumstehen habe, wo ich auch mit der Tastatur klarkomme. Ich kann nämlich keine deutsche Tastatur mehr. Das ist echt krass. Wie schnell man sich das abgewöhnt. Na, passiert was? Ja, es passiert was. Ja, ist Tim noch da? Tim ist noch da.
Ich bin noch da, ja, ja. Ich weiß ja immer nicht, ob ich gehört werde, aber ich kann versuchen, meinen Beitrag zu leisten auf Zuruf.
Ich glaube, es gibt, weil hier gerade so, wäre schon 200 Euro für einen Thunderbolt-of-Fireware-Adapter ausgelieft. Also einen 100er würde ich da problemlos für lassen. 150 wahrscheinlich auch noch. Es gibt wirklich gar nichts. Die einzige Option, die man zurzeit hat, an so einem MacBook Air mit Thunderbolt-Fireware dran zu kriegen, ist eine sehr fantastische Möglichkeit, aber auch sehr teuer, nämlich so ein Thunderbolt-Display. Da kommt auch Fireware raus. Aber ansonsten... Ja, man könnte sich natürlich noch einfach aus dem Thunderbolt-Display hinten das Motherboard rausholen und das dann alleine nehmen.
Ich frage mich ja ernsthaft, was der Grund dafür ist. Ich könnte mir zwei verschiedene Gründe vorstellen, das erste ist, dass diese erste Generation Chips, die Intel geliefert hat, einfach zu teuer sind. Oder keine Ahnung. Zu viel Strom werden sie wahrscheinlich nicht ziehen, sonst wären sie sicherlich nicht in einem MacBook Air eingebaut. Aber mir scheint da irgendwas Nennenswertes zu fehlen. Dass das alle nicht verwenden. Weil alle, die am Anfang angekündigt haben, oh ja, hier ist Thunderbolt super, wir sind dabei. Wir hatten ja über verschiedene Kandidaten da gesprochen, die schon letztes Jahr gleich danach eine Ankündigung gemacht haben. Die haben jetzt alle vor ein paar Monaten gesagt, nö, das ist jetzt alles im Herbst. Und im Herbst will ja Intel mit neuer Thunderbolt-Chip-Technik rauskommen. Und ich vermute mal, wir sind die Spex davon jetzt nicht bekannt, aber ich vermute mal, dass da irgendwas ganz Signifikantes dabei ist. Und das könnte halt die größte Preis, irgendwie sowas in dieser Größenordnung sein.
Der Preis soll deutlich günstiger sein wollen.
Die haben wahrscheinlich alle gesagt, für das Geld kriegen wir unsere Produkte nicht verkauft. Ich meine, wenn schon ein Kabel, die zusätzliche Elektronik brauchen, dann 50 Euro kostet für einen anderthalb Meter. Da ist man so wieder bei diesen Balldynamikpreisen. Aber das ist halt irgendwie alles nicht zu vertragen. Ich brauche auch unbedingt Thunderbolt of Fire und für ein paar Experimente. Und vor allem nach wie vor Gigabit Ethernet hätte ich gerne.
Und dann könnten sie auch gleich die richtig fette Grafikkarte ins Display mit einbauen.
Ja, das wird ja sowieso noch ein Spaß.
Dann könnten sie sich den diskreten Chip auf den MacBook Pros sparen, theoretisch.
Achso, dann brauchst du ein externes Display, um vernünftige 3D-Grafik zu haben.
Ja, wenn du da ein riesen Display dran hast, dann willst du auch die Grafik, dann hast du auch deine Karte gleich da. Dann können sie auch eine reinbauen, die richtig fett von mir aus ordentlich powert, wo der Lüfter hinter dem Display angeht, ist mir dann egal. Aber du schleppst halt nicht so einen riesen Klopper mit dir rum, der dann auch den Strom wegfrisst.
Kannst du Bitcoins auf deinem Display rechnen?
Zum Beispiel. Dann gibt es noch wahrscheinlich die Firmen, die mein Display rechnen lässt, solange ich nicht da bin.
Ein eigenes Betriebssystem. Ein kleines Linux auf deinem Display.
Genau, ich sag net, hat's ja eh auch. Genau, mit Audio, wie einer schon im Chat meint, ist es ja auch so. Ich könnte mir das schon gut vorstellen. Und dann können sie halt das MacBook Pro ein bisschen ausdünnen und dann wirklich R nennen. Die Zukunft wird's uns zeigen.
Ja, wann kommt eigentlich mal ein MacBook Pro hier mit? MacBook Pro R. Mit Retina Display.
Also eigentlich ist doch nur noch die Frage, ob's R Pro oder Pro R heißt. Oder alles andere ist doch eigentlich klar. Es wird schmaler, es wird spitzer, das optische Laufwerk fliegt raus. Und jada, jada, jada, da hatten wir das schon.
Weißt du nicht, dass es R irgendwann mal rausfallen lässt?
Ja, ich denk schon. Und wenn wir schon mal dabei sind, ich hab hier gerade sicherheitshalber nochmal die Preise gegoogelt. Ja, mir ist das ja so ein bisschen entgangen. Aber irgendwie vor so einem Monat, ich weiß nicht, was passiert ist, aber die SSD-Preise sind ganz schön ordentlich gefallen. Also die SSD, die ich jetzt bei mir drin hab, ich hab vor einem Jahr noch irgendwie 500 Euro bezahlt, kostet jetzt noch 300 hier so. Und ich hab wirklich bei 250 Gig, ich hab bei Hardware-Shot immer geguckt, weil da gibt's ja so schöne Grafen, wie so der Preis wieder so langsam sinkt. Aber er ist nicht langsam gesunken, sondern er hat vor so einem Monat plopp gemacht und ist um 100 Euro gefallen. Also irgendwas war da gewesen. Also das heißt, wenn jemand noch überlegt, dass ihm SSDs zu teuer sind und so, ist vielleicht jetzt der richtige Moment doch nochmal nachzugucken.
Insbesondere weil Festplatten gerade mal wieder relativ teuer sind.
Eigentlich schon, eigentlich müssten die SSD-Hersteller jetzt ja sagen, naja, wenn die da gerade so viel bezahlen, dann haben wir ja, unsere Konkurrenz ist ja so gut wie nicht vorhanden. Und dann können wir ja die Preise noch schön lange oben halten, aber nee, irgendwas ist passiert.
Ja, vielleicht ist inzwischen auch irgendwie das Wasser abgepumpt da in dieser Festplatten-Fabrik.
Nee, Festplattenpreise sind schon auch immer noch ganz schön oben, also...
Ja, das würde das auch gerade bewirkt haben. Dadurch, dass die Festplatten jetzt so teuer sind, haben sich wahrscheinlich viele gesagt, dann nehme ich doch gleich SSD.
Könnte sein, ja.
Da steigt halt die Nachfrage.
Ja, aber Nachfrage erhöht doch den Preis und senkt den ja nicht nur.
Naja, aber dadurch steigt dann irgendwann hoffentlich die Produktion und dann können sie Kapazitäten oder was?
Das könnte dem SSD-Markt nochmal so einen kleinen Kick gegeben haben. Ja, welches SSD aktuell fragt jemand? Oder empfehlenswert, empfehlenswert, ja. Ich glaube, es würde zu weit führen. Weil sie ja alle Marken auflisten. Das kann man nicht so sagen.
Irgendeine Presseerklärung? Hat die jetzt hier gerade?
Na, Presseerklärung ist ja immer so.
2012 CES. Das Gleiche haben die wahrscheinlich auch schon hier. Belkin Zanderbolt ExpressDoc für 299 Dollar. Ja, sie haben es vorgeführt. Das heißt aber nicht Preview. Das kann man auch nicht kaufen. Nicht mal für 299 Dollar. Und ich glaube, das Gleiche haben die von dem Jahr auch schon vorgeführt.
Ja, und das müsste auch schon echt ordentlich viel mehr haben als das, was in so einem Zanderbolt-Display drin ist. Sonst kann ich mir gleich so ein Display kaufen, oder?
Das waren aber ungefähr die Sachen, die auch am Thunderbolt drin sind.
Ja, aber dann hau ich den Rest auch noch drauf, hol mir das dicke Display. Okay, kommt doch an, wenn man es dann mit sich rumschleppen will, oder irgendwie so dann natürlich, okay. Aber ansonsten würde ich eher das Display bevorzugen, würde mein altes Display verkaufen, hab gleichzeitig noch einen Stromstecker mit dran.
Also das Display ist schon geil. Das macht viel Spaß. Ja, aber das ist halt scheiße. Ja, genau. September 2012, da kommen sie alle. Da haben sie alle gesagt. Und da gibt es auch die nächste Intel, Thunderbolt-Jet-Sorts-Generation.
Naja, hat nicht Intel auch gesagt, da kommt denn was? Und auch mit Glasfaser und so weiter. Vielleicht wollen sie ja gleich den PC-Markt mit abgreifen. Die wollen halt nicht nur für den Mac-Markt produzieren, weil sie wissen, die Stückzahlen gehen dann doch immer noch im PC-Markt weg. Und dass dann auch endlich Intel oder die PC-Hardware-Hersteller dann mal Thunderbolt einführen, aber vielleicht dann doch eben mit, ich glaube ja nicht, dass sie der Glasfaser oder Glasdisk sind. Das sind ja Plastikkabel, die die wahrscheinlich benutzen. Das reicht ja auf der kurzen Strecke. Aber dass sie halt sowas benutzen, vielleicht, dass sie halt beides anbieten können oder so. Oder vielleicht gibt es dann so optisch und, wahrscheinlich direkt...
Glasfaser spielt erstmal überhaupt keine Rolle, weil du hast auf dem Glasfaser da kein Power.
Ja, dein Belkin braucht bestimmt auch Power oder nicht? Ja, ich sehe das ein. Ich könnte mir ja jedenfalls gut vorstellen, dass die Hersteller den abwarten, was da auf den PC mal kommt oder dass da noch ein bisschen was anderes ist und sie gleich beide Märkte auf einmal bedienen wollen mit ihren Geräten, was ja Sinn macht aus deren Sicht.
Vielleicht will Intel auch flächendeckend Chipsetze ausrollen, die dann mal Thunderbolt können und dann bringen alle PC-Hersteller Thunderbolt und dann sieht die Sache vielleicht dann auch schon ganz anders aus.
Ja, das ist ja zu begrüßen. Also ich meine, dann werden ja auch die Preise billiger, nicht nur bei uns. Also auf der Mac-Seite, sondern insgesamt.
Ich weiß nicht, hat denn dieser PC-Markt die Transition zu USB eigentlich schon abgeschlossen oder sind die da noch dabei?
Ja, die denke ich schon.
Die haben den kurzen Umweg über Esata genommen, aber sind jetzt...
Also ich meine, die Tastaturen, die beiden runden Stecker, grün und lila, sind immer noch da. Aber ansonsten sind die schon alles komplett USB.
Also das letzte PC-Bord, was ich gekauft habe, das hatte, glaube ich, keinen Drucker-Port mehr, aber immerhin noch einen sehr gelben.
Also ehrlich gesagt, ich glaube nicht, dass der PC-Markt für die Thunderbolt-Manufacturer irgendeine Rolle spielt derzeit. Also jeder, der...
Weg warst du wieder?
Naja, aber ich meine, für Notebooks ist das schon interessant. Also auch für PC-Notebooks.
Bei dir geht gerade gar nicht.
Wenn Tim rannt, wird die Verbindung immer schlechter. Was ist das für ein Zufall?
Naja, wir werden es ja sehen, wenn die im Herbst mit ihren Geräten rauskommen.
Ja, aber ich bin mal sehr gespannt, wie das alles wird. Und dafür gibt es auf dem Mac keinen USB 3. Weil ich auch nicht weiß, was da am Augenblick schon kann. Ich hab jetzt einen USB-Stick, der auch USB 3 kann. Das ist jetzt so mein erstes USB 3-Gerät. Ich hab aber gar nicht schneller an meinem MacBook. Lügen da eh nur rum.
Tim, noch da?
Tim hat auch nichts mehr zu sagen?
Na gut, dann haben wir da noch was.
So richtig nicht, oder? Fällt noch jemand was ein?
Roddy kann noch kurz auf seinen Chain of Fools Video erzählen. Steht zumindest auf der Liste.
Stimmt, das steht auf der Liste. Ja, mir hat jemand ein Video empfohlen, das heißt Chain of Fools, wer es mal googeln will, wo jemand irgendwie ein DOS installiert und dann anfängt sämtliche Windows-Versionen, die es so gibt, als Update drauf zu installieren und guckt hinterher, was denn so alles noch funktioniert und welche Sachen übernommen wurden. Das ist auf jeden Fall mal sehenswert, wenn man irgendwie Wahnsinnige bei der Arbeit zugucken möchte.
Und bei der Windows-8-Installation scheitert es dann?
Ich glaube, er kommt nur bis Windows 7, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Ja, aber das ist echt alt. Was ich noch mal sagen kann, wir hatten ja hier mal diese Mr. Daisy und die Apple Factory Story.
Mike Daisy.
Genau.
Der heißt Mike.
Ja, stimmt. Da steht auch, dass er Mike Daisy heißt. Dieses American-Life-Ding. Hat es ja auch schön durch die Presse geschafft, dass seine Geschichte größtenteils erfunden war. Freierfunden war, was natürlich ziemlich scheiße ist. Wobei die haben noch mal dann daraus eine komplette, die habe ich mir auch angehört, Entschuldigungssendung gemacht. Bei This American Life haben noch mal alles aufgezählt, was denn genau falsch war, wie es in Wirklichkeit war. Und was sich da so abgespielt hat, haben auch mit ihm noch mal ein Interview, was tatsächlich, also es ist kein Interview, man hört im Wesentlichen einen sehr wortkargen Menschen, wie er zwischendurch mal verzweifelt, probiert sich ein bisschen zu verteidigen, aber eigentlich weiß, dass das nicht geht. Was auf jeden Fall das Wesentliche aus der Geschichte ist, also ich meine, inhaltlich hat er jetzt nicht wirklich viel erfunden. Also es gab schon Kinderarbeit in Apple-Fabriken nachgewiesen. Und es gab auch, dass sich Leute dabei wirklich schlimm verletzt haben. Er hat allerdings immer den Eindruck erweckt, als ob er die alle getroffen hätte und als ob es total unproblematisch wäre. Ja, ja, Kinderarbeit ist offiziell verboten, aber hey, guck mal, man muss nur mal kurz auf die Straße gehen und schon ist da jemand. Und das ist schlicht und ergreifend nicht der Fall. Er hat niemanden getroffen, also keine Kinder, die da arbeiten. Es hat von dem, was er erzählt hat, auch wirklich viel nicht gestimmt.
Er kann auch nicht an den Orten gewesen sein, weil wohl die Abstände viel zu groß sind, als dass er in dieser kurzen Zeit so viele Orte, die tausende Kilometer voneinander entfernt liegen, besucht hätte und so weiter. Da hakt und quietscht an allen Ecken und Enden seine Story.
Na, auch so Sachen wie er hat gesagt, dass da irgendwo bewaffnete Leute an den Werkstoren von Foxconn rumgestanden hätten. Was nicht der Fall ist in China. Da hat nur das Militär und vielleicht die Polizei Waffen, aber ansonsten hat da niemand Waffen.
In Amerika wärs ja nicht ungewöhnlich.
In Amerika wärs ja nicht ungewöhnlich. Also insofern Amerikaner wär das wahrscheinlich gar nicht aufgefallen. Und diese ganzen Sachen, was er noch erzählt hat, dass in den Schlafsälen der Foxconn-Mitarbeiter, in den Schlafräuben, dass da Überwachungskameras drin wären, die die ganze Zeit überwachen werden, das ist auch nicht der Fall. Also es sind auf den Fluren Überwachungskameras, aber ich finde, das ist ein großer Unterschied, ob im Schlafsaal oder im Schlafraum Überwachungskamera drin sind oder generell.
Also, die ganze Geschichte ist von vorne bis hinten erstunken und erlogen. Ich meine, wenn man sich diese Retraction-Folge anhört, dann merkt man, dass einfach fast nichts mehr übrig bleibt von dem, was er da gesagt hat. Das Einzige, was irgendwie gestimmt hat, ist, dass er da war und dass er vor Foxconn stand und schon ab der ersten Schilderung mit irgendwie, sie tragen alle Waffen, ist eigentlich alles falsch.
Genau.
Bis hin zu wirklich komplett herbeigeredeten Sachen. Er meint ja auch, dass er mit Leuten gesprochen hat, die da irgendwie vergiftet worden seien. Das stimmt einfach alles gar nicht. Oder dieser Typ da mit der klauen Hand, der da angeblich iPads fertigt. Das ist einfach alles falsch. Und das Problem ist, dass viele Leute da immer noch das glauben. Es gibt da auch irgendwie so eine fette Petition auf change.org, wo irgendwie eine Viertelmillion Leute da irgendwie auf Apple einschreien, etc. Und die berufen sich halt auf diese Sendung. Und das Schlimmste ist, dass er eben auch seine Theater-Show bis heute nicht abgesetzt hat.
Genau, der turnt noch rum.
Der turnt rum und erzählt im Wesentlichen die gleiche Geschichte.
Und hofft darauf, dass das niemand mitbekommen hat. Also das ist schon...
Aber der Typ ist jetzt auch verbrannt, also ich meine.
Ja, aber derlei Themen werden noch mehr kommen. Also ich meine, es ist ja schon jetzt schon auffällig, auch beim iPad, wie es jetzt überall hochgekocht hat, dass der Akku zu warm wird, dass er noch lädt, wenn er voll ist.
Na ja, jetzt kriegt halt Apple richtig Kloppe, wo sie früher mal sagen, womit Apple überall durchkommt, weil da guckt halt keiner hin. Inzwischen ist es halt nicht mehr so. Inzwischen kriegt Apple begründet oder unbegründet das Ganze egal, kriegt einfach immer auf den Deckel, irgendwas muss halt sein, weil sonst gibt es ja auch nichts zu berichten. Und dann ist es halt zu warm, ist zu gelb und alles sowas. Und Antennagate und also wie gesagt, berechtigt.
Na ja, aber das ist doch immer das Gleiche. Ich meine, diese ganzen Android, weiß ich nicht, Slabs, die dann nur zwei Stunden halten, da werden sie dann vielleicht auch nicht warm. Aber irgendwie danach ist das Ding tot. Das interessiert halt auch keinen.
Nee, die werden wärmer. Das ist doch, wir hatten das gemacht. Irgendjemand hat ein Video gedreht und hat die Temperatur von diversen Geräten getestet. Und es ist kein, alle sind wärmer geworden als das iPad. Also als das neue iPad. Und das ist auch von diesem Consumer Reports, die auch in ihrem ersten iPad-Review kein Wort von wärmer geschrieben haben, die dann nochmal eine Warnung hinterher geschoben haben vor der unglaublichen Hitze, die entstehen würde. Bis hin zu einem PC-Magazin, der dann genau, da haben wir das den Wired-Link, da müssen wir alle gleich aufmachen. Von irgendeinem PC-Magazin, der das iPad als, wie hat das bezeichnet? Als Penis-Iron. Also als Penis-Bügeleisen wegen der massiven Hitze-Entwicklung etc. bezeichnet hat.
Das iPad als Penis-Bügeleisen? Ja, es ist wirklich Wie benutzt der sein iPad?
Naja, halt auf der sehr sehr heiß.
Wie benutzt du denn damit nicht die?
Ach, das ist so über Hechersiedlisches Piraten-Petikader gelassen. Und das ist es. Nochmal iPad. Ach so, ja und ich hab wahrscheinlich hat im Chat jemand den Link, hoffe ich mal, drauf. Da gab es nämlich jetzt einen schönen Vergleich. Der hat mal geschrieben so, warum das iPad das beste Tablet überhaupt ist. Und zwar, weil diese ganzen Android Tablets so unglaublich scheiße sind. Grube hat das auch verlinkt. Also nicht die Tablet, sondern die Software dafür. Der hatte nochmal, der hat einfach wirklich eine Sammlung von Screenshots. Also die haben Software rausgesucht. Der klang so, als ob er sich wirklich zu viel... Warm und Gelb ist ein schöner Name für Sendung. Was? Und er hat so von größeren amerikanischen Herstellern, jetzt in erster Linie so Medienanbietern, CNN und Konsorten, hat er die Apps runtergeladen, hat jedenfalls Screenshots auf dem iPad und auf dem Android-Tablet gemacht. Das Krasse ist halt, ja, es gibt für die meisten Hersteller, haben Android-Software, aber die nehmen halt ihre Telefonsoftware und skalieren die einfach auf groß. Und es sieht wirklich teilweise erbärmlich aus. Also eine App ist dabei, die nutzt auf so, was haben sie genommen, hier so ein Asus Prime, also so jetzt eines der besseren Tablets mit Android, bestenfalls ein Viertel des Displays aus. Also was wirklich so oben links in der Ecke ist, so ein bisschen Content zu sehen und der Rest des Bildschirms ist einfach schlicht und ergreifend leer. Hat das noch jemand? Nee.
Das ist alles Dreck, diese ganze Android-Tablet-Welt. Das ist alles total nutzloser, überflüssiger Dreck. Die werden nie den Fuß auf den Boden kriegen. Das ist wirklich furchtbar. Die begreifen das auch überhaupt nicht. Das ist alles 16 zu 9-Format. Die haben das überhaupt nicht verstanden, was Apple da vorgelegt hat. Glaublich.
Gibt es denn schon Tablets mit Android 4? Oder sind die alle noch bei 2, 3 oder so?
Na, so eine Handvoll. Das ist halt das große Problem. Das stand auch in dem Artikel drin. Also der war gar nicht irgendwie hämischmachend oder so. Der hat probiert, die besten Seiten von Android rauszuarbeiten. Blieb ihm aber nichts übrig, als zu schreiben, dass es halt doch scheiße ist. Die großen sind halt alle. Also in Amerika sind das dieses Amazon Kindle Fire. Das ist halt auf irgendeinem Android 2 irgendwas. Und dann gibt es noch dieses Nuke Color. Erstaunlicherweise sind die Buchhändler die größten Amazon Tabletverkäufer, was natürlich auch lustig ist. Das ist auch auf Android 2, 3. Und es gibt so ein paar. Hier Asus Eee Prime und oder Super Transformer Prime. Genau. Das ist, das hat schon Android 4. Für dieses Motorola gibt es auch Android 4 und so. Aber wirklich viel ist das noch nicht. Und auf dem Telefon ist es, ich glaube er hat jetzt einen Marktanteil von knapp 5%. Das finde ich echt krass. Da gab es auch so eine Statistik, dass iOS 5.1 nach zwei Tagen einen höheren Marktanteil hatte, als Android 4 nach einem halben Jahr. Und nach 14 Tagen einen höheren Marktanteil als jedes Android überhaupt. Also selbst Android, Gingerbread, irgendwas, was jetzt anderthalb Jahre alt ist. Und neuere Kandidaten haben nicht so eine hohe Verbreitung wie iOS 5.1 jetzt hat. Und das ist als Entwickler echt geil. Man kann jetzt schon sagen, ich will nur für iOS 5.1...
Finger hoch, wer wirklich überrascht ist.
Überrascht nicht, aber es ist schon... Dass das Tempo... Apple immer noch schneller wird bei der Installation dieses Betriebssystems und dieses Tempo nicht... Also dass das nicht sinkt, was man ja erwarten würde, wenn mehr Leute die ältere Hardware haben und...
Jetzt gibt es ja Update-Over-Seher, ne? Hat halt gedauert, aber...
Aber das war bei Android doch Stunde Null Feature.
Ja, haben sie auch die ganze Zeit mit angegeben, dass sie das schon können.
Was nützt denn das Update, wenn es da ist?
Aber es ist wirklich so, dass es für iOS-Entwickler nicht mehr lohnt, ein 5.0 zu targetten, weil es da draußen kaum noch 5.0 gibt.
Also 5.0 ist wirklich raus. Das hat im 0,0%-Bereich. Es gibt noch ein paar Leute, die auf 4.0 sind. Das sind wahrscheinlich die, die ihr Telefon niemals an iTunes anstecken. Ich meine, die wird es auch weiterhin geben, die wahrscheinlich gar keinen WLAN haben, sondern die die ganze Zeit nur über UMTS surfen und irgendwie einen billigen Vertrag haben. Aber der ganze Rest hat immer das neueste Betriebssystem drauf. Und das ist so als Entwickler einfach geil.
Tim? Ja, ich meine mal ehrlich. Die kriegen da keinen Fuß auf den Boden, in diesem Tablet-Markt. Und zwar aus ganz vielen Gründen. Erstens taugen diese ganzen Geräte nicht. Es gibt keine ordentliche Infrastruktur. Mit diesen tausend Märkten, wo du irgendwas kaufen oder nicht kaufen kannst, das ist ein totales Desaster. Ich frag da mal die Developer, die kotzen alle voll ab, was sie für einen Stress haben, diese ganzen Märkte zu unterstützen, weil du musst da überall drin sein, überall updaten, überall irgendwie gucken, dass du da keine Copycats mit drin hast. Das ist undurchführbar. Das kostet so viel Geld. Dann ist die Plattform auch noch scheiße verbreitet. Keine nennenswerte Update-Strategie, die in irgendeiner Form dazu führen wird, dass diese Geräte mal da sind. Dann musst du dich immer noch mit unterschiedlichen 3D-Steinen rumschlagen, etc., Und das wird einfach nichts. Abgesehen davon, dass sie einfach im Gegensatz zu diesem Telefonmarkt, wo sie einfach über die Provider reingehen, und ja im Wesentlichen auch ein Produkt bauen für die Provider und nicht ein Produkt für die Leute, die diese Telefone benutzen, dass sie in diesem Tabletmarkt einfach keinerlei nennenswerte Retail-Strategie haben, außer vielleicht billig, billig, billig. Und Apple ist an der Stelle mit seinen Stores und auch mit seiner sonstigen Verkaufsinfrastruktur weit vorne, weil du verkaufst halt so ein Tablet im Wesentlichen so, wie du bis vor kurzem noch ein Konsumer-PC verkauft hast. Und das ist das, was die Leute wollen. Es gibt ganz andere Incentives, zu einem iPad zu greifen, als zu einem Telefon. Ein Telefon ist so, dass das hat man in der Tasche und irgendwann ist der Vertrag abgelaufen. Dann denkst du dir, hol ich mir mal ein neues. Dann gehen die Leute in den Laden rein und sagen, was heißt das denn? Sie haben ja entweder ein iPhone, das läuft aber nicht auf ihrem Netz. Oder dann haben wir hier noch ein blaues, ein grünes und ein pinkes. Und dann sagen die, ah, dann nehme ich doch das pinke. Da ist dann halt Android drauf, das wissen die aber gar nicht. Und die installieren da vielleicht mal ihre Twitter ab, aber ansonsten läuft da halt nicht viel. Der einzige Grund, dass Android so schnell in den Markt reingekommen ist, dass es die ganzen anderen Anbieter, die nicht Apple sind, einfach nichts gebracht haben. Ich meine, RIM ist einfach mal quasi, kann man sich schon mal darauf einstellen, dass diese Firma in drei Jahren nur noch in der Nachlassverwaltung gegeben wird. Die Chancen von Microsoft sind mir derzeit da noch nicht so ganz klar, aber so richtig golden und rosig sieht es auch nicht aus. Meine nächsten Quartalzahlen von Nokia werden definitiv wieder furchtbar sein. Und ansonsten wer ist noch da? Sonst ist da keiner. Aber Android hat diese Lücke wunderbar gefüllt, dass sie die Nachfolger der Feature Phones geliefert haben. Die so ein bisschen ein paar Sachen haben. Sie nennen es als Smartphone, aber für die Kunden ist es im Wesentlichen immer noch ein Feature Phone. Und dann gibt es noch diese andere Produktkategorie, das ist halt iPhone. Und das ist das, wo die Leute eben in zunehmendem Maße hängen bleiben. Weil Leute, die irgendwann mal ein iPhone gekauft haben, die werden mit einer sehr hohen Wahrscheinlichkeit, zumindest sieht es derzeit so aus, dabei bleiben. Aber dass dieselbe kundentreue Android vorhanden ist, das sehe ich halt nicht unbedingt. Und bei den Tablets ist es halt einfach eine Folkatastrophe. Ich meine, er hat schon diesen Artikel erwähnt mit dem Vergleich, wie die Upstar irgendwie aussehen.
Oder? Ich hab aber den Link jetzt normalerweise noch nicht.
Mich interessiert, mich erinnert diese Android-Fragmentierung immer so ein bisschen an diesen Disney-Film mit dem Zauberlehrling, der irgendwann die Axt nimmt und diesen Besen, der die Eimer transportiert, in zwei hackt. Fantasia, hab ich bis heute nicht gesehen. Genau, es werden immer mehr, es werden immer mehr. Und er verliert zunehmend die Kontrolle über diese bekloppten Besen, die Wasser schleppen. So ein bisschen wirkt dieser Android-Markt.
Das ist ja wirklich so ein bisschen, wenn man sich in letzter Zeit mal umgehört hat, gibt es doch einige Entwickler für Android, die der Plattform gerade, also ich meine natürlich gibt es auch immer wieder neue Software, etc. und neue Leute, die aufsteigen. Aber wie ist dieses Spiel, die jetzt die Unterstützung eingestellt haben, kurzerhand für Android, weiß ich, einfach nicht lohnt? Ja, also da gab es auch einen schönen Heiseartikel drüber, dass für Android-Entwickler ist die Fragmentierung das Hauptproblem. Und das muss Google in den Griff kriegen. Ansonsten wird es dafür einfach keine große App-Auswahl geben. Keine spannende.
Die einzige Möglichkeit, wie sie das in den Griff kriegen können, ist, dass sie ihren schlechten Einkauf Motorola zu so etwas Ähnlichem umbauen, wie das Microsoft mit Nokia macht oder im Idealfall so wie Apple das macht, dass sie quasi alles aus einer Hand machen. Nur dann sind sie eben mit ihren ganzen anderen Partnern, auf die sie derzeit bauen, los und stehen in direkten Qualitätswettbewerb. Und den sehe ich einfach nicht, dass sie den gewinnen können. Guck dir mal Google-Software an. Google Earth. Wie viele Jahre ist das jetzt schon auf dem Markt? Das User-Interface ist immer noch zu kotzen. Also wie man vor allem mit so wenig User-Interface einen schon so sehr nerven kann, das finde ich wirklich faszinierend. Unglaublich. Und auch ihre Webseiten-Initiative. Na ja, okay, gut so. Das ist jetzt ein bisschen hübscher geworden vielleicht. Aber sie kriegen es ja noch nicht mal hin, da so Updates auszurollen, die dann auch wirklich umfangreich sind. Google Groups ist jetzt so ein Hybrid aus zwei User-Interfaces. Das meiste ist irgendwie neu. Aber wenn du dann mal einen neuen Mailing-Listen-Member hinzufügst, dann schalten sie auf das andere User-Interface. Also auf das alte. Völlig bekloppt. Die haben da einfach keine Qualitätskontrolle.
Aber ich muss ja mal sagen, ich habe jetzt mal iPhoto ausprobiert auf dem iPad und auf dem iPhone. Hab es mir doch geleistet. Und da habe ich auch schon von Apple bessere Software gesehen. Also ich finde iPhoto ziemlich misslungen. Insbesondere den Updating-Fotolibrary-Dialog. Also so ein hässlicher Dialog mit Fortschrittsbalken unten dran. Wo er irgendwas macht, ich habe keine Ahnung was, den sieht man doch sehr, sehr häufig. Und ja, iPhoto nicht toll.
Ist das der gleiche Foto-Library-Updating-Dialog, den man ständig bei Aperture sieht?
Ich habe keinen Aperture. Das ist so ein Standard-UI-Alert-View-Dialog, außer, dass unten ein Progress Bar drin ist. Also wirklich sehr, also selbst, ich glaube, der würde durch die Apple Usability Guidelines nicht durchkommen, dieser Dialog.
Jaja, dann ist er das.
Aktualisiere Mediathek, äh, Library heißt das, ich habe das Thema auf Englisch eingestellt.
Mediathek ist auch so ein schöner Name. Das klingt so nach 80ern.
Und ich finde es nicht wirklich gut bedienbar. Also ich habe wirklich lange gebraucht, bis ich rausgekriegt habe, dass man diese Zoom-Loupe hat, wie man die hat und ich habe sie dann auch, ich hatte sie dann gemacht, daran scheitern sie echt alle. Daran, äh, so komplexere Gesten, die ein bisschen komplizierter sind, als reines mit einem Fingerwischen. Und bei iPhoto muss man halt irgendwie mit zwei Fingern so ein bisschen aufziehen. Aber dann zoomt er, sondern musst du irgendwie noch anders aufziehen, um das wegzukriegen. Das ist echt kein Spaß. Das war, ähm, also das ist, ähm, könnte ruhig noch besser werden. Genau, Updating Photolibrary, da haben wir es doch. Und der kommt ständig, der kommt quasi jedes zweite Mal, wenn du diese App startest. Ich hab keine Ahnung, was der die ganze Zeit übertreibt. Ich mach die Kamera roll auf, hey, kein Updating Photolibrary. Wollen wir es hier lassen? Oder habt ihr noch Lust weiterzumachen?
Ich bin fertig.
Dennis, ist es durch?
Ich hab auch keine weiteren Themen. Mir gehen auch die Firmen, die ich nieder machen kann, aus.
In welcher Reihenfolge? Gehen die erst runter und du machst sie nieder? Oder machst du sie nieder und dann gehen sie runter?
Das hängt alles irgendwie zusammen.
Er tritt nach, wenn die sowieso vom Berg rollen.
Dann würde ich sagen...
Mal gucken, was die Hörer sich beschweren bei dem...
Beim nächsten Mal nicht mit Kleine Haken, Tim. Kann ich das dann gleich auf Phonik hochladen, dass die das dann ein bisschen aufarbeiten? So, mal gucken, ob deine Tonspiele überhaupt drauf ist. Jutti, dann würde ich sagen, haben wir's und...
Genau.
Machen's bis zum nächsten Mal.
Du hast mir das Outro nicht zugeschickt, darum kann ich's jetzt nicht spielen.